Was soll das heißen? Du hast nur brave Bücher geschrieben über Kapitalismus.
Ja, ich vermute, dass das Problem bei mir auch ist, dass ich nicht nur Bücher
geschrieben habe, sondern auch welche gelesen habe.
Das disqualifiziert mich, glaube ich, für Kultursendungen im Fernsehen.
So scheint es mir immer mehr zu sein. Ich finde das wirklich absurd,
also man muss das ja ein bisschen den Leuten, die da nicht so im Bilde sind, erklären.
Titelthesen Temperamente kennt jeder ist diese ARD Kultur Sendung,
wurde 17 Jahre lang von Max Mohr moderiert und der war früher auch schon in
Dreisatz und sonst wo zu sehen.
Jetzt geht er in Rente. Nun suchte man einen neuen Moderator und hat sich für
Thilo Mischke entschieden,
der eher für so Reportagen bekannt ist, der also mit Kultur überhaupt nichts am Hut sonst hat.
Er hat sich vorgestellt in einem kurzen Video und sagt, ich bin der Sohn von
Buchhändlern und ich will euch mal meinen Kulturbegriff erklären.
Und der ist, Kultur soll für alle da sein. Das ist ja noch kein Kulturbegriff.
Doch.
Sondern das ist ja einfach nur eine Aussage der Zugänglichkeit,
aber nicht, was dann für ihn Kultur meint.
Aber es ist schon an sich albern, dass man so einen 45-jährigen Berufsjugendlichen,
der nichts damit zu schaffen hatte, mit der Hochkultur plötzlich an so eine
exponierte Stelle setzt.
Hinzu kommt, dass er noch einen TTT-Podcast dann macht mit Jule Lobo,
von der ich auch nichts weiß, außer dass sie einen bekannten Mann geheiratet hat.
Vielleicht ist das aber als Lebensleistung auch schon genug.
Und dann gibt es eben jetzt nicht nur, oder es gibt eigentlich kaum Kritik daran,
dass man nun Leute da hinsetzt, die mit Kultur, naja, also man wird mich ja
vielleicht auch nicht nehmen.
Um Fußballspiele zu kommentieren, sage ich mal.
Und nun hat man aber vor allem eine große Debatte darum,
ist Thilo Mischke eine falsche Besetzung, weil er durch sehr merkwürdige Äußerungen
in den letzten Jahrzehnten aufgefallen ist.
Vor allem hat er ein Buch geschrieben, das den unfeinen Titel trägt, In 80 Frauen um die Welt.
Und die Passagen, die daraus zitiert werden, sind ähnlich unfein wie dieser Titel.
Und dann gibt es noch irgendwelche Podcast-Aussagen zu einem sehr eigenartigen
Evolutionsverständnis in Bezug auf Vergewaltigung, Männer und Frauen.
Ich will das hier alles nicht wiedergeben, ich habe es auch nur am Rande rezipiert,
kann aber sagen, ja, das ist alles höchst bedenklich.
Ich habe Thilo Mischke nicht gekannt und war aber die letzten Tage sehr amüsiert.
Es gibt diesen einen Podcast, den habe ich auch in einer Story verpackt. Weißt du, wie der heißt?
Feministische Shelf, irgendwas. Ich verlinke es, ich suche es raus.
Und es wird jetzt so kritisiert, wie er über Frauen spricht.
Und ich finde, das stimmt.
Aber noch schlimmer ist sein Verständnis von sozialer Entwicklung,
sozialer Evolution, Vorgeschichte und so weiter und so fort.
Denn das ist natürlich alles totaler Schrott.
Also es ist wirklich alles totaler Schrott. Ich komme ja dieses Jahr mit einer
neuen Erzählung der Familie und so wie wir sie kennen, der starke Mann raus
in die Welt, kümmert sich um die Frau und so weiter und so fort.
150 Jahre von 300.000 Jahren Menschheitsgeschichte und wir wissen eigentlich ziemlich genau,
wie das vor der Industrialisierung als die Kernfamilie erfunden wurde,
weil man für die Dampfmaschine Fabrikarbeiter brauchte und die Fabrikanten meinten,
soll sich mal die Frau darum kümmern, dass die Kleidung sauber ist,
wenn er morgens zur Arbeit kommt,
und nichts davon, nicht mal in Ansätzen und nicht mal als Poin Arnte,
wie er das verwendet, funktioniert.
Ich will es gar nicht zitieren, was er da sagt, aber das ist unglaublich dumm auch.
Wir leben im 21. Jahrhundert und irgendwelche Leute kommen daher und erzählen
mir was vom Neandertaler, damit der Keule durch die Gegend läuft.
Kann ich damit heutige Phänomene erklären?
Könnte schwierig werden.
Außerdem nur einen inhaltlichen Hinweis. Dieses Buch von ihm heißt In 80 Frauen
um die Welt und nicht Mit 80 Frauen um die Welt. Genauso ist es auch gemeint.
Wenn heute irgendwer kommt und
sagt, aber er hat ja selber unterbunden das nächste Auflagen erschienen.
Ja, wie kann denn ein Verlag und das meine ich jetzt sozusagen ahistorischer.
Wir können natürlich immer sagen, später ist man immer schlauer und vor 20 Jahren
war nicht die Zeit, in der man sich über was auch immer Gedanken gemacht hat.
Stimmt alles, aber das ging auch damals nicht.
Wenn ein Autor mit so einer Idee kommt und der Verlag hat diesen Titel.
Deswegen ist er mir nur eine Erinnerung. Nur deshalb kannte ich den,
weil dieser Titel mir da eine Erinnerung war. Und nee, das war auch nicht vor zehn Jahren anders.
Das ist einfach Unsinn, das zu sagen. Und es geht ja jetzt auch hier nicht darum,
dass irgendwo jemand einen Herrenwitz gemacht hat in einem Fünf-Stunden-Podcast
oder so, sondern da wird ein Buch vollgeschrieben, da gibt es ein Lektorat und
damit macht man dann einen Bestseller.
Naja, also davon aber mal abgesehen, finde ich überhaupt diese Personalentscheidungen,
diese beiden interessant und bestätigen wieder, was ich so denke über Kultur
im öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen.
Es ist wirklich immer nach dem Prinzip Verflachung.
Also es ist, wenn einer geht, dann kann man davon ausgehen, es kommt immer was Schlechteres nach.
Es ist so interessant zu sehen, dass es niemals aufwärts geht.
Ich meine, wir haben jetzt in der Oper Frankfurt einen Generalmusikdirektor,
der am Klavier sitzt und wahnsinnig toll über Opern erzählen kann,
Dinge vorspielt, erklärt.
Gebt ihm die Sendung wegen mir. Ist egal, ob der schon mal von der Kamera sonst
stand oder sonst was, gibt ihm die Sendung, er kann es machen.
Ich dachte jetzt auch dran, wen würde ich da besetzen? Ja, ich würde Leute besetzen,
die jetzt im intellektuellen Leben zu Hause sind.
Für mich wäre jetzt eine Idealbesetzung Nils Schniederjahn und Theresia Enzensberger zusammen oder so.
Also Leute, die tatsächlich mit Kunst und Kultur etwas zu tun haben,
die in intellektuellen Debatten drin sind,
denen müsste man eine solche Sendung geben und da muss man nicht gucken,
wie viel Instagram-Follower jemand hat und dann bekommt man da eine Sendung.
Also es ist sehr eigenartig.
Oder dir, Lars Weißbrot hat dich vorgeschlagen.
Ich habe das geschickt bekommen von dir und von anderen dann auch.
Ich bedanke mich für diesen Vorschlag von Lars Weißbrot, das freut mich,
ehrt mich, aber ich habe ja genug zu tun.
Also ich möchte mich ja keinesfalls bewerben für diese Sendung.
Wolfgang, wenn ein Land ruft, sei froh, dass es nicht zu den Waffen ist.
Dann lieber TTT, das würde ich auch sagen, ja.
Ich will noch eine konstruktive Wende einbauen, denn wir haben ja interessante
Gleichzeitigkeiten, wir haben nachher im Podcast auch noch eine, aber hier jetzt auch.
Jule Lobo hast du schon angesprochen, die steht im Ruf, den Podcast-Titel Thesen,
Temperamente zusammen mit Thilo Mischke zu machen, weil eine Sendung in der
Woche geht ja nicht, man muss ja noch einen Podcast machen.
Und einen Tag bevor das aber alles um Thilo Mischke irgendwie diskutiert wurde,
haben die noch einen Podcast zu El Hotzo gemacht, weil El Hotzo hat ja auf Twitter
eine große Entschuldigungs- und so weiter-Runde gedreht.
Nun wissen wir weder bei Thilo Mischke noch bei El Hotzo oder Sebastian Hotzo,
wie heißt er, keine Ahnung, wie die ihr Privatleben führen.
Ja.
Ich will trotzdem eine Ergänzung zu der sehr guten Diskussion um diese ganzen Thematiken machen,
denn ich finde, bei solchen Themen sollte es auch und das ist vielleicht der
konstruktivste Beitrag, auch wenn das gleich von mir ganz schlimm und ich erwarte
auch schon Kommentare so auf YouTube entsprechend da,
aber wenn man über Männer redet, darf man ruhig öffentlich auch über Männer
reden, wie man über Männer halt so redet und es gehört nun mal zur Natur der
Sache, dass der wahre Gedanke ist zu sagen.
Ich habe Sebastian Hotz mal auf dem Foto gesehen, ein bisschen klein,
ein bisschen dick, aber halt auch sehr berühmt.
Natürlich kommt er aus einer Jugend, wo er immer verschmäht wurde von den Frauen, wie auch immer.
Wie so viele Männer, alle, hat eine mediale Öffentlichkeit, die sich zu seinen Gunsten da ausspielt.
Und da ist eins plus eins dann zwei.
Wenn er sich dafür entschuldigt, dann kann jeder aus seinen eigenen Freundinnen
Geschichten erzählen, dass wahrscheinlich mit, und das ist ja dann die Stefanie Stahl-Logik,
diesen Menschen habe ich noch nie gesehen, aber sein Problem schon tausendmal,
alle fallen in die gleichen Muster irgendwie.
Und jetzt gibt es einen Begriff, den ich gerne verwenden möchte,
um sozusagen vorzuarbeiten, damit es nicht beim nächsten Mal heißt,
aber der hat doch online immer sich so feministisch gezeigt und wie auch immer.
Du hast ja dieses ganz tolle Buch Selbstschuld mit Anker-Christin Plusti geschrieben.
Sie hat vor drei Jahren in der Corona-Zeit ein Buch über Feminismus geschrieben.
Süß. Mit einem spektakulären Kapitel, sanft.
So, und in diesem sanft Kapitel beschreibt sie den Potenz-Feminismus.
Also ich will jetzt zwei Feminismus-Begriffe vorstellen, den einen von Clusty,
den anderen dann von mir.
Clusty sagt, es lohnt sich gar nicht für niemanden, wenn wir jetzt einfach sagen,
die Welt ist, wie sie ist. Und jetzt haben Frauen das Recht,
genauso scheiße zu sein und sich in patriarchalen Hierarchien durchzusetzen
und wir haben mit einer Quote dann auf Augenhöhe Arschlöcher.
Weiblich, also Arschlöcherinnen und Arschlöcher, muss man ja sagen.
So, und sie nennen das Potenzfeminismus. Also die Frauen sozusagen,
Linen, hau dich rein, hier,
melde dich zu Wort, so der CSU-Feminismus, melde dich zu Wort,
egal zu was, die Hauptsache du bist präsent in der Ortsvorstandswahl und so
und dann kommst du irgendwann an Dorothees Platz. So, das ist Potenzfeminismus.
Diesen weiblichen Feminismus, der einfach auf Empowerung läuft und das patriarchale
System dann aber trägt, unterstützt und dann heißt es, ja, ja,
die Top 1%, Männer wie Frauen jetzt gleich scheiße, ist nicht gut.
So, und jetzt gibt es, möchte ich einen zweiten Begriff vorschlagen für diese
El-Hotzo-artige Twitterei zum Thema, ja, ja, hier die Frauen und so.
Das ist Schleimer-Feminismus. und ich finde, wenn jemand öffentlich,
gerade als Mann, so agiert, dann einfach ausblenden.
Also die besten Herangehensweisen sind die von Lensi aus dem Studio Rot Kontext
oder wie heißt Kollektiv Rot?
Studio Rot. Du weißt schon. Sie sagt einfach, also im Feminismus haben Männer
nichts zu suchen. So streng würde ich es nicht sehen.
Nein, nein, das würde ich auch nicht richtig sehen.
Aber Schleimer Feminismus Also Männer, die eine Instakachel produzieren,
die man dann selber nochmal reproduziert im Sinne von, seht hier,
ein Mann sagt das auch, ich habe recht.
Hilft nicht. Also wir brauchen weder Potenzfeminismus noch Schleimerfeminismus.
Also wir brauchen weder Potenzfeminismus, soweit klar, noch El Hotzo zum Thema Feminismus.
Ist immer verdächtig.
Und jetzt muss ich aber nochmal nachfragen. Es ist so, dass also die Lobos nochmal
extra eine Folge aufgenommen haben zu dem Fall El Hotzo.
Und einen Tag später sagt dann Jule Lobo, ich habe mir einen vor allem gewünscht,
um diesen Podcast zu machen und das ist Thilo Mischke.
So ungefähr. Ich weiß nicht genau.
Interessant.
Wie die zeitliche Reihenfolge, aber es ist wirklich ein bisschen interessant.
Ich wünsche der ARD viel Glück. Ich freue mich darauf.
Lass mich noch eine Sache zu diesem Thema. Also es sind alles normale Menschen.
Selbst Elon Musk mit 400 und so weiter Milliarden, das sind alles ganz normale Menschen.
Im sozialen Nahkampf gilt für die, was für alle gilt.
Keiner ist immer super cool, keiner ist immer ein Arschlauch,
Elon Musk sitzt auch nicht da und entwirft die Rakete selbst.
Also niemand ist hier Rocket-Seite.
Elon Musk ist ja nun in seinem Devianten-Verhalten eine besondere Ausnahme.
Aber trotzdem, selbst da steckt noch ein normaler Mensch dahinter.
Ja, das merkt man ja auch immer an der Beschränktheit seiner Tweets oder an
doch seinen eher schlechten Auftritten, die er hinlegt.
Es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass wir einem besonders intelligenten Kopf dazuhören.
Genau.
Aber wir kommen auf ihn heute nochmal zu sprechen.
Also selbst 400 Milliarden, zwischen dem Mikrofon oder der,
schreibenden Handtastatur sieht man das nicht, dass da 400 Milliarden sind.
Also da ist alles ausgeblendet. Da sieht man einfach den rohen Menschen.
Und so ist das grundsätzlich immer auch bei uns. Also wir sind auch ganz verletzliche
Menschen, wenn ihr uns auf der Bühne seht. Wir haben ja wieder Salon gemacht.
Alle waren nett zu uns. Das ist auch für uns schön.
Ja, das ist ja schön. Und wir haben ja über das Menschliche gesprochen und zwar
das Menschelnde auch bei der Gala von der Bild-Zeitung und dem ZDF, Ein Herz für Kinder.
Also wer mal diese ideologische Veranstaltung, die über drei Stunden dauert,
sich zu Gemüte führen will in Kurzform und heruntergedampft auf das,
was es da eigentlich zu besprechen gibt,
kann das dann im Live-Salon nachhören, der ist schon veröffentlicht.
Ich habe, du wirst mich schelten, wie der OMR-Podcast gehört,
aber es wirft halt was ab.
Es wirft wirklich etwas ab. Und zwar.
Die Gäste sind gut dort.
Ja, die Gäste sind interessant und vielleicht ist dieses, sie einfach reden
lassen, gut, zumindest für mich.
Ich kann da sehr gut Material sammeln. Und was mir auffällt bei reichen Leuten,
die erfolgreich sind, also reiche Leute, es gibt ja Leute, die sind einfach
reich und haben sehr viel Geld und sitzen irgendwo dort. Okay.
Aber dann gibt Es gibt ja Leute, die sind im Beruf, verdienen sehr,
sehr, sehr viel, also vier, fünf Millionen oder so im Jahr.
Müssen aber dafür Konzessionen machen, in einer Weise, wie ich sie niemals machen möchte.
Müssen dann Weihnachtskarten schreiben mit Sprüchen drauf.
Nicht nur das. Sie müssen natürlich dann auch, wenn sie in Interviews gefragt
werden, so antworten, dass weiterhin die Geldflüsse offen bleiben.
Das heißt, was man dort beim OMR-Podcast, wenn dort solche großen Leute,
Vorstandsvorsitzungen so vertreten sind, was man da eigentlich erleben kann,
ist uneigentliches Sprechen.
Sie müssen die ganze Zeit so durchlavieren, ich darf ja in die Hand,
die mich füttert, nicht beißen.
Und das ist sehr schön zu beobachten.
Es ist Andreas Wiele zu Gast, der war früher bei Springer, war da im Vorstand
für Anzeigen und Rubriken tätig, hat jetzt auch selbst gegründet, Startup und sowas.
Aber war dann, also waren dort fast 20 Jahre, glaube ich, ist jetzt aber auch
im Vorstand von ProSieben oder im Aufsichtsrat, hat dort also so eine beobachtende Funktion,
kümmert sich also dann nicht um das operative Geschäft, aber ist nach wie vor sehr, sehr wichtig,
war einer der Friede Springer Boys, wie sie damals hießen, neben Matthias Döpfner.
Und jetzt fragt Philipp Westermeyer ihn folgendes.
Und wie war Springer in all den Jahren kulturell? Also ich meine, hat sich viel geändert?
Ich meine, ich frage natürlich auch ein bisschen, weil nachdem du da raus bist,
hat sich ja dann auch, sagen wir mal, öffentlich noch mal einiges materialisiert.
Er stellt das ja sehr offen, ja, aber wir wissen schon, da war ja einiges bei
Springer, ja, wir hatten diese ganzen SMS von Döpfner, wir haben die Affäre
Julian Reichelt und und und.
Und jetzt hören wir mal uns, also er redet jetzt erstmal über die Geschichte
von Springer, die ersten drei Minuten haben wir schon mal rausgenommen und jetzt
geht es mal darum, was, ja, diese Kultur, wie ist die jetzt irgendwie anders?
Also das hat sich im Laufe der vielen Jahre ganz schön geändert,
als ich angefangen habe, im Jahr 2000 war es also der typische hanseatische,
Verlag, Blaue Bläser, goldene Manschettenknöpfe,
Anzug und sehr viel Sie und sehr formal.
Und das haben wir, glaube ich, wirklich sehr stark aufgebrochen und es zu einem
dann auch mit dem Umzug nach Berlin zu einem jungen,
modernen, aber immer noch konservativen Unternehmen gemacht, wo wir versucht haben,
eben die Werte der Offenheit mit traditionellen Werten und auch den starken
Wertbekenntnissen von Axel Springer zu vereinbaren.
Das ist uns, glaube ich, eine Zeit lang super gut gelungen.
Jung, modern, aber konservativ und die Werte von Axel Springer.
Wir würden ja jetzt gerne mehr wissen zu den eigentlichen Skandalen da und nicht,
ob die noch blaue Anzüge mit goldenen Knöpfen tragen.
Er deutet für uns jetzt mal die Figur Springer, Axel Springer.
Ja, es ist halt immer so, dass Axel Springer in der Geschichte auch dann plötzlich
wieder zu einem konservativen und manchmal auch einen rückwärtsgewandten Ruf bekommt,
ohne dass es unbedingt gerechtfertigt ist, weil die Werte bleiben eigentlich immer die gleichen.
Auch Axel Springer war, als er das Unternehmen gegründet hat,
ein unglaublich moderner, vorwärtsdenkender Mensch.
1948 von der Aussöhnung mit Israel zu sprechen und all diesen Dingen,
an die Vereinigung von Europa zu denken, das war nicht so cool,
das war wahnsinnig modern.
Naja, sicherlich durfte er jetzt nicht die Altnazilinie fortsetzen in dem Sinne.
Ja, nur war das quasi damals die Agenda einer konservativen Bundesrepublik,
die Springer dann für die Masse umgesetzt hat und der Masse auch eingeimpft hat.
Also die Bild-Zeitung war da nie progressiv. Man kann sagen,
sie war nicht regressiv in dem Sinne, dass sie jetzt versuchte,
Adenauer von rechts zu überholen.
Das war natürlich nicht der Fall.
Jetzt kommt es zu den 68ern.
Er wurde dann überholt von den 68ern, die halt dann da in vielen Dingen recht
hatten, in vielen Dingen auch übers Ziel hinaus geschossen sind.
Und ich glaube, in einer ähnlichen Phase befindet sich Springer jetzt vielleicht wieder.
Umso wichtiger ist es, dass die Werte, die Springer hochhält,
vor allem eben im Hinblick auf Israel und die Juden, im Hinblick auf die Freiheit
aufrechterhält und auch dabei bleibt.
Auch wenn mancher Zeitgeist im Moment vielleicht in eine andere Richtung weht.
Das ist sozusagen ein bisschen das große Bild.
Hast du den Eindruck, dass hier jemand spricht, der frei ist?
Der frei von der Leber weg reden kann? Nee, haben wir überhaupt nicht.
Das dann innerhalb ist von Axel Springer immer Rumors und Medien,
da gibt es immer viele kleinere und größere Skandale.
Habe ich auch in der Zeit erleben dürfen, als ich selber da war.
Dürfen.
Wenn du jetzt auf Julian Reichelt und so weiter anspielst, Ich habe,
da ich das selber von drinnen in Teilen erlebt habe, anders,
nicht mit dem Julian, traue ich mir da wirklich kein Urteil zu.
Also da ich es von innen erlebt habe, traue ich mir kein Urteil zu.
Das ist alles möglich. Aber zugleich die, die außen stehen, pass auf.
Von außen sollten die Leute alle sehr, sehr vorsichtig sein. Ich weiß nur, was ich...
Denn die sollen sich auch besser kein Urteil zutrauen. Also wenn man drinnen
war nicht und wenn man draußen war auch nicht.
Die ganze Zeit erlebt habe...
Dass der Wunsch nach Aufklärung und nach Gerechtigkeit und nach dem guten Umgang
mit allen, also denjenigen,
die da vielleicht die Opfer sind und denjenigen, die da vielleicht die Täter sind.
Aber nur vielleicht, wir haben ja das Buch von Stuckart-Barre gelesen.
Damit wirklich anständig umzugehen, ist sehr, sehr stark ausgeprägt im Wertekompass
von Springer, vom Vorstand und von Matthias ganz besonders.
Ja, super. Das ist wie als Matthias Döpfner im Pivot-Podcast zu Gast war und
von Scott Galloway verabschiedet wurde als mit, das ist ein Family Man,
so viele Kinder, so eine gute Ehe, das hat man ja noch nie erlebt.
Vorbild für junge Männer. Wiele redet immer noch weiter. Das ist immer noch
die Antwort auf diese eine Frage.
Dass man das von außen nicht immer so sieht, das glaube ich.
Es ist halt einfach nur wirklich sehr, sehr schwer.
Und ich habe das Glück gehabt, als ich 2020 weggegangen bin.
Ich hatte zum Beispiel den Eindruck, es ist relativ einfach,
das zu beurteilen, was da vor sich geht.
Diesen Sachen jetzt auch nur noch von außen erleben zu dürfen,
das ist keine spaßpflichtige Veranstaltung für niemanden da gewesen.
Warst du denn überrascht über die Heftigkeit dieser Welle, die da kam?
Ja und nein. Also natürlich ist Springer auch immer Lieblingsfeind und weil
dort starke Positionen bezogen werden.
Starke Positionen, ja das deshalb. Und jetzt auch interessant zum Thema Täter-Opfer.
Das gehört zum Medienspiel dazu. Natürlich war es schon ganz schön heftig und
für die Betroffenen, für alle Betroffenen.
Und ich kenne fast alle, hat das schon allen wehgetan und ich hoffe,
dass alle da irgendwann auch ihre Wunden geheilt haben und weiter nach vorne
gehen können, was ich glaube jetzt durchaus der Fall ist.
Lass mich kurz nachfragen. Also der Wester-Mann, Wester-Meyer,
stellt ganz offene Fragen.
Man weiß nicht mal genau, geht es jetzt hier um den Zeitpunkt oder die Skandale
um Julian Reichelt's Abgang und so.
Das wird nun mal so angedeutet, genau.
Aber er betont hier, nein, das ist eine ganz große Krise und es wäre alles schlecht.
Aber es geht schon um diese Julian Reichelt-Geschichte.
Genau, und er sagt jetzt einfach, naja, jetzt hoffen wir mal,
dass alle da irgendwie gut rauskommen, so als gäbe es da gar nicht auch Schuldige
bei irgendetwas, sondern generell ist es halt immer dort, wo starke Meinungen sind,
da ist auch Kontroverse, da ist Kritik und da hoffen wir mal, dass es allen gut geht.
Und was ich so interessant finde, ist, wenn man sich ja mit Leuten,
die viel Kapital haben und da ganz oben mitmischen,
beschäftigt, dann kann man ja häufig sehen, dass die gar keine Angst haben,
vor einer unguten Nähe zu leben.
Komischen Leuten zu Rechten zum Beispiel, dass da einfach kein Problem ist,
mit denen irgendwie Geschäfte zu machen, sondern dass man sich auf so einer
Ebene begegnet, wo die Inhalte keine Rolle mehr spielen.
Also wenn wir uns begegnen, dann würden ja inhaltliche Ausrichtungen schon eine
Rolle spielen, ja, aber da geht es eigentlich nur noch darum,
wie kann ich jetzt ein Geschäft da und dort machen, dann ist mir egal, ob du jetzt,
die AfD unterstützt oder nicht, das ist für mich keine Frage mehr, sondern.
Wir auf einer Geschäftspartnerebene kommen wir ja miteinander klar.
Also warum soll ich mich mit irgendwas anderes noch beschäftigen?
Das heißt, diese Werte, die da immer betont werden, sind ja de facto gar nicht
da und das zeigt sich ja genau daran, auch wenn du dir die Privatsenderstrukturen
und sowas ansiehst, wo da überall
das Geld herkommt, dass die da gar keine Hemmungen haben für irgendetwas.
Und das ist jetzt nochmal besonders deutlich. Wir haben jetzt schon gehört,
naja, dann hoffen wir mal, dass alle ohne Wunden da rauskommen.
Dann würde ich sagen, naja, die einen haben ja den anderen auch Wunden zugefügt.
Das ist ja nicht so, als sei das so einfach über alle gekommen wie ein Hagel,
was man sagt, da sind alle Autos ein bisschen kaputt gegangen.
Und jetzt kommt er auf Julian Reichelt noch zu sprechen.
Gerade durch großen Zufall saß ich zwei Reihen und bin Julian Reichelt begegnet
im Flugzeug nach London und da macht er auch wieder einen ganz fidelen Eindruck,
ob ich jetzt alle seine politischen Meinungen teile oder nicht,
das brauchen wir nicht zu kommentieren, aber man kann ja auch sich kennen und
auch über verschiedene politische Überzeugung hinweg befreundet und bekannt sein.
Ich glaube, das ist auch ein ganz wesentlicher Wert, den wir uns alle aufrechterhalten
sollen, keinen Klassenkampf hinzuführen.
Da kommt es ihm noch als Wort, keinen Klassenkampf. Also die Superreichen unter sich,
verstehen sich unabhängig von der jeweiligen politischen Position.
Wenn der eine da einen Fimmel hat und unterstützt gerne die AfD,
naja, dann ist das seine Leidenschaft, der andere geht gern golfen,
aber eigentlich ist das egal, kein Klassenkampf.
Wir, die quasi die Interessen der Reichen vertreten oder selbst die Reichen
sind, wir halten da im Ganzen zusammen und freuen uns, dass der Julian Reichelt
jetzt wieder ganz fidel ist.
Ja, lass mich dazu mal einen Clip spielen, der sozusagen ein bisschen umzusammenhängend
ist, aber ein bisschen aus unserem Metier.
Ich führe kurz aus. meine Vermutung ist und das ist aber große Fragestellung
also es kommen wieder Thesen von Stefan die auf YouTube gerne kommentiert werden dürfen,
der Unterschied von Kapital und Arbeit
ist vielleicht auch so zu verstehen dass Menschen die wissen dass ihr finanzieller
Alltag nicht mit Arbeit zu bestreiten ist also die sozusagen von Kapitalerträgen
leben dass die so eine Art Distanz plötzlich aufbauen Wie du es gerade beschrieben hast.
Also wenn ich vom Kapital lebe und weiß, nee, es kommt jetzt nicht darauf an,
dass ich eine Überstunde mache, sondern dass der Deal am Ende hinhaut.
Es ist sozusagen zielorientiert und nicht, okay, noch 15 Handschläge,
also Handarbeiten, was auch immer und dann habe ich so und so viel Geld.
Dann ist der Stundenzettel voll, ja.
Also man kommt in so eine gewisse Distanz. Wir kennen das ja,
dass man, selbst die Arbeiter entfremden sich von ihrem Produkt,
aber Menschen, die mit Kapital so hantieren, erst recht.
Die leben dann also in so einer eigenen Welt, bei der sie wissen, das ist entkoppelt.
Also hier ist nicht, das entspringt nicht einer intrinsischen Logik,
sondern einer Geldlogik, was hier passiert.
Mein Wohl und Wehe hängt davon ab, dass die Return on Investments entsprechend da sind.
So, Menschen müssen also, und das sieht man ja häufiger in Filmen und umso älter
die Filme sind, umso besser sieht man das.
Menschen bereiten sich unglaublich lange drauf vor, einen Abend durchzuführen.
Also da wird sich eingekleidet, da kommt der Butler nochmal um die Ecke und
dann weiß man, okay, jetzt verlassen wir das Haus, steigen ins Auto und ab dann läuft die Show.
Ja, da muss man abends die Hände schütteln, der Bürgermeister ist da und so
diese typischen, wie man es halt so früher zeigt.
So, und das haben wir ja heute wieder gesehen bei Menschen, die auch so jenseits
ihrer eigenen Arbeit Rendite einfahren, zum Beispiel in der Politik, Christian Lindner. Ja.
Also das ist völlig klar, der Typ ist kompletto rollendistanziert,
dem geht es nur um gewisse Prozente bei einer Bundestagswahl,
so wie es anderen Menschen halt um gewisse Prozente bei Renditen oder Verträgen
oder wie auch immer geht.
So und jetzt haben wir für die, und zwar durch Christian Lindner das eigenes
Zutun seiner Partei, das Wort Schauspielerei.
Ja.
Falsch interpretiert.
Und Ulrich Mattes, wir kennen ihn als Goebbels in der Untergang und Freund von
Angela Merkel, er hat auch irgendwie für sie viel gelesen oder sowas,
keine Ahnung, die treffen sich immer mal,
war also sozusagen im Fokus von Apokalypse und Filterkaffee für ein Gespräch,
das der politische Journalist Markus Feldenkirchen führt, mit einem Gast,
in dem Falle Ulrich Mattes.
So, und Feldenkirchen möchte über die FDP reden und Ulrich Mattes grätscht kurz
dazwischen und reformuliert, was dort pervertiert wurde, muss man so zu sagen, ja?
Kai Wegner, das schäbige Schauspiel des Christian Lindner, darüber schreibt
die Augsburger Allgemeine.
Mir geht es hier nicht unbedingt um den Inhalt dieses Kommentars,
sondern um den Punkt der Schauspielerei in der Politik.
In dem Text heißt es nämlich, Moment, Moment, Moment, schon wieder wird der
Begriff Schauspielerei,
Theater, der Schauspieler, theorativ, ich kann auch sagen, muss kein Fremdwort
verwenden, also negativ besetzt verwendet.
Also quasi Schauspielerei im Sinne von Lügengeschichte, von so tun als ob.
Ich muss da mein Veto einlegen, das könnte er dann auch.
Ich habe noch nicht mal es zu Ende zitiert. Ja, aber da muss ich mein Veto einlegen,
weil es geht ja in der Schauspielerei darum,
dass man zu einem bestimmten Punkt von Wahrhaftigkeit mittels des So-Tun-als-Ob kommt.
Man bemüht sich aber um Wahrhaftigkeit.
Man bemüht sich darum.
Menschenmöglichkeiten, Menschsein darüber auszudrücken, indem man so tut als ob. was ein schöner,
ein jahrtausendealter Vorgang ist, sich eine Maske aufzusetzen und über die
Maskierung zu einer anderen Form der Wahrhaftigkeit zu kommen.
Und jetzt im Zusammenhang mit Lindner und seinem Possenspiel,
ähnlich wie bei Söder, muss ich auch meine Erregung zügeln, wenn der Name Lindner fällt.
Und das, was die da pexiert haben mit der FDP, in irgendeiner Weise mit dem
großen, wunderbaren Beruf des Schauspielers und mit der wunderbaren,
jahrtausalten Institution des Theaters in einem Atemzuge zu nennen,
kränkt den Beruf des Schauspielers und kränkt die Institution des Theaters.
Also du kannst sagen, das Possenspiel, diese ganze Lüge-Geschichte von den FDP-Altfordern,
aber nicht Schauspielerei und so weiter.
Das geben wir mal weiter an die Kollegen von der Augsburger Allgemeinen,
die hier quasi das auch sehr gerügt haben.
Also die Schauspielerei.
Sehr richtig.
Jetzt haben wir über ein Metier gesprochen. Bei dem kommt man ja aus der Schauspielerei
nicht raus. So wie Erwin Goffman meinte, sowieso niemand.
Schon das kleine Kind auf der Schaukel spielt vor, dass es ihm Spaß macht,
damit die Oma es weiter...
Jaja, aber Erwin Goffman meint ja, dass wir in verschiedenen sozialen Rollen
verschiedene Rollen spielen.
Das heißt, du spielst jetzt die Rolle des Podcasters, nachher spielst du die
Rolle des Vaters, dann die Rolle des Liebhabers, was auch immer.
Und das ist etwas, was eine soziologische Beobachtung ist. Was jetzt schauspieltheoretisch
hier von Mathis ausgeführt wird, geht ja zurück sehr stark zum Beispiel auf Diderot.
Der sagt also, gerade da, wo man sich die Maske aufsetzt und wo man artifiziell
wird, kann man Wahrhaftigkeit wahrhaftiger ausdrücken, als es direkt zu fühlen.
Also wenn ich auf der Bühne stehe und...
Spiele den Jungen, der um seinen Vater trauert und ich mache das auf artifizielle
Weise, setze da mir die Maske der Trauer auf, dann ist das wahrhaftiger,
berührender auch für das Publikum.
Also wenn ich wirklich ein Junge wäre, der gerade um seinen Vater traut,
das ist nicht ein gutes Schauspiel.
Das gute Schauspiel ist also das Künstliche. Und damit ist natürlich Schauspielerei schon Manipulation.
Nur bei Lindner und bei Söder und all den Leuten haben wir es ja nicht in dem
Sinne mit Schauspielern zu tun also sie haben natürlich etwas.
Manipulatives in dem was sie tun, aber ich glaube wir müssen uns gewahr werden
dass das deren Charakter entspricht, ich glaube wir suchen immer nach der Hinterbühne
die gibt es bei Ulrich Mattes, Ulrich Mattes spielt Goebbels,
ist danach nicht Goebbels,
Ulrich Mattes Ich habe ihn auch in klassischen Rollen gesehen schon,
ist dann, wenn er privat sein wird, ein anderer.
Bei Christian Lindner muss der sich zwar fertig machen, bis der mal so aussieht
wie Christian Lindner, aber der ist, das ist sein Charakter,
kommt also dieser Art und Weise, was er uns darstellt, leider sehr nah.
Das heißt, er ist ja eigentlich da gar nicht als der Schauspieler unterwegs.
Wer das jetzt vertiefen möchte, muss sich unbedingt den Film May December ansehen,
der hoch in meinem Ranking ist, der besten Filme des Jahres.
Das ist der Film, der uns erklärt, was hier Ulrich Mattes kurz ausgeführt hat.
Ja, also dieses Buch von Goffman heißt ja auf Deutsch, wir alle spielen Theater
und auf Englisch The Expression of Self in Everyday Life.
Was bedeutet in beiden Formen, Deutsch wie Englisch, wir spielen immer Theater,
wir drücken uns immer aus. Also mit Ausdrücken ist ja so gemeint,
es gibt so einen ganz kurzen Moment zwischen, was bin ich wirklich und wie zeige ich es.
Daran beißt sich ja die Psychologie die Zähne aus und wir als ihr Publikum und
Kunden, Mandatsträger und so weiter, alle mit.
Es gibt also keine Authentizität, auch bei Lindner gibt es nicht in dem Sinne
den wahren Kern, den wir jetzt nochmal herausholen müssen.
Es ist also immer Schauspiel. Und jetzt müssen wir unterscheiden zwischen gutem
Schauspiel, wie Ulrich Mattes beschrieben hat, das Wahrhaftige,
das als ausgedachte Wirklichkeit noch näher rankommt.
An das wahre Gefühl als jemanden, der wirklich nur einfach vor sich hin,
ich sag jetzt mal, existiert, ohne Schauspiel.
Ja, sogar die Kinder, die sich einfach wirklich nur ausdrücken.
Oder halt schlechtes Schauspiel, wenn jemand, weil er nicht anders kann,
aber wir es auch besonders sehen, in Politikerrolle Schauspieler.
Und wir aber verstehen, der drückt sich gerade nicht, das ist nicht das,
was er wirklich denkt und fühlt, sondern Arbeit und Kapital erfolgt einer anderen
Logik. Er möchte hier Profite einheimsen, irgendwas und so weiter und so fort.
Und ich denke, so sollten wir nächstes Jahr insbesondere die Politik beobachten.
Wir haben eine Bundestagswahl, vorher kommt noch Donald Trump an die Macht.
Das ist in Amerika besonders interessant, weil Donald Trump hat die Wähler überzeugt
durch besonders hohe Authentizität.
Egal was er für einen Quatsch erzählt, man hat immer verstanden,
der fühlt das gerade wirklich.
Das ist so krass, dass er wirklich inbrünstig glaubt.
Ja und dabei ist er natürlich da ein guter Schauspieler.
Genau, er ist ein sehr wahrhaftiger Schauspieler. Also er kann sich gar nicht
verstecken vor sich selbst. Was ja auch eben zu diesem Effekt führt.
Und er hat sich zu der Rolle gemacht.
Genau, er hat sich zu der Rolle gemacht, aber er hat sich zu der Rolle gemacht,
in der er sich total wohl fühlt. Also wir sehen diese...
Deswegen kann er ja auch in jeden Podcast gehen und losreden.
Es kann ihm nichts passieren. Genau, das ist nämlich dieser Punkt.
Israel Klein hat gestern so eine Jahreszusammenfassung gemacht mit Publikumsfragen
und hat da unter anderem den Satz gesagt,
was ich an Podcasts so liebe und an X so scheiße finde, ist,
wenn ich heute auf Twitter bin, weiß ich, ich sehe dort Leute,
die ich eigentlich mag und jetzt hasse ich sie mehr.
Und im Podcast hört man Leute, die man eigentlich scheiße findet,
aber plötzlich mag man sie. Also diese Langform Stimme und Stimmung und so weiter
funktioniert besonders gut für Leute, die authentisch sind.
Donald Trump dazu zu hören, jeder fühlt es, aber die Amerikaner wählen eben
diesen Präsidenten und den Apparat drumherum.
Das sind sozusagen schlechte Schauspieler. und diese Distanz war selten so groß,
also dass wir sozusagen einen wahrhaftigen,
und auf ihn wählen wir, aber alle anderen würden an dieser Wahl total scheitern,
weil ich will es jetzt mal so sagen, die Gefahr ist wirklich sehr hoch,
dass sehr viele aus diesem Apparat eigentlich Donald Trump aus dem Weg haben wollen.
Also die haben andere Ziele, die wissen, jetzt wieder zu dem Alten ans Büro
und dann irgendwie überzeugen, eine Unterschrift zu machen, nee,
es wäre eigentlich cooler, wenn er jetzt altersbedingt und so weiter so ein
bisschen aussortiert wird, sodass einfach der ganze Apparat so nachrücken kann.
Nur eben, das sind schlechte Schauspieler und es merkt das Publikum auch relativ zügig.
Ich habe nur kurz reingeguckt, du hast ja auch diesen Film Civil War empfohlen.
Ja.
Der Gedanke kam mir dann Mitternacht sozusagen, also ich habe nur die erste
Viertelstunde geguckt und habe aber so ein bisschen gesehen,
okay, dieser Film erzählt eine total gewalttätige Gesellschaft.
Also Amerika ist schon wieder im Bürgerkrieg, überall Waffen,
überall Munition, aber die Protagonisten schießen Fotos.
Ja, es ist eigentlich ein Film über Fotografie.
Genau. Da wird also über Bande,
festgehalten, worum es eigentlich geht. Ist es überzeugend oder nicht?
Also wie verbindlich es für die Abwesenden und so.
Diese großen Fragen, die werden für Amerika, glaube ich, ganz,
ganz wichtig nächstes Jahr, weil dieses Authentizitätsspiel,
das Trump so gut beherrscht, beherrscht dieser Apparat drum einfach nicht.
Also J.D. Vance ist, ihm hört man auch gerne plaudern zu, aber man muss sich
wirklich in die Lage eines 19-jährigen Jungen, der gerade versteht,
wenn mich drei Frauen verlassen, Okay, dann muss ich erstmal reich werden.
Wie mache ich das? Ich hole mir eine Wallet und so.
Und dann suche ich erstmal mein Kryptokram zusammen und so.
Und das ist sozusagen, das überzeugt wirklich nur die 19-jährigen Jungs,
für die ist das gemacht, aber die anderen halt nicht. Und darin steckt eine sehr große Gefahr.
Wir gehen nochmal zurück zu OMR und zu den weiteren Ausführungen von Wiele.
Und zwar, da sind wir nämlich direkt bei dem Thema Authentizität.
Er ist also dann bei Springer und bekommt eine S-Klasse.
Als ich Vorstand wurde mit 37, ich hatte vorher nie mehr Geld ausgegeben als,
das war ja damals alles noch Mark,
6000 Mark für einen gebrauchten Fiat Uno und plötzlich kriegte ich eine lange
S-Klasse mit Fahrer und hab dann da hinten rechts drin gesessen.
Natürlich findest du das erstmal saukool und denkst, was für ein super Typ.
Aber irgendwie habe ich mich dann zunehmend unwohl darin gefühlt und habe gesagt,
davon darfst du nicht abhängig werden.
Zuerst bin ich zwischen Hamburg und Berlin gependelt und da gab es noch nicht
die 90-Minuten-Zucht, da war das super.
Und irgendwann bin ich dann hingegangen zu unserem sehr netten damaligen Aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden,
Herrn Wieter, und habe gesagt, ich möchte mein Auto zurückgeben.
Was wollen Sie, mehr Geld haben? Nein, ich finde das nicht mehr richtig.
Und auch gerade dann in Berlin mit der S-Klasse bei Startups vorbeizufahren,
ist sowieso auch bescheuert.
Da geht der Kaufpreis gleich erstmal ins Dreifache.
Und dann wollen sie nicht, warum machen? Ja, ich will das einfach nicht mehr so.
Und dann bin ich auf, die dann gerade aufkam, E-Scooter und sowas umgestiegen in Berlin.
Das finden natürlich die Mitarbeiter auch saukool, als sie mich das erste Mal da gesehen haben.
Ja, das ist diese Entfremdung. Ja. Man ist plötzlich in einem ganz engen Zusammenhang
mit Sachen, bei denen man versteht, hier kommt es nicht mehr auf mich an,
sondern das sind Kapitalkräfte.
Das ist sozusagen nicht aus meiner Arbeit erwachsen, sondern ich bin halt wo reingerutzt.
Aber dann kritisiere ich ja genau. Ja, das glaube ich schon.
Und das finde ich ja das fürchterliche daran.
Also nicht nur, dass ich würde das Auto natürlich, also wenn es für mich überhaupt
einen Grund gäbe, eine solche Position zu haben, dann ja wohl die,
dass man eine S-Klasse mit Chauffeur hat und nicht, dass man mit Matthias Döpfner
und Friede Springer zusammen essen muss.
Ich hätte gerne einfach nur die S-Klasse mit dem Chauffeur, ohne das andere, ohne Springer.
Jedenfalls ist auch interessant, dass er jetzt diese unglaubliche Position dort
hat und jetzt maskiert er sich doch eigentlich als jemand anderes.
Denn wenn man darüber nachdenkt, was ist das für eine Position,
dann kommt einem sehr schnell, assoziativ, die S-Klasse und der Chauffeur in den Sinn.
Ja, nur in solchen Positionen kann man sich das überhaupt leisten und hat das irgendjemand.
Jetzt aber ist eben die neue Kultur, dass man nicht mehr auftritt wie jemand
aus dem Vorstand, sondern man tut so, als sei man der normale Angestellte.
Und das ist das große Problem.
Das schafft natürlich eine Nähe. Er sagt ja dann, ja, die Mitarbeiter waren
da begeistert, wenn ich mit dem E-Scooter ankam.
Aber es ist ja ein Übertünchen des eigentlichen hierarchischen Verhältnisses.
Und deswegen würde ich, wenn ich jetzt in einem solchen Unternehmen als Angestellter
tätig wäre, immer den Chef bevorzugen, der mit der S-Klasse kommt,
weil ich dann genau weiß, ah, das ist der Chef, der fährt nämlich S-Klasse und
hat sogar noch einen Chauffeur.
Da weiß ich, wo ich stehe und da kann ich auch dann für mich einstehen.
Wenn ich aber da jemanden habe, der 15 mal, 30 mal mehr verdient als ich,
aber genauso aussieht wie ich und genauso ankommt mit dem E-Scooter,
dann denke ich, wie soll ich jetzt mit dem über mein Gehalt verhandeln?
Das ist eigentlich interessant, denn wir sind hier bei dem Thema,
das Andreas Reckwitz ausgespart hat, obwohl er das Buch zum Thema geschrieben hat, Verzicht.
Denn wir hatten schon mal den Spruch von Adam Toos über den Westen.
Der Westen kann sich seine Kriege nicht mehr aussuchen. Und das heißt,
jetzt sind plötzlich Kriege blöd.
Putin macht das ja ungeheuerlich, was Putin da macht. Und hier auch,
er sagt, meine Mitarbeiter fanden das ganz toll.
Nee, die haben natürlich darüber gelacht, weil es ist ja absurd.
Es ist ja dein Spruch, wir sollten nicht die erste Klasse abschaffen im Zug, sondern die zweite.
Also erst wenn der Verzicht auf die Annehmlichkeiten nicht ihm obliegt,
ist er bei seinen Mitarbeitern, bei ihnen.
Denen das ja auch so ist. Die müssen sich ja auch sozusagen überlegen,
wie sie zur Arbeit kommen, weil erste Klasse bleibt ihnen verwehrt,
sie sind halt in der zweiten Klasse und der Chef hat sie für sie nicht abgeschafft.
Der hat nur für sich die erste Klasse abgeschafft und das ist natürlich Quatsch.
Ja, die anderen haben keine Mark mehr gesehen. ProSieben, das ist jetzt also
die neue Stelle, die er dort hat.
Er ist da, wie gesagt, nicht ganz im operativen Geschäft, schaut aber von außen drauf.
Und jetzt hören wir mal, was Westermeyer da fragt, denn wir wissen ja,
bei ProSieben ist auch die Familie Berlusconi mit drin über Umwege.
Und sagen wir aber, letzte Frage zu ProSieben, weil ich meine,
das ist doch schon, glaube ich, nicht ganz so einfach, diesen Aufsichtsrat zusammenzuhalten.
Da sind ja eine Menge auch unterschiedliche Menschen da, da sind die Erben von
Berlusconi, glaube ich, mit dabei.
Da ist schon auch viel, sagen wir mal, drüber zu lesen, was da so passiert.
Ja, wobei man auch da mal eine Helikopterperspektive einnehmen sollte.
Ich glaube, es ist für ein Medienunternehmen erstmal wahnsinnig wichtig,
dass es immer nur ein Geschäft betreibt und Eigentümern gehört,
die nur Medien betreiben.
Weil sonst hast du immer andere Interessen.
Und außerdem Eigentümer hast, die auch dem westlichen Verständnis von Medien
und Pressefreiheit verbunden sind.
Nur mal ganz kurz, also sehr viele, die da investiert sind mit Medien,
machen ja noch andere Dinge.
Also es werden ja auch bei ProSieben, werden ja auch vermutlich Banijay-Produktionen,
das gehört ja zum Teil auch Bernard Arnault, der LVMH hat.
Und auch das ist ein Konsortium über mehrere Länder verstreut.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass hier der eine ist, der sagt, ich mache nur die Zeitung
oder ich mache nur den Fernsehsender.
Ich meine gerade Berlusconi, ich hätte jetzt gesagt, da wäre so ein Spruch angebracht
wie, es wäre schon gut, wenn man da Investoren hat, die sich wirklich nur in
der Wirtschaft auf den Märkten umschauen nach Profiten und nicht auch noch ein
Land betreiben nebenbei.
Aber nein Stefan, alles super.
Und da haben wir das große Glück mit Mediaset und auch mit PPF zwei westliche
größere Investoren zu haben,
die Medienunternehmer sind und die in westlichen Ländern aktiv sind, also Demokraten sind.
Sie sind alle Demokraten, wir wissen Berlusconi, da ist ja Mediaset zu verordnen,
war ja ein wirklich vorbildlicher Demokrat, da können wir froh sein,
dass da noch Chinesen drin stecken.
Ja, das ist ganz toll.
So, letzte Frage.
Über all die Jahre, so hands down, wer hat dich am meisten beeindruckt?
Stefan, willst du einen Tipp abgeben?
Über all die Jahre, wenn er seit 2000 dort ist, er kann jetzt eigentlich nur
Angela Merkel sagen, nochmal ihre Höhenluft mitschnuppern.
Stefan, du bist zu seriös.
Also auch wenn er im Moment jetzt auch wieder von vielen ganz kritisch gesehen
wird, ich glaube Elon Musk.
Das so denken unsere Medieneliten.
Also, ich versuche ja jetzt überall das Positive zu sehen.
Elon Musk den wir jetzt alle scheiße finden, zeigt uns, wie Milliardäre so drauf sind.
Ja, ja, der macht das sehr schön.
Ja, und in der Hinsicht ist das super.
Ja.
Ausgerechnet der Reichste ist der Öffentlichste und damit der Wahrhaftigste,
der uns Aussagen darüber gibt, wie die Superreichen so drauf sind. Und zwar alle.
Unverblümt. Ja.
Also wenn einer immer die ganze Zeit behauptet, nee, das ist nicht mein Business,
ich baue Raketen, ich baue Autos und so.
Aber eigentlich dieser Kapitaltyp ist, der nur so kurz vorbeischneit und sich
von Marc Andresen dafür feiern lässt.
Also die Managementmethode von Elon Musk ist, am Dienstag 10 Uhr hat er einen
Termin in seinem Geschäft, dann fragt er sie, was ist euer größtes Problem und dann löst er es.
Er hat also 50 Mal im Jahr das größte Problem von Tesla und von SpaceX und Starlink und so gelöst.
Wo ich mir denke, ja, das ist schon nicht ganz unclever weil wir haben das auch
im Corporate Therapy mal besprochen,
du willst eine Organisation, die hierarchisch aufgebaut ist,
also die strukturiert ist und gleichzeitig brauchst du aber jemanden,
der die kleine Variation erkennt und hochjazzt.
Und das kann eigentlich nur der Chef, aber der ist ja immer abgekoppelt,
kriegt Beschlussvorlagen und freut sich auf das nächste Schnittchen und so.
Und das kriegt man eigentlich nicht zusammen. Das geht aber,
wenn man so ein postheroischer ich komm nur mal kurz vorbei,
dann beschreibt ihr mir das Problem, wenn ihr nicht ehrlich zu mir seid,
werdet ihr alle gefeuert, also seid ehrlich zu mir, sagt, was das Problem ist
und dann mache ich die Executive Decision sozusagen, die ihr alle nicht könnt,
aus hierarchischen Beschränkungen und sage,
diese Abteilung wird jetzt geschlossen, das Werk kommt weg, wie auch immer.
Also das funktioniert, nach soziologischen Logiken ist das super,
nur es hat nichts mit einer Genialität von Elon Musk zu tun.
Nee, er ist der Einzige, weil er der Einzige nur sein kann, der diese Entscheidungen trifft.
Ja, wenn du typischerweise morgens ins Büro fährst und acht Stunden lang dir
Beschlussvorlagen vorlegen lässt, dann verpennst du schon mal,
dass es für deine Autos eigentlich keinen Markt gibt und stehst dann wie der
VW-Vorstand vor deiner Belegschaft und sagst,
ihr habt alle super Arbeit gemacht, aber der Markt ist nicht mehr da.
Und du hast einfach am Markt vorbei operiert. Das passiert natürlich.
Deswegen ja auch die große Lehre daraus, wenn ihr, also liebe Hörer,
falls ihr mal super reich sein solltet, werdet, wie auch immer,
manchmal passiert es ja.
Versucht nicht, der fleißige sonstige Irgendwas-Chef zu sein,
sondern lebt euer Leben, aber kommt einmal in die Woche in euer Unternehmen,
lasst euch die Sorgen ehrlich erzählen und dann haut einfach auf den Tisch und
trefft eine Entscheidung,
um dieses Problem zu lösen und dann guckt, wie das eine Woche später,
ohne euer Dazwischenfunken und so weiter, was die Leute erzählen und dann als
Chef einfach raushalten aus dem Laden, nur die großen Probleme lösen.
Ja, das ist Regieren. Das ist eigentlich Merkel.
Wir weisen noch auf den Salon schon mal hin.
Ich würde mal sagen, wir machen das bessere Kulturfernsehen nur ohne Bild.
Wir sprechen im Salon über wichtige Bücher, die zu lesen sind.
Wir müssen es so sagen. Wir reden im Salon über Worte, geschriebene Worte.
Ja.
Das ist für die einen fantasymäßig noch hinter dem Planeten so und so aus Star
Wars oder am Rande des Universums, wo noch nie jemand und so weiter.
Also das ist für Kulturfernsehen, das können die sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Ja.
Dass wir uns Sätze, geschriebene Sätze, die über Seiten hinweg eine Argumentation aufbauen.
Dass wir anderthalb Stunden, zwei Stunden über ein einziges Buch reden.
Und das wird in diesem Salon, also neben den Texten, die wir dann natürlich
empfehlen, wird das Buch, über das wir beide ausführlich diskutieren,
das Buch von Eva Illus sein, Explosive Moderne.
Es geht um die Gefühle, die Schlüsselgefühle unserer Zeit und natürlich um die Politik.
Sie scheint sich auseinanderzusetzen, nicht nur mit der Politik,
sondern hat sich auch wieder die kulturellen Erzeugnisse angeschaut,
hat in Netflix-Serien reingeschaut, um zu erfahren, mit welchen Gefühlen haben
wir es da eigentlich zu tun,
wo stehen wir gesellschaftlich,
politisch, gefühlsmäßig gerade.
Und für mich besonders toll, sie hat ihrem Buch ein Zitat vorangestellt aus
Tristan und Isolde von Richard Wagner und da heißt es, Tristan verwirrt,
was träumte mir von Tristans Ehre, Isolde, was träumte mir von Isoldes Schmach.
So beginnt dieses Buch, mysteriös, wir fragen uns, was kommt da noch,
das werden wir jedenfalls dann im Salon uns zu Gemüte führen,
werden darüber diskutieren, du verrätst noch, wie wir in den Salon kommen.
Auf neuzwanziger.de, wir sind ein Podcast mit einer Webseite,
gibt es einen goldenen Button, dem folgt man einfach, ist alles selbsterklärend.
Wir haben wieder eine E-Mail bekommen von jemandem, der an irgendwas mit,
ich habe mich auch schon bei Steady gemeldet, dann habe ich zurückgeschrieben,
melde dich da nochmal mit dieser E-Mail, wie du es uns geschrieben hast und zack.
Kam als nächstes die Antwort, alles erledigt.
Super. Also es klappt immer. Es klappt immer. Die ist der präferierte Weg.
Ab drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei. Wer uns über Apple hört und da nicht nochmal
extra woanders hin will, kann uns auch über Apple hören.
Da ist es etwa 50 Cent teurer, weil Apple mehr Gebühr verlangt.
Aber da kann man es dann direkt anklicken.
Und wer schon einen Account bei Patreon hat, findet den Podcast auch dort.
Jetzt wo du Tristan und die Solde vorgelesen hast. Ich werde ja im Januar mit
Ole in Leipzig in die Oper gehen.
Ich werde also das erste Mal, und ich zähle kurz aus dem Augenwinkel,
vielleicht 30 Opern, 25, 30 Opern das erste Mal außerhalb Frankfurts in eine Oper gehen.
Wir haben ja schon ein paar Mal über die Oper gesprochen. Ich will nochmal anfügen,
ich habe das ja schon so als den stillen Raum, wo man so ein bisschen die Bühnenrealität
und alle anderen schweigen, bitte. Ein bisschen husten, okay, nehmen wir hin.
Man zeigt noch kurz, dass man ein Mensch ist, aber mehr will man nicht wissen von den Leuten.
Wir lesen allerdings immer die Übertexte oben mit. Es sind ja nicht alle Opern auf Deutsch.
Zuletzt Nacht vor Weihnachten gesehen mit Monika, russisch.
Man liest den Text so mit und Opern zeichnen sich dadurch aus,
dass sie sehr redundant sind, inhaltlich, aber sehr variantenreich in der Ausformulierung.
Und ich habe mir kurz überlegt, jetzt wo du das vorgelesen hast,
wie wäre es, wenn ich Opernkritiker wäre.
Ich säße ja in der Oper, würde das mitlesen, auch im Sinne von,
das kann man halt gut später zitieren, anders als die Musik,
das Schauspiel, wie auch immer, müsste man halt ein Foto machen vom Bühnenbild oder so.
Ich wäre ein sehr unglücklicher Mensch, wenn ich in der Oper die Sätze,
die ich toll fände, immer mitschreiben würde für später oder so.
Ja, es gibt solche und solche Kritiker. Ja, es gibt Kritiker,
die ja nur mit Notizbuch reingehen, andere lassen es weg.
Ich würde sagen, die Opernkritiker, wenn es jetzt nicht eine selten gespielte
Oper ist, wie diese dort, dann ist das so, dass die das auch kennen und können.
Also die haben das parat.
Ich habe ja bisher nur zwei Opern zweimal gesehen. Der Rest ist ja für mich
alles neu, alles Erstlingswerke in meinem Kopf.
Die sehen ja zum 25. Mal den Tristan. Die wissen dann schon,
welche Stellen wichtig sind.
Sie ist ja dann schon nicht mehr sensibel für die...
Nein, man entdeckt ja immer Neues. Das ist ja das Interessante an der Oper,
weil es einen so überfordert.
Man kann sich ja gar nicht auf alles konzentrieren, muss also eine Auswahl treffen,
konzentriert sich vielleicht auch mehr auf die Inszenierung oder achtet mal
besonders auf den Text oder so.
Und in der Weise ist eigentlich das Opernerlebnis nie langweilig,
wenn es dann einigermaßen gut ist, weil man doch sich immer wieder wundert,
wie viel man verpasst hat.
Bisher.
Ja, ja, also dass man immer wieder auf Neues stößt.
Kommen wir zum Fernsehen. Wir verlassen sozusagen den ganzen Sprung zum Fernsehen.
Es gab ein, wie soll man sagen, Terror-Amok-Anschlag in Magdeburg.
Der interessante Parallelen für uns Zuschauer hat mit diesem Fall in Manhattan,
dass ein junger Mensch ein CEO erschießt.
Findest du das eine Parallele? Ich sah es jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so als
eine Parallele, außer dass,
wir wissen jetzt bei dem mutmaßlichen Mörder in Manhattan nicht genau schon die Motive,
aber wir haben glaube ich da schon unterschiedliche Situationen.
Also der eine verbreitet ja, also der eine scheint ja sehr gezielt jemanden
gesucht zu haben, den er aus dem Weg räumen will.
Diesen CEO aufgrund der Versicherung, aufgrund seiner Geschichte mit dieser Versicherung etc.
Und jetzt haben wir ja hier jemanden, der so eine diffuse Angst hat und sie
auch selbst die ganze Zeit bei Twitter verbreitet hat und sonst wo.
Also der eigentlich diese Stimmung, Deutschland ist nicht mehr Deutschland,
Deutschland wird untergehen,
jetzt muss was getan werden, wir brauchen jetzt die große Aktion,
der daraufhin wahllos Menschen umbringt.
Genau. Wir haben es also mit Brüchen in unserer Sehgewohnheiten zu tun.
Den ersten hast du ja schon genannt.
Also Luigi hatte ein ganz spezifisches Ziel.
Ja.
Und er hat einen ganz peniblen Plan. Er sagt, ich drucke mir eine Waffe,
schreibe damit auch Geschichte.
Das erste Attentat quasi mit einer 3D gedruckten, zumindest teilweise 3D gedruckten
Waffe, die man einfach, also was einfach bedeutet, nicht zu detektieren.
Also das kann einfach überall hergestellt werden. und er ist in Manhattan, also dem,
bestüberwachtesten Ort, der ist so gut überwacht, dass es Fernsehserien gibt,
wie Person of Interest, die sagen, wir nehmen mal Manhattan und New York als
sozusagen Epizentrum der Überwachungsgesellschaft und so,
das ist wirklich verrückt, das ist auch schon wieder zehn Jahre her und er schießt
dort ganz gezielt jemanden auf der Straße und wenn wir das Mordmerkmal Vorsatz,
anwenden wollen, was es besonders schlimm macht als Verbrechen,
dann ist hier jeder stimmt überein, das war Vorsatz.
Also zielgenauer kann man gar nicht ermorden. Und trotzdem haben wir Reaktionen
im Publikum, die sagen, das finde ich gut.
Ich habe ihn kennengelernt, den Luigi, durch die Tat,
Und jetzt bin ich Fan. Also Internet ist ja wirklich voll davon.
Ja, weil er natürlich das mitbringt, was in den sozialen Medien gut funktioniert.
Attraktivität, dann ein Look, der jetzt noch dadurch, dass man offizielle Bilder
veröffentlicht, wenn er da abgeführt wird in einem orangefarbenen Anzug,
natürlich erinnert an die Marvel- und DC-Filme, an eine Figur wie den Joker.
Das ist eigentlich Bühnenrealität. Der also so eine Rächerfigur wird und der
zugleich natürlich diese Stimmung aufgreift, dass die Leute, gelinde gesagt.
Zutiefst frustriert darüber sind, wie das Versicherungssystem den USA ist.
Und sie sehen quasi in diesem einzelnen Rächer ihren Helden.
Und das ist eine neue Dimension, die es auch glaube ich so nicht gab.
Und weil jetzt so von irgendwelchen Leuten bei Twitter, so aus Springer-Konzernen
und so immer gesagt wurde, ja die Linken sind jetzt alle so schamlos, dass die den abfeiern.
Das ist interessanterweise, wenn man sich das genauer ansieht,
gar nicht ein linkes Phänomen.
Also das ist nicht jetzt irgendwie die Bernie Bros, nur die jetzt da irgendwelche Memes draus basteln,
sondern interessanterweise ist das ja sehr breit, weil die Versicherungen werden
gehasst in den USA, auch von Republikanern, auch von konservativen Wählern.
Und die sehen jetzt alle gerade und das ist auch kulturell eingeübt,
dass man solche Figuren ja im Kino so lange auch glorifiziert hat,
sehen alle in ihm irgendeinen Heilsbringer.
Es ist jetzt nicht irgendeine Voke-Blase oder irgendeine linke Blase,
sondern es ist sehr, sehr weit verbreitet in den USA und deswegen ja auch so erstaunlich dann für,
sagen wir, die etablierten Medien, dass plötzlich die ganzen Kommentarspalten
voll sind mit Leuten, die Luigi toll finden.
Und die dann aber nicht unbedingt einem linken Lager zuzuordnen sind.
In der Hinsicht ist es eine Beziehungstat zwischen einem Patienten und dem Chef
seiner Versicherung, die er brauchte für sein Rückenleiden, wie auch immer, und halt nicht bekam.
In dieser Beziehung stecken sehr viele Amerikaner.
Und die Tat selbst wird von sehr vielen, wenn nicht gut geheißen, aber halt verstanden.
Weil, wir haben es ja eben schon besprochen, es gibt nichts zu erklären.
Also der Authentizitätsquotient, der es medial erfolgreich macht,
ist so hoch, niemand muss mehr irgendwas erklären. Jeder versteht sofort.
Ja, also ich hatte eine Story geteilt
auf Instagram, die die deutschen Sehgewohnheiten sehr gebrochen hat.
Da hat nämlich eine Frau sich von ihrem Mann vorlesen lassen,
was die Fehlgeburt gekostet hat.
So, und die gehen dann die Rechnung durch, Schritt für Schritt.
Drei Tage Aufenthalt im Krankenhaus, Narkosemittel so und so und so weiter.
Und sie fragt dann immer, war es das? Ne, hier sind noch zwei Posten.
Und am Ende summiert sich das irgendwie auf 63.000 Dollar und sie sagt, we are broke.
Und plötzlich ist dieses drei Wochen lang auf Instagram öffentlich leiden,
dass man das eigene Kind verloren hat, sozusagen an den Rand gedrängt,
weil jetzt kommt das eigentlich zu lösende Problem, Geld.
Gefühle werden jetzt drüber geschoben, jetzt geht es ums Geld.
Und das betrifft ganz Amerika.
Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie sehr alle verstehen, um was es hier geht.
Und Scott Galloway hat im Podcast eine sehr interessante, wie soll man sagen,
er kommt ja auch mal mit scharfen Thesen.
Er hatte kurz ausgeführt, dass er selber nicht am Gesundheitssystem teilnimmt,
sondern er hat seine Millionen Dollar und wenn er zum Arzt geht,
zahlt er halt einfach, was da aufgerufen wird, anstatt sich noch mit so einer
Bürokratie rumzuschlagen.
Jaja, so und so viel kostet meine Versicherung und dann muss ich aber noch beachten,
wenn ich den Notarzt rufe, ist die Selbstbeteiligung 500 Dollar für den Transport
und so weiter, also dieser ganze Scheiß, einfach ausblenden und sagen.
Bezahle ich halt die 300.000 Dollar, weil es mal irgendwas ist,
so, bevor ich jetzt hier in Schulitäten komme. Oder wie man das sonst so nennt.
Das betrifft das ganze Land. Nur er als One-Persenter kann sich halt freikaufen von diesem System.
Für die anderen bedeutet es, der Lobbyismus, vor allem der Demokraten gegenüber
hat es so korrumpiert, dass ein Mord auf offener Straße, gerade weil der Vorsatz
so deutlich ist, so gutiert wird.
Also ein sehr großer Bruch mit Sehgewohnheiten, wie wir das eigentlich eingeimpft
kriegen, durch alle Krimiserien, Mord ist nicht gut.
Was du jetzt gerade nochmal sagst, die Rolle der Demokraten,
weil das jetzt immer so gesagt wird, die Linken sind hemmungslos geworden und jubeln einem Mörder zu.
Nein, es gibt gerade deshalb viele aus konservativen und rechten Kreisen,
die Luigi zujubeln, weil sie Big Pharma und alles, was damit zu tun hat,
mit den Demokraten identifizieren. J.D.
Vance hat das in zig Podcasts immer wieder betont.
Big Pharma, das ist jetzt alles Demokraten und wir sind die,
die gegen Big Pharma kämpfen.
Also das ist nicht so einfach mit dieser Links-Rechts-Unterscheidung da zu machen.
Jetzt wird mit Kennedy allerdings ganz Pharma ausgeräumt. Das ist natürlich auch ein Problem.
Gut, also Scott Galloway sagt, das ist hier Lobbyismus, wenn das Land so korrumpiert
ist und Politik versagt, sind die Leute wütend.
Und wenn dann einer sozusagen es sich traut, es in die Selbstjustiz zu übernehmen,
dann steht das Land daneben und sagt, finde ich jetzt gar nicht so schlecht.
Allerdings im Großen und Ganzen.
Half, you have a self-correction. And that's the good news. Income inequality always self-corrects.
The bad news is that the means, or the vehicles of self-correction are war, famine, or revolution.
And I would argue this is a form of revolution. I believe the Me Too movements
and the Black Lives Matters movements, which both had righteous components of
them, but all of these things have in common is the following.
They're going after the 1%. And effectively what happens is people Das heißt,
If the 1% is making more money than the bottom 99, at some point the bottom
99 figures out the best way to double their wealth is to either show up and
kill these people, tell them to move out of the country, or to shame them.
This is what has happened in Central America and nations all over the world
throughout modern history. And this is a form of revolution.
When people decide, when they see that insurance companies have a profit motive
in denying claims, when they see insurance companies and their shareholders
consistently getting richer,
and they also know somebody whose wife got lung cancer, which meant they were
going to be bankrupt two years later, they start to get enraged.
This is a form of Er.
Hat vollkommen recht und wir können das auch parallelisieren mit der Zeit vor der Französischen.
Damals wurden wahnsinnig viele Flugschriften und ähnliche Publikationen veröffentlicht,
die auch hämisch waren, die nicht eine Analyse der Gesellschaft geleistet haben,
sondern die von Rache-Gelüsten getrieben waren,
die die moralischen Verfehlungen des Adels angreiften,
die sexuelle Freizügigkeit stigmatisierten, Weil sie sagten,
das sind eigentlich die Liederlichen, während wir hier im Dreck leben müssen,
nehmen die uns das Letzte ab und amüsieren sich auf unsere Kosten.
Und genau diese Art der Publikationswut, die es da gab, die auch hemmungslos
war und irgendwelche Raubdrucke geisterten durch Paris und sonst wohin.
Das ist eigentlich eine Stimmung, die wir jetzt wieder haben in dieser Meme-Produktion zu Luigi.
In all diesen Kommentarspalten können wir das erleben.
Und deswegen ist das so interessant, wenn immer wieder jetzt zu so einer Ordnung gerufen wird.
Also jetzt muss man aber wieder anständig sein und wir haben doch einen Modus,
wie wir um Menschen, die getötet wurden, trauern und so weiter.
Dass das also natürlich alles hilflose Versuche sind. Und eigentlich diesen
revolutionären Charakter, den es hat und den Galloway hier glaube ich gut auf
den Punkt bringt, zu verdrängen.
Was auch zur Folge hat, dass das interessanteste Thema gerade medial ausgespart
wird, weil sie es keiner zutraut.
Nämlich, was machen diese Führungsetagen gerade, um sich abzusichern?
Also sowas passiert kurz vor Weihnachten und hier weiß man einfach,
sehr viele Reisepläne sind ganz anders geworden.
Also sehr viele CEOs bunkern sich jetzt besonders ein, sind nicht mehr in New
York einfach auf der Straße zu sehen. Der Typ war ja bei einem Treffen mit den
Investoren und musste nur die Straßenseite wechseln.
Von dem Hotel raus in die nächste Bewirtungsrunde rein, zu den Investorentreffen.
Und genau auf diesem kurzen Meter, 100 Meter vielleicht, wurde er ermordet.
Also das wird derzeit auch mit so einer stillen Freude an sehr vielen Orten gesehen.
Was bedeutet, hier haben wir so eine gewisse Entkopplung, nicht nur von Kapital
und Arbeit, was ja der Revolutionsbegriff, sondern auch von massenmedialem Gespräch
und was die Leute gerade wirklich umtreibt.
Ja.
Weil wir haben in Europa oder in Deutschland einen Anschlag auf einen Weihnachtsmarkt
und drei Tage später werden alle Weihnachtsmärkte besonders geschützt,
weil man natürlich weiß, so ein mediales Theater führt zu Nachhamertum.
Also gerade die Woche danach ist halt besonders kritisch so,
es ist dann nicht einfach nur so ein Aktionismus der Sicherheitsbehörden und
Medien, sondern nee, da kommen dann Leute so auf Ideen und denken,
ach, das könnt ihr auch mal machen. Irgendwie so, wenn die Wut schon entsprechend da ist.
In der Hinsicht ist dieses mediale Abfeiern von Luigi für sehr viele Leute schon
sehr gefährlich, weil man nicht genau weiß, wie viele jetzt so kurz vorm Civil
War, den sie in die eigene Hand nehmen, sind.
Gut, gehen wir mal zu, also ich springe mal einen Clip, den ich nur kurz referiere,
Der Spiegel Online-Chef war im Spiegel Podcast zu Gast, nicht der Spiegel Online-Chef,
sondern der Spiegel Korrespondent aus Amerika und erzählt dort,
ja ja, also diese Krankenversicherung hier, das ist wirklich für sehr viele
Leute ein Thema und dann fällt da sozusagen vom Reportieren ins Tagebuch schreiben
und sagt, ich musste das letzten Monat auch erst machen fürs nächste Jahr,
meine Krankenversicherung kostet 1900 Euro im Monat.
Exklusive dieser ganzen Selbstbeteiligung. Also sobald der Notruf wählt oder
bei einem Arzt vorstellig wird, sind es nochmal ein paar hundert Dollar,
die dann in Action zu bezahlen sind.
Hier geht es bei den 1900 Euro nur darum, wenn er dann mal eine große OP hat,
die auf 38.000 Dollar sich aufsummiert, wird die halt entsprechend bezahlt.
Aber dieser ganze Kleingram ist aussortiert. Also es ist schlimm,
schlimm, schlimm, wie es da in Amerika zugeht.
Magdeburg. Ich will jetzt diese Clips einfach nur hintereinander weg mal spielen,
um zu zeigen, dass wirklich alles falsch gemacht wurde, aus meiner Sicht.
Ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt, denn ich habe mir gar nichts dazu angesehen.
Ich habe nur ein paar Dinge dazu gelesen online, mehr nicht.
Also massenmedial ein Drama, sondersgleichen. Klar, es ist eine besondere Herausforderung,
wenn die Sehgewohnheiten so gebrochen wird, dass es eigentlich nach islamistischem
Terror aussieht und dann später aber heißt, nee, vielleicht genau das Gegenteil und so.
Aber wir kommen jetzt echt in so ein Jahr, in der alle Sehgewohnheiten gebrochen
werden irgendwie, ist so mein Eindruck.
Also alle hängen so drin in ihren Skripten und hoffen dann, dass sie drei Stunden
nach dem Vorfall so eine Art Sondersendung machen können, in der irgendetwas,
Bestand hat über die Nacht hinaus, aber es ist einfach nicht mehr so.
Also in der Hinsicht ist das stellvertretend für totale Orientierungslosigkeit,
Sendungseröffnung am 20.12., also dem Tag des Anschlags.
Guten Abend, auch wenn er alles andere als gut ist. In Magdeburg hat es einen
mutmaßlichen Terroranschlag gegeben.
Ein Fahrzeug ist trotz Absicherungen über den Weihnachtsmarkt gefahren und hat
mehrere Besucher überfahren.
Knapp 70 sollen dabei verletzt worden sein, 15 davon schwer.
Mindestens zwei Menschen sind ums Leben gekommen. Der Fahrer wurde von der Polizei festgenommen.
Der Verdächtige soll aus Saudi-Arabien stammen. Eine kurze Zusammenfassung.
Mindestens 400 Meter weit soll der Wagen laut Medienberichten durch den Weihnachtsmarkt
Magdeburg gefahren sein.
Mit, so die Stadtverwaltung, hoher Geschwindigkeit.
Vorbei an den Ständen, mitten durch die Menschenmenge.
Am frühen Abend ist der Markt schon gut besucht. Vor etwa einer Stunde spricht
der Magdeburger Rettungsdienst von 60 bis 80 Verletzten.
Die ersten werden bereits in der Universitätsklinik behandelt.
Zwei Tote sind bisher bestätigt.
So, zum einen der Ton. Dunja Hayali beginnt das wie so eine Pfacherin,
die uns jetzt irgendwie gemeinsam abholt, an so einem Trauergottesdienst,
der spontan eingerichtet wurde, weil ich habe mit Magdeburg nichts zu tun.
Sehr viele Leute nicht. Wir haben mit dieser menschlichen Tragödie dort was zu tun.
Nur es ist, auch wenn es eine besondere Tatdurchführung ist,
eine Tragödie unter vielen.
Und typischerweise haben wir professionelle Stellen, die dafür zuständig sind.
Und wenn auch vorher das ein öffentlicher Platz ist, gilt doch spätestens ab,
das ist jetzt ein Tatort, eine gewisse Zugangsbeschränkung.
Wir wollen nicht, dass irgendwelche Täter dort ungehindert durchfahren können.
Nur wollen wir, dass die Presse da einfach ungehindert durchfährt durch so einen Tatort.
Nur weil es heißt, das ist so groß, ihr ist so groß, das Durcheinander,
wir gehen jetzt einfach mal dahin und filmen ab, wo der da durchgefahren ist,
um, ja was denn eigentlich, den Leuten zu Hause verständlich zu machen,
weil es irgendwie ganz wichtig ist, dass sie jetzt verstehen,
wie das aus Sicht des Täters aussieht.
Es gibt ja nichts zu verstehen. Es ist einfach eine furchtbare Tat und sie hätte
die Zahlen nennen können, es ist auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt und dort jetzt nochmal so drüber zu filmen,
dann Opfer nicht direkt, aber so halb indirekt zu zeigen.
Und im Internet war ja, was ich da bei Twitter an Bildmaterial fluktuieren sah, noch ganz anderes,
dass ich mich immer wundere, wie das sein kann, dass man da glaubt,
hier zeige sich jetzt journalistische Brillanz.
Ja genau, es gibt da journalistisch nichts zu tun.
Man muss warten, was die Behörden dazu sagen, was die Motive sind und dann ist
da bahnfrei für die Helfer.
Und sonst weiß ich nicht, was ich da jetzt erfahre, ob der jetzt 430 Meter oder
sonst wo nochmal rechts abgebogen ist.
Also all die Thesen, die hier so mitlaufen, mein Publikum ist ein voyeuristisches.
Kann gut sein, dass sie das im ZDF-Zentrale hier in Mainz so sehen,
nur vielleicht ist das Publikum gar nicht so voyeuristisch.
Ja, auch wenn dann davon ist, halt trotzdem nicht zeigt.
Selbst wenn, ist das Aufgabe, dann kann immer noch Springer das machen.
Und dann sagt man, ah, die Schmuddelkinder sind wieder mit dem Handy da gleich
hin und haben sozusagen die, wie heißen sie, die Publikumsreporter und so weiter aktiviert.
Können jemand in Magdeburg mal kurz auf die Straße gehen und das filmen?
Im ZDF, also wirklich null Reflexion.
Schalten wir nach Sachsen-Anhalt, nach Magdeburg, Hagen, Mikulas.
Was weiß man denn mittlerweile?
So, wir hören jetzt mal, sie stellen natürlich die Standardfragen,
er gibt die Standardantworten.
Wahrhaftigkeit. Wissen, was war. Da ist was Schlimmes passiert.
Betrifft mich das hier jetzt auch?
Nein, es betrifft mich nicht.
Trotzdem ist es passiert. Es hat einen gewissen Human Interest.
Es gibt tausend Bücher, in denen man nachlesen kann.
Juristische Ader scheint es wohl irgendwie zu geben. Ich kenne auch sehr viele
Leute, mich inklusive, die dann einfach ausschalten.
Das ist so dieses typische, hinten sitzt ein Dreijähriger auf dem Kindersitz.
Nachrichten machen wir aus.
Das machen auch Erwachsene. Dafür braucht man gar keine Kinder auf dem Rücksitz.
So, wir hören jetzt mal, wie er legitimiert, überhaupt irgendeine Information weitergeben zu können.
Beile über die Tat.
Über die Tat weiß man so viel, dass es ein Einzeltäter gewesen sein soll.
Das hat gerade der Ministerpräsident hier, der hier gerade vor Ort war, nochmal bestätigt.
Also das ist das, wovon die Behörden gerade ausgehen. Ein Einzeltäter,
der mit einem Auto, mit einem Mietwagen auf den Weihnachtsmarkt gefahren sein
soll heute am frühen Abend.
Und sie blenden jetzt den Korrespondenten klein, um im großen Bild nochmal zu
zeigen, wie das Auto in den Weihnachtsmarkt fuhr.
Eigentlich ist dafür Springer und TikTok zuständig. Niemand braucht sowas.
Und dafür haben wir TikTok in den letzten Jahren kritisiert,
dass solche Videos dort veröffentlicht werden.
Du hast hier mal irgendwann gesagt, ich gehe nicht mehr zu TikTok,
weil ich nicht laufend Leute sterben treten will.
Also ich muss ja, das ist ja, die Szenerie ist ja heute so, wir haben ein Weihnachtsfest,
bei dem die Kinder iPhones am 24.
Geschenk kriegen, sich die ganzen Apps draufhauen und am 25.
Noch bevor sie bei der Oma am Tisch sitzen und den ersten Klos essen,
haben sie schon drei Leute sterben sehen.
Unvermittelt, sie haben sich in ihre Schulgruppe eingemeldet,
haben genau gesehen, welche drei Typen da gemobbt wurden mit,
zeig mir mal deine Weihnachtsgeschenke und so weiter, die da nicht antworten,
sondern weinend zu Hause sitzen.
Das heißt, diese Kinder kommen dann morgens runter, setzen sich bei der Oma
an den Tisch und die Oma macht so das Radio an und da kommt ein Wetterbericht
und die sagt, das ist aber schlimm, so wieder so düsteres Wetter.
Also für die Oma ist sozusagen das die größte Nachricht der Welt,
wie das Wetter ist und sie findet es ganz schlimm.
Und der Sohn, der nicht darüber spricht, hat schon drei Leute sterben sehen und wurde gemobbt.
So, und jetzt kommt das CDF und sagt, wir haben Medienlogik A,
Medienlogik B, wir entscheiden uns für die drei Morde und das Mobben.
Für alle. Aber wir machen es im ganz seriösen Moderationston von Dunja Hayali,
die ist ja eine ganz tolle, die kriegt auch ganz viele Preise.
Dann sieht man das nicht, für was wir uns hier entscheiden.
Ich würde ja bei dem Zuschalten von Korrespondenten immer sagen,
Das ist ja nur dann sinnvoll, wenn Korrespondenten etwas sagen können,
was Leute im Studio nicht sagen könnten. Also sonst für den Korrespondenten.
Ja.
Ja, also das ist ja unsinnig. Also wenn ich jetzt, wir könnten uns jetzt über
die Frankfurter Politik unterhalten, ja.
So, aber wird das jetzt, wird unser Gespräch dadurch besser,
dass ich sage, ich bleibe jetzt hier und du stellst dich jetzt raus vor das
Rathaus in Frankfurt und ich schalte dich dann zu und sage, und Stefan,
was kannst du uns sagen, wie wird der Haushaltsplan für 2025 sein?
Genau, und diese Frage nehmen wir jetzt genau so. Warum ist dort ein Korrespondent,
der uns irgendwas erzählt?
Und wir hören weiter zu, zweimal hat er es schon entsprechend legitimiert,
wie er das weiter versucht, uns zu erklären, warum er das als Korrespondent vor Ort macht.
Betroffenen heißt es, es sind 68 Betroffene, darunter 15 Schwerstverletzte und zwei Tote.
Das ist das, was der Ministerpräsident hier vor Ort gerade bestätigt hat.
Der war mit der Innenministerin gerade hier vor Ort zum Tathergang.
Ja, scheint es so zu sein oder es ist bestätigt worden, dass es so ist,
wie die Videos das zeigen.
Also der ist mit dem Auto auf den Weihnachtsmarkt gefahren durch eine der Gassen
und auf einer anderen Seite wieder raus aus dem Markt und hat dabei mehrere Menschen überfahren.
So, der Ministerpräsident hat
bestätigt, die Behörden sagten und so weiter und so fort. Also in dem...
Die Leute liegen noch blutend auf der Straße und so, ja, zwei Stunden nach der Tat.
Ist egal, ob der Ministerpräsident bestätigt, dass es zwei Tote sind oder nicht.
Das ist einfach eine völlige Nonsensinformation.
Schlimmer noch, der Ministerpräsident hat in dem Moment andere Aufgaben,
als mir zu bestätigen, wie viele Leute da tot sind.
Hast du auch das aus den Tagesthemen mit Ingo Zamperoni? Kommt das noch?
Wir kommen darauf zurück.
Das sollten wir schon dokumentieren.
Genau, wir hören jetzt erst drei Experten. Den Clip, wie du ihn meintest,
müssen wir beschreiben. Ich habe ihn nicht, da er in einer Sondersendung lief
und ich aber nur sozusagen die fertigen, ja die Redaktion auch mal ein bisschen
drüber nachgedacht, Tagesthemen, wie sie im Programm stehen.
Den aber wie ist zu dem ein Gespräch, dass wir nachher, es ist so absurd,
jetzt erstmal drei Clips zu Experten.
Dunja Hayali ist ja schon sozusagen als Seelsorgerin aufgetreten,
sie möchte uns also sagen, das wäre zu verhindern gewesen, ja muss sie denn
so einen kurzen Rock tragen, so ungefähr, ja. Also wir haben hier Victim-Blaming.
Nur Victim ist in dem Falle, ist jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert,
aber dieser Typ wollte Deutschland schaden.
Aufgrund politischer Handlungen. Und er hat sich die Greifbaren ausgesucht,
beliebiges Publikum. Irgendwelche Leute auf der Straße.
Das heißt, er hätte jeden einfach auf der Straße genommen und wir alle wissen,
da kommt morgens ein Schulbus, da geht die Tür auf, 80 Schüler kommen raus.
Wenn man Deutschland schädigen will, nimmt man wie Anders Breiweg eine Insel,
von der keiner flüchten kann und er schießt 80 Kinder.
Man fährt einfach auf so einen Schulbus drauf, wie auch immer.
Also solche Taten sind nicht zu verhindern.
Ja, es wird jetzt wieder diskutiert, da waren drei Meter und da waren vier Meter
frei und so weiter. Da denke ich immer, Leute, ihr geht doch alle durch,
statt ihr seid alle irgendwo auf Gewalt.
Wo sich hundert Leute gerade einmal tummeln. Wie soll das denn gehen?
Es ist doch, es ist, es ist einfach, wenn da ein Fünf-Poller-Mehr gewesen wäre,
wäre der woanders reingefahren in der Menge.
Also das ist nicht herzustellen.
In Deutschland mangelt es nicht an Menschenmasse. Also es sind überall Menschenmengen,
wenn wir sie sehen wollen.
Das ist wirklich so verrückt, dass man sich immer wieder diese Debatte gefallen lassen muss.
Und jetzt hören wir uns das mal an hier im Heute-Journal. Und ich finde,
das ist einfach ganz falsch.
Es ist aus sehr vielen Gründen ganz falsch, den Leuten hier vorzugaukeln,
dass das die relevanten Gesprächsthemen sind.
Die Frage, die sich wahrscheinlich...
Das ist jetzt vom Tattag 20.
...alle Stellen ist, wie konnte das passieren? Ja, das ist wirklich ein Anschlagsszenario,
das wirklich sehr eingeübt, durchgespielt und eigentlich sehr effektiv verhindert gehört.
Das Einfahren jeglicher Fahrzeuge auf große Menschenansammlungen,
ob das jetzt Fanmeilen bei der EM sind oder Weihnachtsmärkte in Deutschland,
sollte eigentlich effektiv verhindert werden.
Es soll eigentlich einen geschlossenen Ring von Betonbarrieren oder Metallbarrieren,
um die solche Menschenansammlungen stattfinden.
Wie kann man sowas reden? Also ich weiß doch, wenn man in einer größeren Stadt
unterwegs ist und dort an einer
Kreuzung mit dem Auto hält, dann gehen da mal gerade 90 Leute drüber.
Wenn dann jemand ausflippt und eine Psychose hat und sagt, ich fahre jetzt alle
platt, dann fährt der alle platt.
Das ist wirklich so ein Irrsinn, diese Debatte da zu führen.
In Frankfurt, der Hauptbahnhof, an dem ungefähr alle 30 Sekunden den ICE hält,
mit 400 Meter Länge, ist die Fußgänger, der Fußgängerüberweg ist fünfspurig.
Da fährt man einfach mit 50, 60 kmh auf den Fußgängerweg zu und bleibt dann halt stehen.
Wenn hier die Eintracht spielt, stehen 10.000 Leute vorm Stadion, ungeschützt.
Da ist eine zweispurige Straße davor. Und zwar eine, die man richtig runterbrettert.
Es ist nicht möglich, das zu schützen. Und die erklären uns ja einfach,
ja, da wurde ein Fehler gemacht und so weiter. Herr Jalli kam immer wieder darauf
zurück. Das war jetzt am 20., am 21.
Sie haben die noräigischen Punkte angesprochen. Wir haben gelernt,
Fluchtkorridore muss es geben.
Das ist klar, aber dass die auch nicht abgesichert sind, das war irgendwie nicht richtig klar.
Sie hat hier im Gespräch den Generalbundesanwalt zugeschaltet aus Karlsruhe.
Der hat mit Magdeburg wirklich gar nichts zu tun.
Zum Beispiel durch absenkbare Poller. Warum gab es das da nicht in Magdeburg?
Das kann ich hier nicht beantworten. Ich glaube, das wird in Magdeburg jetzt
intensiv auch selber beraten.
Was können wir tun?
Hätte man auch etwas anderes tun müssen im Vorfeld?
Von allem, was man über diesen Täter weiß, da sind ja sehr viele Tweets und
Leute, die Interviews mit dem schon früher mal geführt haben, bekannt,
ist ziemlich klar, dass dieser Mensch eine Katastrophe anrichten wollte und
viele Menschen in den Tod reißen wollte. Das war seine Idee.
Und dann hat er sich irgendeine Stelle ausgesucht, an der er es besonders gut machen kann.
Wäre es die eine nicht gewesen, wäre es die andere. Und damit ist diese Debatte einfach hinfällig.
Es gibt so viele Debatten zu führen, der Typ hat es seit einem Jahr lang,
es gab schon E-Mails letztes Weihnachten, dann aus Versehen eine amerikanische
Berlin-Polizeistelle statt irgendwie nach Berlin und so.
Ja, der hat ja zum Teil gedroht unter dem Account, ich glaube des Bundesinnenministeriums
auf Twitter und man fragt sich,
warum sind da Behörden dem nicht nachgegangen, was muss eigentlich man alles
machen, also wir wissen von Leuten, die sich auf einer Straße festgeklebt haben,
um das Klima zu schützen,
dass da deren ganze Bude ausgeräumt wurde und dass die dann ins Gefängnis kamen,
weil sie irgendwo mal ein bisschen den Verkehr blockiert haben.
Wir haben es hier mit jemandem zu tun, der wohl sehr aggressiv und mit eindeutigen
Drohungen gearbeitet hat und dem ist nicht nachgegangen worden.
Wollen wir jetzt über Poller sprechen?
Ja, und Maschinengewehr in der Twitter-Bio für 50.000 Leute, die ihm gefolgt sind.
Also hier ist ganz viel Nachlässigkeit, ganz viel Unterlassung,
aber nicht beim absenkbaren Poller vor dem Weihnachtsmarkt.
Selbst am 23. Tage später, Herr Hayali konnte nicht loslassen.
Reden wir über das Sicherheitskonzept mit Christian Schneider.
Er ist Terrorabwehrexperte und zugelassener Experte für Zufahrtsschutz. Schönen guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend und grüß Gott, Frau Hayali. Herr Schneider,
hat das Schutzkonzept den allgemein anerkannten Regeln der Technik,
so heißt das Ganze offiziell, entsprochen?
Leider nein, denn wenn dort ein ordentliches Zufahrtschutzkonzept nach den allgemein
anerkannten Regeln der Technik installiert gewesen wäre, dann hätte der Anschlag
so nicht stattfinden können.
Das heißt, Sie sagen eigentlich, die, die das geplant haben, haben keine Ahnung?
Also all die allgemein anerkannten Regeln der Technik haben sie sich nicht gehalten.
Das ist offensichtlich geworden.
Und welche Ahnung sie haben, das weiß ich nicht. Aber vom Zufahrtsschutz,
glaube ich, verstehen sie nicht so viel.
Da sind jetzt irgendwelche Sündenböcke gesucht und die führt man dann am Ende
nochmal im ZDF und in der Bild-Zeitung vor oder was?
Also sollen jetzt die Polizeileute, die dort den 1 Meter Zufahrt nicht geregelt
haben entsprechend, was soll jetzt geschehen? Also was ist die Forderung?
Ja, man würde irgendjemandem Amt ausfindig machen, der bei der Planung des Weihnachtsmarktes
auf irgendeinem Poller nicht geachtet hat. Dann denkt man, ja,
da hätte man es verhindern können.
Oder ist die Logik hier, er hätte es lieber woanders machen sollen,
aber auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja jedes Mal das selbe. Wir hatten ja hier mal diese
ganze Debatte mit Nancy Faeser mit dem Messerverbot.
Oder dann sagt das ja, wenn man ein größeres Brot zu Hause hat,
dann braucht man auch ein größeres Messer.
Oder wenn man Fleisch schneidet und dann, das ist Dual Use, damit lassen sich
andere Dinge machen. Und dann sagen die, also da war ja auch die Idee,
wir verbieten Messer, aber man kann Messer in dem Sinne nicht verbieten.
Also das sind alles solche albernen Debatten.
Wir könnten auch genau dieselbe Sendung jetzt machen und sagen,
wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass es Autos gibt, mit denen man so viele Menschen plattfahren kann.
Ja, also ganz konkret die Frage BMW, warum fährt das Auto weiter?
Nach 30 Kontakten mit Menschen, warum fährt das Auto weiter?
Könnte man auch fragen, so machen wir auch eine Sendung zu.
Also wirklich absurd, du hast jetzt diese Waffenverbotszonen,
da haben wir in Frankfurt zwei Diskussionen, in Sachsenhausen und Bahnhofsviertel.
Waffenverbotszonen heißen Waffenverbotszonen, sind aber eigentlich,
die Polizei darf ja alles zonen.
Also wenn ab 20 Uhr Waffenverbotszone heißt, ist das nur das Signal an die Polizei,
die muss dir nicht erklären, warum sie dich festhalten und dich komplett durchsuchen.
So, in deren Sicht ist das zumindest verlogen. Aber da steckt noch eine Intention
dahinter, die man unter Sicherheitsgesichtspunkten, okay und so,
ja, lass mal die Polizei mal 20 Uhr machen, was sie will.
Hier, das, was wir bisher gehört haben, ist einfach dumm. Das ist unreflektiertes,
dummes Zeug, mit dem Oma Erna irgendwie das Gefühl von, man hätte das verhindern
können, der Täter ist gar nicht der Schuldige, sondern wer wäre eigentlich so.
Sonst feiert man immer die Polizei und alle ab.
Also die Verbindung gibt es ja tatsächlich, man könnte auch die Debatte führen,
ja der Luigi hätte den CEO nicht erschießen können, wenn der CEO in einer Tiefgarage geparkt hätte.
Genau.
Warum musste der über eine Straße gehen?
Hätte man eine Tiefgarage gehabt.
Wäre es alles nicht passiert.
Also das ist alles schon mal nicht gut. Jetzt kommen wir so langsam zu diesen anderen Sachen.
Wir hören ja ein Gespräch, es ist alles strunzdumm.
Lassen Sie uns vielleicht einen Satz zum mutmaßlichen Täter verlieren.
Das, was wir bisher wissen, ist, dass er wohl aus Saudi-Arabien stammen soll,
seit 2006 in Deutschland.
So, zwei Stunden nach dem Anschlag, man kommt aus Saudi-Arabien,
klicken natürlich alle Sehgewohnheiten, alle Skripte einfach rein.
Dass man danach sehr viel mehr mit der Aufklärung seine eigenen Fehler machen
muss, als mit der Tat in den kommenden Tagen, wird ja einfach ausgeblendet. Sie hauen einfach raus.
Dafür haben wir eigentlich andere Medienkanäle, über die wir zu Recht lachen
und die wir ignorieren und so weiter und so fort.
Warum das CDF das jetzt so mitmacht, ist völlig unklar.
Als Arzt praktiziert den Sicherheitsbehörden nicht.
Ich kann dir sagen, sie sind ja schon von Springer und all denen so getrieben,
dass wenn das jetzt ein islamistischer Anschlag wäre und sie hätten es dann
nicht in Minute 1 schon dreimal betont, dann würde man ihnen den Vorwurf machen, da seht ihr wieder,
das linke ÖAR, so funktioniert es halt.
Was aber bedeutet.
Deswegen liefern sie jetzt immer schon alles mit.
Genau, die eigentlichen Terroropfer sind hier vor allem auch die Medien.
Ja.
Ja, und genau so sagen wir das. Hier haben wir Medien, die sich gefesselt,
der Chefredakteur ist heute Abend der Terrorist.
Sie wissen aber noch nicht allzu
viel und deswegen versuchen Sie hier über Gespräche Sinn herzustellen.
...bekannt sein soll. Das klingt als Laie nach einem untypischen Täter.
Es ist auch. Also erstens, das Alter ist relativ hoch.
Wir hatten ja doch in der Vergangenheit, jetzt in den letzten 24 Monaten,
Täter, die immer jünger geworden sind, bis hin zu 15 Jahren.
Einer der Täter, die an der Vorbereitung
der Anschläge auf das Taylor Swift-Konzert in Wien beteiligt war.
Also das Alter ist ungewöhnlich.
Das Alter ist ungewöhnlich, ja, dass diejenigen, das ist ja zum Beispiel in Schweden und so,
auch gezielte Taktik, dass diejenigen, die was auch immer für politische,
terroristische Motive haben, sich dann einfach Minderjährige nehmen,
weil sie wissen, die sind halt feuerfrei.
Also das ist durchaus eine Strategie. Wenn jetzt hier der Alte selber zuschlägt,
also ich weiß nicht genau, wo die Botschaft jetzt für Oma Erna stecken soll,
dass es typischerweise immer jüngere Leute sind.
Also hat man jetzt hier auch noch falsch beobachtet, da muss man jetzt die Alten
auch alle wieder in die Überwachung holen, wenn sie aus einem muslimischen Land
eingewandert sind, vor 20 Jahren.
Nationalität ist ungewöhnlich. Das letzte Mal, dass Saudis an einem islamistischen
Terroranschlag beteiligt waren, war 2001.
Da waren 18.
Der Typ lebt seit 20 Jahren in Deutschland. Was hat er mit Saudi-Arabien zu
tun? Aus dieser Richtung kann man auch fragen. Das ist also.
Attentäter bei 9-11 aus Saudi-Arabien. Normalerweise sehen wir andere Nationalitäten.
Also wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen, dass es ein Einzeltäter war und nicht zum
Beispiel die Terrororganisation, der sogenannte Islamische Staat.
Was heißt das dann jetzt für uns, für die Zuschauenden? Also es ist ja schwer.
Das ist jetzt die entscheidende Frage. Was heißt das eigentlich schon?
Nach so einem Attentat zu sagen, und jetzt geht das Leben einfach weiter,
sondern das, was Terroristen...
Das können die Medien auch langsamer verstehen. Egal was im Fernsehen passiert,
das Leben geht immer weiter.
Es klingt irgendwie kritisch und so, aber...
Ja, das wird hier jetzt als empathielos und attestiert wahrscheinlich, aber das ist nun mal so.
Und für die Zuschauenden bedeutet ein solcher Terroranschlag in erster Linie,
dass der Krimi 20 Minuten später anfängt, weil die noch die Sendung haben.
Genau. Wir haben selber hier Rutger Breschmann gelesen, wie er sagt,
im Krieg blühen die Leute auf.
Das Leben geht nicht nur weiter, sondern die Leute sagen sogar später, war besser als zuvor.
Die Solidarität war toll. Genau.
Karolin Ehmke kommt aus Kriegsgebieten zurück und sagt, was mich am meisten
beeindruckt ist, dass trotzdem, egal was da passiert, und da ist gerade ein
Haus, vor dem zerschossen wurden, das Leben geht weiter, da wird Wäsche aufgehangen,
im Bus wird der Fahrzeug kontrolliert. Und es war ja tatsächlich so.
Dass sehr viele Leute, so habe ich zum Beispiel gehört bei SWR 4,
meinem Heimatsender, wo der Schlager noch ein Zuhause hat, da waren Leute,
die einen Tag, zwei Tage später interviewt wurden und die zum Weihnachtsmarkt
gingen und sagten, jetzt ist recht.
Zum Beispiel, genau. Also alle Paradigmen, alle Prämissen dieses Gesprächs sind irgendwie doof.
Versuchen ist ja Angst zu schüren.
Ja, die Terroristen versuchen Angst zu schüren. Nur wie kommt die Angst zu Hause an bei Oma Erna?
Das schafft der Terrorist nicht. Dafür braucht er die Real-Life-Berichterstattung.
Haben wir noch ein Bild von dem Auto im Weihnachtsmarkt? Ja,
haben wir. Könnt ihr es bitte einblenden?
Das ist das CDF, das diesen Terror verbreitet.
Ja, also es ist schon klar, wenn es jetzt nicht hier um einen Amoklauf handeln würde.
Was wäre der Unterschied? Da fährt jemand mit einem Auto auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt,
tötet fünf Leute, hunderte Paläste. Puh, zum Glück nur Amok.
Ja, in Trier gab es ja den Fall. In Trier ist ja ein Amokfahrer ohne ein politisches
Motiv reingefahren in die Einkaufszone und hat dort auch viele Menschen ermordet.
Und das war für alle, die da drumherum standen, für die Betroffenen,
für alle, war es genauso schlimm.
Man hat aber dann natürlich nicht noch den Terrorismusexperten dazuschalten können.
Also medial verändert sich was. Medial verändert sich was.
Genau. Wir hören mal ihn hier, ach nee, ihn hören wir nicht zu Ende.
Also dieses Gespräch ist, wie es ist.
Wir hören eine Kurzmeldung, eine
Kurzmeldung, kontextfrei, in einem Kurznachrichten-Blog am selben Abend.
Der US-Milliardär Elon Musk hat sich in den deutschen Wahlkampf eingeschaltet
mit einer Wahlempfehlung für die AfD.
Auf seinem Kurznachrichtendienst X schrieb der Berater von Donald Trump,
nur die AfD könne Deutschland retten.
Während es dafür von Spitzenkandidatin Weidel Zustimmung gab,
zeigten sich Vertreter anderer Parteien empört.
Bundeskanzler Scholz sagte, die Meinungsfreiheit gelte auch für Multimilliardäre. Milliardär.
Das ist doch alles super witzig. Scholz erinnert Musk an die Meinungsfreiheit.
Oder uns, dass Musk sie auch hat.
Ja, Musk hat doch deswegen X gekauft. Er wollte doch eine Arena of Free Speech.
So. Da muss man aber sofort eine Berichterstattung machen, wie Musk das selbst
untergräbt und es ihm um seine Meinungsfreiheit ging und er diese 40 Milliarden
aufwandte, um die anderen Meinungsfreiheiten zu unterdrücken.
Und der Typ hat sich doch auf X ein Jahr lang erklärt.
Es ist doch Musks Aufgabe als Besitzer, die Sicherheitsbehörden darüber zu informieren,
was auf seiner Plattform los ist, wenn dort jemand Massenmord ankündigt.
Ja, und das wird kontaktiert. Und das Weide darüber sehr erfreut ist,
da fahren wir noch. Ach nee.
Das hätte ich mir selber denken können, aber der Rest ist doch interessant.
Also wirklich schlimm. Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm. Sie müssen uns natürlich noch ein paar Bilder zeigen.
Bundeskanzler Scholz und weitere Bundespolitiker.
Also die stehen einfach mit ihrer Kamera neben dem Einsatz.
Nutzen das als Schnittbild.
Haben mit Entsetzen auf den mutmaßlichen Anschlag reagiert. Auf der Plattform
Ex schrieb Scholz, die Meldungen aus Magdeburg lassen Schlimmes erahnen.
Meine Gedanken sind bei den Opfern und ihren Angehörigen.
Der Weihnachtsmarkt war nach der Tat geschlossen worden. Auch der Straßenbahnverkehr
in Magdeburg wurde eingestellt.
Hagen Thober ist für uns vor Ort in Magdeburg. Hagen, wie ist die Situation derzeit?
Ja, wie ist die Situation derzeit? Also, wir sehen hier schon mit seinem Telefon, ne?
Ja.
Er telefoniert mit Ingo Zamperoni, weil irgendeine andere Art von Leitung hat
mal wieder nicht funktioniert. Also so ein einseitiger Satellitenbetrieb.
Er kann nur vom Tatort senden.
So, Telefon heißt für mich, ich habe auch ein Telefon. Ich kann auch jemanden
in Magdeburg anrufen und fragen, wie ist die Stimmung vor Ort.
Dafür brauche ich nicht Ingo Zamperoni.
Und Olaf Scholz kondoliert auf X, auf Elon Musks Plattform bei so einem Event.
Ja.
Was ist denn da schiefgegangen? Und wieso kann uns das CDF nicht darüber oder
hier Tagesthemen Informationen geben?
Das wäre mal interessant, ja.
Das ist doch skandalös.
Dass wir keinen anderen Kanal mehr haben für deutsche Politiker,
um offizielle Statements abzugeben.
440 Mitarbeiter des Bundespresseamts.
Ja.
Und die sagen, Olaf, du musst twittern. Also dafür brauche ich keinen Staatsmann.
Also dann lieber schweigen, auf Twitter kondolieren und auszublenden,
dass das Elon Musk und die Plattform des Täters ist und dass hier eine Art von
Free Speech sein soll, so einen Attentat auf so einen Weihnachtsmarkt zu machen.
Also es geht drunter und drüber. Alice Weidel macht eine Veranstaltung vor Ort
und statt dass die Medien sagen, soll sie mal, übernehmen sie die Pressearbeit
für diese Veranstaltung.
Zu wenig steht die Politik an der Seite derer, die unter den Fehlern unserer
Regierungen leiden müssen.
Zu sehr steht Die Relativierung der Taten derer im Mittelpunkt,
die unsere Gesellschaft verachten.
Warum hat Alice Weidel das Recht,
das ZDF zu nutzen, um ihre Weihnachtsansprache aus dem Terroreinsatzgebiet sozusagen,
also vom Tatort, mir zu Hause hinzulegen. Warum bezahle ich dafür Gebühren?
Also ich sehe auch gar keinen Sinn mehr darin. Also ich würde auch sagen,
hätten das ZDF jetzt einfach Winterpause gemacht, wäre es für alle besser gewesen,
vor allem für die Meinungsfreiheit in Deutschland.
Absolut. Einfach nichts zu senden, wäre wirklich, wäre Helene Pescher.
Also ich meine, man muss, ja, ich will das kurz erwähnen, ja,
Helene Fischer, ich habe die Show nicht ganz geguckt oder ich habe sie fast
gar nicht gesehen, ich habe bei YouTube so ein paar Dinge nachgeholt und interessanterweise,
nach wirklich Ewigkeiten nochmal, im Fernsehen auf großer Bühne, Reinhard May.
Reinhard Mai singt erst ein Lied allein mit den Kölner Philharmonikern.
Und dann singt er mit Helene Fischer ein Duett, ein Lied, das heißt Wir,
das ist schon alt, von 1990, über eine Ehe, die Schwierigkeiten natürlich hat,
aber ob es nicht doch auch geht.
Wirklich grandios, auch von ihr, muss ich sagen. Also die beiden machen das
perfekt. Also wir haben da den, ich glaube, 82-jährigen Reinhard Mai.
Musst du mir nicht sagen.
Ja, ich weiß, du magst das ja auch, wie sie da für Udo Jürgen singt,
aber die beiden da, muss ich sagen, das ist wirklich ganz großartig gemacht
und ich würde auch festhalten wollen, macht lieber nur noch sowas im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen,
dann lasst das lieber mit der Kultur ganz, bevor da so andere rankommen,
dann Helene Fischer, Reinhard May, Reinhard May sowieso ein großartiger Texter und dann ist gut.
Und was hier stattfindet, ist absurd und hat dieses Hinterherhecheln.
Einmal muss man sich natürlich nichts gefallen lassen, wenn dann tituliert wird,
wir sind links beim ÖR, deswegen müssen wir jetzt die ganze Zeit die AfD protegieren.
Und dann hat man noch eben diesen Korrespondenten am Telefon, der jetzt...
Eine Exklusivität herstellen soll, wo es einfach keine gibt.
Ja, also wir kommen jetzt auf diesen Korrespondenten.
Soll ich das kurz beschreiben, was da los war?
Wir können es gleich beschreiben.
Weil.
Wir sehen auch Ausschnitte wie.
Den Clip habe ich natürlich bei Instagram gesehen, der wurde mir geschickt.
Wir lernen ihn erstmal kennen, es ist wirklich grotesk. Wir hören nur kurze
Snippets, wie so seine Korrespondenten Beiträge aussehen.
Großes Rätsel ist, der Mann ist Arzt, der hat seit 2006 hier in Sachsen als Arzt praktiziert.
Eigentlich jemand, der Menschen helfen soll und der richtet jetzt solchen Schaden an.
Ja, eigentlich jemand, der Menschen helfen soll, richtet jetzt solchen Schaden
an. Also Oma Erna, ich verstehe es auch nicht.
So. Wer ein Krankenhaus von innen kennt, weiß,
ja, ja, die haben da irgendwann mal einen hypokratischen Eid gehabt und die
wissen auch, wie eine Leber funktioniert, aber als Arzt hechelst du von Ding
zu Ding und als Psychiater kriegst du quasi nur Anrufe von und hier wieder Notfallen,
da wieder, der ist suizidal und so weiter. Habt ihr Plätze?
Nein, haben wir nicht. Keine Ahnung. Es ist alles ist Stress, ja.
Ich dachte immer, das sei wie in der Schwarzwaldklinik.
Ja. Welche Sehgewohnheit soll bei Oma, genau.
Ja, Schwarzwaldklinik. Klaus Jörg Rosso.
Ein Arzt, der eigentlich Menschen helfen soll. Ja, ja, genau.
Der soll eigentlich Menschen helfen, aber der Mensch ist sozusagen,
der ist schon in Narkose, bevor der Arzt den Raum betritt, ja,
bis schnell, schnell geht und so.
In Schulen ist wie bei unserer Lehrer Dr. Spech.
Ja.
Also wir haben da ganz klar.
Ja, also es ist wirklich, das ist schon mal bescheuert. Jetzt kommt ein Spruch,
wo ich mir denke, Das kann einfach nicht wahr sein.
Offiziell heißt es, es gibt zwei Tote, also ein Erwachsener und ein Kleinkind.
Sehr tragisch. Wir haben morgen den vierten Advent. Weihnachten steht vor der
Tür für die Angehörigen sehr schwer.
Ja, wenn nicht Weihnachten wäre, wäre alles halb so wild. Oder was?
Also es ist ja, das Ding ist, es ist sinnlos.
Also die einzige gute Korrespondenz wäre zu sagen, ich stehe hier,
ich weiß nicht warum, ich kann Ihnen auch nichts sagen, zurück ins Studio.
Also, wenn deine Familienangehörigen auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt überfahren werden,
ist Weihnachten vorbei.
Dann ist auch egal, ob Weihnachten gewesen wäre oder was auch immer.
Dann ist einfach dieser vierte Advent, spielt dann keine Rolle mehr.
Und wie er hier noch in dieser Sehgewohnheit bleiben kann, oh Mann,
dieser Tatort hinter mir, das
ist wirklich so schlimm. Und zwei Tage vor Weihnachten musste das sein.
Das kann man doch noch nicht mal vor der Kamera dann reflektieren.
Man muss sich doch Gedanken machen, was man da sagt.
Und das ist einfach, das geht einfach gar nicht. So, Interview,
Pressekonferenz-Settings.
Jetzt will ich auch was gegen die Politik sagen, denn so geht es einfach nicht.
Wir hören jetzt die Oberbürgermeisterin in einem Pressekonferenz-Setting,
das so schlimm ist anzusehen.
Also wenn man denkt, okay, die Abendnachrichten sind wichtig,
damit man nochmal sieht, der Staat funktioniert, was auch immer.
Ich bin emotional aufgewühlt, das hätte auch mir passieren können.
Es erreicht mich näher, als ich wusste gar nicht, dass Magdeburg mir so nah ist, wie auch immer.
Leute können ja tatsächlich emotional betroffen sein und nicht einfach nur erleiden,
dass jetzt die nachfolgenden Sendungen sich verschieben.
Die Politik muss sich hier von den Medien emanzipieren. Vielleicht sollten wir
wirklich den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk abschaffen, damit das Verhältnis
zwischen Politik und Medien artgerecht verfeindet ausgestaltet wird.
Denn dieser Scheiß, der hier stattfindet, das geht so nicht.
Also so verliere auch ich jedes Zutrauen in den Staat und seine Handlungsfähigkeit.
Ja, als betroffene Oberbürgermeisterin der Landeshauptstadt Magdeburg kann ich
nur sagen, wie erschüttert und zutiefst betroffen ich bin und bin mit dem Herzen bei denen.
Und ich meine nicht ihren Wortbeitrag, wir sehen gleich, was wir sehen.
Von mir ist auch sie weinen, sie ist auch ergriffen.
Da sind jetzt, da sind jetzt ein Dutzend Mikrofone zappeln vor ihrem Gesicht
drum und jeder versucht noch näher an ihren Mund zu kommen.
Sie ist nicht ausgeleuchtet, sie steht irgendwo im Hintergrund einen Tisch mit
zwei Flaschen, also Standardbewirtung Situationen in so Behörden.
Sollten die sich da hinsetzen oder was? Keiner versteht, sie wird von der Seite
gefilmt, die Kameraleute hatten gar keine Aufstellposition und irgendein Typ
steht mit seinem Oh, ich muss das hier abhören, was sie sagt.
Ich habe also noch ein billigstes Kabel, was auch immer, an meinem Aufnahmegerät
und halte ihr das auf Augenhöhe zwischen Politikerin und Kamera für die Tagesnehmen.
Entschuldigung, bei den Opfern und bei den Angehörigen.
Und wir haben uns überlegt, dass wir in der Nähe die Möglichkeit des Trauerns eröffnen wollen.
Und zwar an der Johanniskirche wollen wir die Möglichkeit schaffen,
dass man innehalten kann und in unmittelbarer Nähe des Tatortes dann tatsächlich
eben auch Blumen niederlegen kann und einfach derer gedenken,
die da Opfer geworden sind von einer Gewalttat,
die ihresgleichen sucht. Also ich bin zutiefst erschüttert.
Ja, ich war jetzt in Dortmund, habe da auch Termine mit dem Oberbürgermeister
gehabt und habe ihm ja sozusagen zugerufen, gestalten Sie, kommen Sie in eine
Rolle, in der Sie medial was hermachen, verbünden Sie sich mit den anderen Oberbürgermeistern
hier aus dem Ruhrpott, zeigen Sie,
ja, ja, in Berlin schön und gut, aber wir sind das Ruhrgebiet,
machen Sie hier einen kommunalpolitischen Aufschlag.
Was vor allem bedeutet, machen Sie sich Gedanken über Ihre Ästhetik.
Wenn Sie Pressekonferenzen machen, und das machen Sie als Politiker,
dann machen Sie bitte Pressekonferenzen.
Kein Politiker darf näher als fünf Meter an sie ran. Sie stehen auf einer Bühne.
Da ist ein Licht, das kann eingeschaltet werden.
Sie haben ein Mikrofon, der Rest wird gepoolt. Die Leute stecken ja ein Kabel
irgendwo rein. Niemand steht im Bild.
Holen sie sich alle Verantwortlichen auf die Bühne. Machen sie es wie die Amerikaner im Grunde.
Gut, aber in Magdeburg haben die noch nie so Presse gehabt.
Magdeburg zählt zu den 80 urbanen Zentren mit mehr als 100.000 Einwohnern.
Das sind Großstädte. die haben eine ich kenne es natürlich nicht,
aber die haben Räumlichkeiten.
Das sind Bilder der Überforderung von allen Seiten.
Total.
Und man braucht diese Bilder auch nicht, weil sie führen jetzt so gar nichts.
Naja, vor Ort schon. Also diese Pressekonferenz ist ja für die Magdeburger.
Ja, aber deswegen muss die ja nicht mit den Tagesthemen sein.
Genau, aber auch für die Magdeburger muss es ordentlich gemacht werden.
Ja, wegen mir, ja.
Und auch nicht Termine irgendwie anberauben, von denen man nicht weiß, was man hier hält.
Und das war ja bei, als der Ministerpräsident dann da war, mit dem Korrespondenten von der ARD,
das war in so einer Live-Schalte wohl, also in einem Live-Stream,
da wurde ja einfach der Ministerpräsident, der ein Statement in andere Mikrofone
gab, unterbrochen vom Korrespondent der ARD,
der sagte, hier ist Ingo Zamperoni, der will mit Ihnen sprechen, dann nimmt der,
Ministerpräsidenten das Handy und redet dann mit Zamperoni weiter und alle Kameras
bilden das noch ab und zeigen das dann in den sozialen Medien,
so habe ich es ja dann auch gesehen.
Und dann denke ich mir, dass solche Bilder da unterlaufen, ist einfach auch
ein Selbstverständnis von Journalisten, wo ich sage, ihr habt jetzt,
ihr könnt da jetzt gerade gar nicht helfen, ihr könnt eigentlich nur stören.
Deswegen kann man sich dann nicht mal bitte zurücknehmen.
Rainer Hasselhoff war da und stand auf der Straße. Er kann von mir aus eine
Begehung des Tatorts machen, um sich ein Bild zu verschaffen,
weil er redet ja danach öffentlich.
Es wäre schon nicht verkehrt, da Bescheid zu wissen.
Nur das öffentliche Reden und dass sich etwas anschauen muss,
Also ganz zwingend getrennt werden. Dieser Tatort gehört dann auch abgesperrt.
Der Ministerpräsident ist da in formaler Funktion. Da hat kein Journalist was zu suchen.
So und die Situation war ja dann so, dass er sich da hat überrumpeln lassen
von oh, zehn Mikrofone. Ja klar, ich rede ja gerne in Mikrofone.
So und dann steht der Korrespondent, den wir eben gehört haben,
direkt Schulter an Schulter neben ihn und telefoniert in voller Lautstärke mit
Ingo Zamperoni oder halt der Redaktion und kriegt dann das Signal so jetzt ist Ingo live.
Du kannst das Telefon jetzt rübergeben, ergibt es Rainer Hasselhoff,
der greift einfach zu, sagt, ach Ingo Zamaroni, ja, dann telefoniere ich jetzt
mit dem, während alle Journalisten weiter eigentlich ihre Fragen vor Ort stellen
wollten und dann auch reinrufen, wir haben auch Fragen.
Also das war ein, also das passte so wenig zu dieser Situation,
wie sie hätte gestaltet werden müssen von den Politikern.
Es ist von allen völlig anstrücklich.
So, wir gucken jetzt noch was ganz Schlimmes. Konstantin Kuhle.
Sie reden gerne mit Bundespolitikern, ist ja klar. Was hat Konstantin Kuhle mit Magdeburg zu tun?
Wir wissen es nicht, keine Ahnung. Er ist irgendwie im Sicherheitsrat da,
im Sicherheitsausschuss des Bundestages, wird also jede Woche mal informiert über irgendwas.
Wie auch immer, reines ProPorts, wie es heißt, die ihn hier als Gesprächspartner klassifiziert.
Er ist zugeschaltet aus einem, kennen wir ja seit Corona, ach,
sie sind im Hotel und sie haben ja einen Airports dabei, ja,
kein Problem, wir führen jetzt mit ihnen ein Gespräch über, so,
was die FDP da abliefert.
Wir sind jetzt ganz hart in diesem schlechten Schauspiel.
Also schlechteres Schauspiel gibt es gar nicht als das.
Haben wir uns da alle zu sehr an solche Warnungen auch gewöhnt und nehmen sie
vielleicht auch nicht ernst genug, gerade acht Jahre nach dem Anschlag in Berlin
auf dem Breitscheidplatz?
So, das ist der 20. Das ist also der Tattag. Dieses Ereignis hat außer dass
es aussieht wie am Breitscheidplatz nichts damit zu tun.
Also die Motivationslage ist anders, der Täter ist ein anderer,
es ist einfach alles anders und Konstantin Kuhle.
Das ist ein ganz schrecklicher Abend, nicht nur für Magdeburg,
für Sachsen-Anhalt, sondern für unser ganzes Land.
Und es gibt kaum eine Floskel eines Politikers, die an einem solchen Abend die
Trauer und den Schrecken in irgendeiner Weise angemessen beschreiben könnte.
Es gibt kaum eine Floskel.
Ja, und er beginnt die Antwort mit einer Floskel. Das ist nicht nur für und und und.
Es gibt kaum eine Floskel. Wir hören jetzt eine und überlegen mal,
ist das jetzt eine, die sich noch eignet, also die nicht zu denen kaum gehört.
Diese Antwort, diese erste Antwort, die er hier gibt, in der kommt,
nachdem er die Floskeln eigentlich ausschließen wollte, noch diese Floskel vor.
Jeder Anschlag in dieser Form ist einer zu viel.
Ach nee.
Aber in einer anderen Form ging es, oder was?
Also mir ist es völlig unklar, was hier passiert. Der islamistische Terrorismus
darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen.
Richtig ist, dass die...
Richtig ist, nicht dass du dich wunderst und noch offene Gedanken zum Thema
hast. Richtig ist, was Konstantin Kuhle jetzt sagt.
Richtig ist, dass die abstrakte Gefahr des islamistischen Terrorismus in Deutschland
und Europa nie weg gewesen ist.
Und wir haben uns womöglich in den letzten Jahren zu sehr daran gewöhnt,
dass diese Gefahr im Hintergrund stattfindet.
Was heißt wir? Also bin ich jetzt durch Koblenz gerannt und habe mich zu sehr
daran gewöhnt, an den Islamismus.
Das fand halt im Hintergrund statt, also im Hintergrund bei 45.000 Followern
mit einem Maschinengewehr und der Botschaft, das ist ein Arzt,
der hier ein Magdeburg-Psychiater ist.
Und offenbar ist es ja kein Islamismus, wie sich wohl jetzt so herauszustellen scheint.
Also es ist wirklich, cool, ihr möchtet jetzt nochmal appellieren an alle?
Ich kann nur an alle wahlkampfführenden Parteien und an alle Kollegen,
Politikerinnen und Politiker appellieren, sich in den nächsten Tagen im Wahlkampf zurückzuhalten.
Ich rufe dazu auf, innezuhalten, gerade über die Weihnachtsfeiertage,
die Opfer und ihre Angehörigen trauern zu lassen.
Gerade über die Weihnachtsfeiertage. Also zwei Tage Waffenstillstand, danach Feuer frei.
Weil Weihnachten ist ja ein besonderes Fest. Finde ich auch sehr interessant.
Ulf Poschert hat ja einen riesigen Fünfspalter geschrieben in der Welt über
den Angriff auf die Christen oder so. Also die Christen standen ja schon.
Genau.
Das ist Magdeburg. In Magdeburg gibt es keine Christen. Das ist Ostdeutschland.
Wenn man sich das auf einer Karte anguckt, ja, da gibt es noch Kirchen und einen
Ministerpräsidenten, der dann ganz pflichtbewusst in diese Kirche geht und so
eine Entourage mitbringt.
Aber da ist nichts mit der christlichen Weihnachtsmarkt.
Zumal der Weihnachtsmarkt jetzt an sich natürlich aus dem christlichen Anlass
heraus entsteht, aber das ist nun wirklich kein christlicher Markt in dem Sinne,
das hat wirklich nichts damit zu tun.
Also man wird nirgendwo finden, weder in der Bibel noch in anderen Schriften,
esset viele Mandeln und Krippelchen und besauft euch mit Glühwein,
also das ist nirgendwo zu finden und das ist aber interessant, dass,
also bei Ulf Poschert kann man das ja sehr schön sehen, dass dann,
Und Ole hatte dann so kommentiert, naja, ich würde auch so einen Artikel schreiben,
wenn eigentlich dieser Attentäter ein bisschen so klingt wie viele Weltkommentierer,
die dann unten so ganz wütend irgendwas reinschreiben.
Und dann hat Ulf Posch dann nochmal drauf geantwortet, also auf Ole und sagte
dann, ja, so nach dem Motto, das ist so die linke Dominanz in den Medien.
Und das ist interessant, dass also jemand, der bei Springer ist,
und ich will hier betonen, er ist ja auch nur Angestellter, er ist ja gar nicht
der Unternehmer, für den er sich mal hält, er ist ja wirklich nur der Angestellte,
aber dass er bei so einem wirkmächtigen Konzern ist, der durch Zukäufe jetzt
noch mächtiger geworden ist und aber nach wie vor sich verfolgt glaubt von einer
linken Dominanz, die dann zur Not ausgeht von Ole,
der einen kleinen Podcast mit mir zusammen macht.
Aber wir sind am Ende dominanter als der Springer-Konzern.
Ich würde sagen, ich wünschte, es wäre so. Es ist aber leider nicht so.
Selbst wenn Le Pen zusammen mit Trump eine G20-Sitzung eröffnet, um sie abzuschaffen.
Und hier in Deutschland die AfD mit 27 Prozent im Bundestag sitzt.
Und alles in Grund und Boden argumentiert.
Dann werden die bei Beispiel...
Heißt es immer noch, aber der hat gegendert. Die am Mainstream der Genderer...
Ja, dann werden die immer noch sagen, dass das Jacobin und die Gender Studies
an der Uni Trier das Problem sind.
Ja, absolut. Konstantin Kuhle hat jetzt hier den Appell an die Politiker gemacht.
Ja.
Noch in demselben Statement mit diesem Appell, sich jetzt zurückzuhalten und
es nicht parteipolitisch Wahlkampf auszubeuten, gerade nicht zu Weihnachten, kommt das hier.
Dann warum ein 50-Jähriger mit einer unbefristeten Aufenthaltserlaubnis eingebettet
in einen Arbeitsplatz sowas macht, das sind die Punkte, auf die es jetzt ankommt.
Das ist Aufgabe der Sicherheitsbehörden und die Parteien sollten sich mit dieser
Frage des Terroranschlags im Wahlkampf jetzt zurückhalten.
Ein 50-Jähriger, der die Hälfte seines bewussten Lebens in Deutschland lebt,
als Arzt arbeitet, der macht hier keine Arbeit, der ist embedded.
Das ist eigentlich ein Schläfer. Was natürlich jetzt eine besondere Herausforderung
ist, wo wir doch 7000 syrische Ärzte haben, die größte Ausländeranteile in der
deutschen Ärzteschaft sind, die sind alle Schläfer in dieser Logik.
Aber jetzt zu Weihnachten Ball flach halten und so.
Scholz vor Ort, er hat sich kurz versprochen.
Die Stimmung in der Stadt am Morgen gespenstisch ruhig. Die Spuren der Nacht noch sichtbar.
Mittags kommen der Bundeskanzler und Sachsen-Anhalts Ministerpräsident zum Anschlagsort,
sprechen Anteilnahme und Dankaus bitten um Solidarität.
Mir ist wichtig, dass wenn so ein schlimmes, furchtbares Ereignis stattfindet,
ein so furchterer Anschlag, dass wir als Land zusammenbleiben,
dass wir zusammenhalten und dass wir uns unterhalten,
Arken, dass nicht Hass unser Miteinander bestimmt.
Ja, dieses zweimal furchtbar sagen. Beim ersten Mal habe ich es ihm ja noch abgenommen.
Und mit ersten Mal meine ich nicht das erste Furchtbar, sondern als er über
Putins erneute Atomwaffendrohung sprach und öffentlich sagte, Furchtbar, Furchtbar.
Und Robin Alexander hat sich ja in seinem Podcast schon darüber beschwert,
dass das sehr instrumenteller Einsatz von Furchtbar, Furchtbar ist.
Weil Oma Erna natürlich auf furchtbar sofort reagiert und sagt,
das ist so furchtbar. Atombomben und so.
Jetzt hier in dieses Redemanuskript, Putin bedroht uns mit Atomwaffen zurückzufallen,
furchtbar zu sagen und sich dann zu erinnern, nee, stärker ist,
wenn ich es zweimal sage.
Das ist auch schlechtes Schauspiel. Das ist so weit weg von Authentizität.
Sehr gut, finde ich aber, wie er zuerst sagte, wir sollten uns unterhalten.
Ach nee, Unterhaken. Denn wir sollten uns wirklich mehr unterhalten, was das angeht.
Peter Neumann, ich versuche mal schnell zu finden, hat ja eine sehr gute Instagram-Kachel
gemacht, in dem er kurz darauf hinwies, ich lese mal vor.
Terrorismus-Experte muss man dazu sagen. Genau, also Terrorismus-Forscher,
nicht jemand mal schnell zugerufen, sondern ja.
So, und das heißt jetzt für uns, Zäsuren erkennen und Surrender-Momente besonders betonen.
Also ich möchte an einen erinnern, nur damit ihr kurz versteht, um was es geht.
Wenn der außenpolitische Beauftragte, Referat 6, Kanzleramt, Christoph Heusken,
uns sagt, noch drei Tage vor Putins Angriff habe ich es nicht geglaubt, dass es geschieht,
dann ist das nicht irgendeine Meinung oder so, sondern dann müssen wir das ganz
ernst nehmen und jeder, der sagt, also ich habe das gewusst,
der hat doch schon immer so geredet und so weiter und so fort,
das gilt dann einfach alles nicht.
Also es wird durch einen Typen aufgewogen, der sagt, ich habe Merkels Außenpolitik gemacht.
Ich habe Putin getroffen, mehr als jeder andere Deutsche.
Ich habe auf ihm in Russisch über seine Politik gesprochen und ich habe es drei
Tage vorher mir nicht vorstellen können, dass es passieren.
So, dann bedeutet das was. Und wenn nun Peter Neumann, der Terrorismusforscher,
auf X schreibt, oder er hat es auf X geschrieben und die Deutschlandfunk hat
es dann für uns in so einer Kachel aufbreitet, nach 25 Jahren in diesem Geschäft,
in Anführungszeichen Geschäft, denkst du, nichts könnte dich mehr überraschen.
Aber ein 50-jähriger saudischer Ex-Muslim, der in Ostdeutschland lebt,
die AfD liebt und Deutschland für seine Toleranz gegenüber Islamisten bestrafen
will, das hatte ich wirklich nicht auf dem Zettel.
Und es wird uns nächstes Jahr ganz viel begegnen, solche Sachen,
dass Sachen passieren, die wir nicht auf dem Zettel hatten.
Wie zum Beispiel, dass Donald Trump dieses Big Business,
Big Pharma, Big Finance, was auch immer, zerschlägt und plötzlich Elizabeth
Warren vielleicht die größten, auf diese Themen bezogenen, öffentlichen Bekundungen dazu abgibt.
Während gleichzeitig ein Deportationsprogramm läuft aus Texas,
wo wir uns alle fragen, ich habe diesen Film Siege gesehen, also da sagt Bruce
Willis, sie wollen das nicht, liebe Politiker, dass wir diese Migrationspolitik machen.
Aber jetzt, wo sie uns beauftragen und plötzlich sind da Konzentrationslager
in irgendwelchen Stadien aufgebaut und so.
Also wir werden ganz viele Sehgewohnheiten haben, wo Leute sagen,
sorry, aber das hatte ich nicht auf dem Zettel. Und dann werden sehr viele hämische
und so weiter Kommentare kommen.
Und die muss man dann alle wegwischen und sagen, ja, das sind alles auch toll,
aber mir geht es um diesen Surrender-Moment.
Mir geht es um diese Zäsur. Mir geht es um diese Radikalisierung.
Das wird nächstes Jahr, glaube ich, sehr anstrengend. Aber hier hat man mal
wieder gesehen, wenn ein Terrorexperte da sagt und sagt, das hatte ich nicht
auf dem Zettel, dann ist das der wichtigste Terrorexperte für uns,
den wir fragen können, diesen Themen.
Wenn irgendwer sagt, Polar hätte mal hingestellt werden müssen und so,
dann ist es nicht so gut. Wir hören noch einen Clip.
Wir haben ja vorhin schon gehört, der Münch, der Generalbundesanwalt,
der ja vorher BKA-Chef war,
ist zugeschaltet im Gespräch mit Hayali und das ist auch ein Typ,
wo man sagt, zum Glück traut er sich das einfach öffentlich jetzt so zu sagen
und hoffentlich handelt er dann auch entsprechend.
Ja, wir haben ja viele Herausforderungen aktuell und wir haben immer gesagt,
das Anschlagsrisiko ist nicht weg.
Hier haben wir allerdings keinen Hinweis auf einen islamistisch motivierten Anschlag.
Ganz im Gegenteil, der Sachverhalt selbst von der Tatbegehungsweise,
der lässt sich so einsortieren, wie man das auch.
Könnte. Allerdings eine völlig andere Motivationslage. Ein, wenn man so will,
auch untypischer Täter, der nicht in ein solches Raster passt.
Ja, untypischer Täter passt nicht ins Raster Islamismus.
Ja, das Gegenteil. Das sind jetzt diese mutigen Verwaltungsakte, die wichtig sind.
Spitzenpolitiker, die irgendwelche Scheißpressekonferenzen geben an irgendwelchen
Orten und sich so ein Telefon reichen lassen, weil Ingo Zamperoni jetzt der
wichtigste Gesprächspartner der Welt ist und Ingo Zamperoni lagert seine eigene
Chefredaktion an den Terroristen aus. Das braucht niemand.
Da kann man einfach weggucken. Also öffentlich-rechtliche Nachrichten einfach
ignorieren nächstes Jahr.
Wenn gleich ja die Privatfernsehsender noch schlimmer sind.
Ja, auch ignorieren. Gar keine Nachrichten mehr konsumieren.
So ein paar Podcasts, in denen irgendwann viel zu spät aus dieser Richtung,
aber in zu langer Form irgendwas besprochen wird.
Wer am Tag eines Ereignisses gerne tiefe Analysen haben will.
Kriegt sie nicht. Die gibt es dann einfach nicht.
Gibt's nicht, ja.
In der Hinsicht, das ist wirklich ganz düster gewesen, was da abgelaufen ist
und was soll ich sagen, ich will noch ein, ich habe ja auch so ein paar Podcasts
gehört und so, dass jetzt irgendwelche Leute, da kann man jetzt drauf achten,
sagen wir mal so, darauf können wir achten.
Es gibt jetzt ganz viele Kommentatoren, die aus der Schweiz Podcast machen und
in Dubai sitzen und den jungen Männern Tagebücher schreiben.
Hoss und Hopf.
Hoss und Hopf zum Beispiel, aber auch viele andere. Wenn ein Ereignis aufgegriffen
wird, im Sinne von der Podcast beginnt mit, eigentlich wollten wir erst nächstes
Jahr wieder podcasten, aber jetzt ist ja so krass, das müssen wir alle hier und so weiter.
Und dann macht man so einen Stuhlkreis irgendwie der Seelsorge.
Und die Seelsorge besteht dann daraus, dass man nur die alte Sehgewohnheit,
der deutsche Staat ist so scheiße, ich bin zu Recht weggezogen und mache jetzt
Bitcoin-Pflege in Dubai.
Der Täter wird einfach ausgeblendet, im Mittelsprung steht nur die Tat.
Und die Dysfunktionalität in Deutschland.
Genau, das haben wir bei Hayali gehört, weil der Poller nicht richtig stand.
Da hat man wieder gesehen, in Deutschland funktioniert gar nichts.
Wenn man solche Podcasts hört, kurz den Kopf einschalten und dann den Podcast
ausschalten. Sowas braucht jetzt wirklich niemand.
Ich verstehe aber die Attraktivität.
Aber man kann sich trotzdem dagegen wehren, denn es macht durchaus Sinn, einfach klüger.
In der Hinsicht ist so eine Meditation über sich selber Gedanken machen, was da passiert ist,
führt einen weiter, als sich da einfach von so Ideologien, die nicht mal die
Ideologen, die sie selbst vorbringen, durchschauen, sondern die einfach mit
so einem Flow mitgehen, weil es für sie profitabel ist.
Das ist nun mal die einzige Währung, die da zählt.
Das geht da nicht auf. Und es betrifft aber wirklich sehr viele Podcasts.
Da muss man dann nächstes Jahr seine eigene Nachrichtendiät mal so ein bisschen neu organisieren.
Du hast jetzt eben gesagt, die Kinder haben ihr Smartphone und sehen morgen
schon drei Leute sterben und gehen dann erst zur Oma an den Frühstückstisch.
Sie haben Cybermobbing mitbekommen, sie sind vielleicht sogar daran beteiligt
oder Opfer des Mobbings, sie sehen viele schlimme Dinge.
Jetzt interessiert mich sehr deine Meinung, bist du denn für einen Smartphone-Bann an Schulen?
Absolut. Gut.
Interessant. Denn ich war auch immer dafür, will auch nicht sagen,
dass ich davon komplett abgerückt bin,
habe nur jetzt nochmal über einiges nachgedacht, dadurch, dass ich den Podcast
von Taylor Lawrence gehört habe, der Power User Podcast und da kommt sie auf
diesen Smartphone-Band zu sprechen.
Da gibt es ja jetzt einige Entwicklungen in den USA, die sehr weitreichend schon
sind in vielen Bundesstaaten.
Sie zählt ein bisschen mal auf, wie es sich da verhält.
Lately, a moral panic about kids and smartphone use has been sweeping the country.
Politically driven special interest groups, right-wing billionaires and bad
actors are preying on parents and teachers' fears and misunderstanding of technology
to push for cell phone bans in schools.
Das ist also ein Trend, auch in vielen Bundesstaaten schon.
States, including Florida, Indiana, Ohio, South Carolina and Louisiana,
have all recently passed laws banning cell phones in K-12 schools.
And nearly seven in ten adults support some form of cell phone bands in schools.
Taylor Lawrence ist dagegen. Sie hat nun einen Gast dort, der natürlich auch
aus ökonomischen Interessen gegen einen solchen Bann ist.
Es ist Brandon Cade Hernandez.
Der ist Präsident von der Education Media Company Mrs.
Wordsmith, also die sehr viele Online-Tools auch herstellt, will also durchaus
die Digitalisierung im Klassenzimmer vorantreiben.
Er äußert sich jetzt wie folgt.
Wir sahen, was die Surgeon General report kam aus und war über die crisis der
mentalen health. Und wir sort of stayed in das Raum und wirklich connected es
deeply zu cell phone usage.
Und dann in some ways, ich denke, die ist sort of typisch adult-behagier,
wir haben ourselves aus der equation.
Und das Problem nicht über die Adults-Relationshänge mit Kindern und die Fähigkeiten,
die sie außerhalb der Relation, die wir individuell mit jungen Leuten haben,
sondern wir haben es nur über den Telefon.
Und so habe ich glaube, das hat sich angefangen, die Accountability zu verändern,
was der Adults-Roll ist, in einem jungen Persönlichkeitsentwicklung zu unterstützen
und ihre Möglichkeit, sich zu dem Moment zu adaptieren.
Die Argumentation hier ist, es gibt tatsächlich große Probleme unter jungen Menschen.
Man hat aber jetzt sich mit dem Smartphone einfach ein Opfer rausgesucht oder
hat eine Begründung für all das, was schief läuft, gefunden,
sodass eigentlich die, die in Verantwortung zu ziehen wären,
also zum Beispiel Eltern,
Institutionen, Schulen, Lehrer etc., sich jetzt rausnehmen und sagen,
wir müssen nur das Smartphone entfernen, dann ist alles wieder gut.
Er sieht das auch kritisch unter einem wirtschaftlichen Gesichtspunkt bzw.
Einem Bildungsgesichtspunkt?
Boundaries are always good in every place. I have work meetings where we're
just like, phones away, let's have our eyes on each other, let's stay really focused, right?
So like creating norms around the use of technology like at any moment is great.
At the same time, I also have work meetings where I have an AI tool who's taking
notes so one person doesn't have to do that.
I use technology to assist me every day in my life.
And as a 40-year-old man, I am learning how to do that und catch up with the times.
Wenn wir die phones weg von Kindern, wir lassen ihre Möglichkeit zu haben,
die assistive tools zu ermöglichen, dass sie mehr produktiv.
Wie ist deine Idee mit einem Smartphone-Bann?
Also du würdest ja wahrscheinlich nicht die Digitalisierung aus der Schule rausnehmen
und sagen, wir machen nur noch die Tafel und Frontalunterricht.
Unterricht. Das wäre ja so meine Idee.
Ja, also Tafel gibt es nicht mehr. Das ist jetzt vorbei.
Ich glaube nicht, dass jemand aus unserer Hörerschaft noch eine Grundschule
kennt, wo eine Tafel wie wir sie kannten.
Mit Kreide? Nein. Aber das war doch immer praktisch.
Ja, aber das ist mittlerweile alles elektrifiziert. Sagen wir mal so. Also ein Beamer.
Was bedeutet, du hast dann auch ein mobiles Gerät, damit jedes Kind mal an der
Tafel, aber vielleicht bleibst du am Tisch sitzen oder wie auch immer.
Ich bin da sehr, ich bin nicht zwiegespalten.
Ich habe eine Meinung, aber ich handele zwiegespalten.
Denn zum einen sage ich, in der Schule keine Smartphones, im Unterricht aber
schon, wenn es gezielt eingesetzt wird. Also in diesem Sinne.
Um das zu präzisieren, dein Problem sind die Smartphones auf dem Schulhof quasi und in den Gängen.
Und nicht dann, wenn der Lehrer sagt, so jetzt holt man das Smartphone raus
und jetzt machen wir mal alle Chat-Chipy-T an und geben dem auch mal eine Aufgabe
zu lösen und dann gleichen wir das mal ab mit unseren Aufgaben, dann würdest du sagen,
ja, das ist ein sinnvoller Einsatz oder wenn man das als Taschenrechner benutzt
etc., aber du bist eigentlich dagegen, dass die jungen Leute,
wie jung, müssen wir da nochmal reden,
die ganze Zeit dann auch jenseits dieser Unterrichtseinheiten mit dem Smartphone unterwegs sind.
Ja, eigentlich ist alles super easy. Grundschule, da bin ich gegen jede Elektrifizierung.
Schon da einen Film zu zeigen, finde ich bescheuert.
Da hat gefälligst die Lehrerin vorzulesen, falls in der Pause Unterhaltungsbedarf ist.
Also bei uns in der Grundschule, bei meinem Sohn jetzt, wird einfach gelesen.
Da sitzt die Lehrerin vorne, die knuspern alle in ihrem Zwieback rum und so
und dann wird halt einfach vorgelesen. Das ist ja eh gut.
Also in der Grundschule keine elektronische, da bin ich eigentlich auch für
eine Tafel. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum die das jetzt alle ersetzt haben.
In der weiterführenden Schule gibt es natürlich sehr viele Anlässe,
in denen die Lehrer einfach sagen, und da will ich nochmal kurz den Hinweis
geben, vor allem an dich, es ist ja kein Frontalunterricht.
Die Kinder kommen ja in ein Klassenzimmer, holen sich die Aufgaben aus dem Schrank,
sagen dem Lehrer, wie sie ihre Gruppe jetzt zusammengestellt haben,
selbstständig, um die jetzt zu lösen und dann sagt der Lehrer,
ach ihr macht jetzt Deutsch, okay gut, dann macht mal Deutsch.
In diesen Momenten.
Naja, aber es muss ja schon der Deutschlehrer da sein, für Deutsch zu machen.
Also bei denen, ich kenne ja auch noch ein paar Lehrer und ich kenne jetzt auch
nicht nur Lehrer, die 90 sind, sondern ich kenne auch Lehrer,
die zwischen 30 und 40 zum Beispiel sind und da habe ich schon den Eindruck,
ich war noch nicht dort zu Gast,
dass die einen Unterricht machen und sagen, hallo, ich bin der Geschichtslehrer,
1789 Französische Revolution, wer war Robespierre?
Alles schöne Pointen. Ich will sie dir trotzdem etwas zerstören.
Der Modus ist natürlich so, dass die Kinder, wenn sie jetzt Deutsch machen,
weil da noch Aufgaben zu machen sind, in die Klassenzimmer des Deutschlehrers
gehen und nicht plötzlich beim Mathelehrer sitzen und dort als Gruppenarbeit aber Deutsch machen.
Also die Zuordnung ist sozusagen nicht, der Klassenverband geht in die Klasse
und dann ist er Deutsch, weil der Deutschlehrer ist da, sondern ah,
ich habe noch Deutschaufgaben offen, ich gehe jetzt also.
Und das ist nicht so eine Reformschule, die du mir da gerade beschreibst.
Nein, und ich meine ja auch nicht, dass das jede Unterrichtsstunde ist,
aber pro Tag gibt es so ein, zwei Stunden, wo man einfach noch die offenen Aufgaben
und dann hat man halt, wenn man mehr Bedarf hat, mehr Mathe als andere und so weiter und so fort.
Aber man muss ja mitunter, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel eine Sprache lernt oder ein Latinum braucht.
Dann hat man natürlich Spanischunterricht und sitzt im Spanischunterricht bei der Spanischtherrie.
Richtig, da werden auch Vokabeln noch überprüft, ganz wie wir es vorher auch hatten.
Genau, worauf ich nur hinaus will ist, wenn Schüler zu einem Lehrer gehen in
einem für dich untypischen Setting, aber in das du dich kurz reinversetzt und
dort eine Frage stellen, die man auch einfach googeln könnte,
dann bin ich total dafür, dass man den Kindern sagt, sorry, aber hier stehen
noch drei andere, die haben echte Fragen, das kannst du auch googeln.
Oder im TBT-Zeitalter, das kann der TBT viel besser spontan beantworten als ich.
Ja.
Also da bin ich total dafür. Aber wir wissen ja alle, gerade Soziologen sagen,
Unterricht schön und gut, aber eigentlich besteht die Schule daraus,
was man lernt in der Pause, Weg zur Schule und so weiter und so fort.
Und da bin ich für einen sehr restriktiven Einsatz, was bedeutet,
dadurch, dass es so zeitlich beschränkt ist, umso weniger Smartphone-Zeit,
umso mehr andere Zeit und mir geht es um diese andere Zeit.
Wir alle kennen das aus Verlegenheit mal das Smartphone rausholen.
Naja, ab der weiterführenden Schule. Achso, bis zu welchem Alter.
Also darf man mit 17, wenn man in der Oberstufe ist zum Beispiel,
ein Smartphone noch auf dem Schulweg haben und auch auf dem Schulhof. Also bis dahin.
Ich verbiete niemandem ein Smartphone dabei zu haben, aber es sollte geregelt
sein, dass die Kinder es nicht kognitiv als ständig verfügbar und so weiter.
Aber diese Bands gehen ja weiter.
Ich weiß es genau.
Taylor Lawrence stellt das jetzt mal einen größeren Zusammenhang.
So much of this reminds me, and we've covered a lot on this show,
and I've written so much about this, of this broader moral panic around technology
use that's happening right now and technology use among children.
And I think these school bans, cell phone bans, are very much tied to that.
You hear a lot of conversations around mental health.
We've debunked the idea that social media use or cell phone use is remotely
the cause of any sort of mental health crisis among children.
It is just simply not true.
Yeah. absolutely no data back set up, despite what people like Jonathan Haidt,
who are essentially political actors.
Den hasst sie wirklich, Jonathan Haidt.
Das gibt, glaube ich.
Keinen Podcast, in dem sie nochmal erwähnt.
Wie stimmen sie das?
Ich habe das Buch ja auch gelesen und fand an sich das erstmal sehr schlüssig.
Sie sagt jetzt, das hat gar keine Evidenz, was er da beschreibt.
Das kann ich jetzt so nicht nachvollziehen. Was ich sagen würde,
ist, dass er natürlich dann,
sehr gut andockbar ist für sagen wir eine Unterrichtsform und auch eine Gesellschaftsform,
die ich jetzt als konservativ der Einfachheit halber beschreiben möchte.
Und da wäre ich dann wahrscheinlich eher wieder weg von Hyde.
Very much misleading people want people to believe.
Then you see things that are happening in Australia, where they're trying to
up the age of internet or social media use to 16.
I know there's an effort that Jonathan Hyde has pushed himself to raise it Ja.
Hier muss man ganz klar unterscheiden zwischen Smartphone und Social Media.
Zwei ganz unterschiedliche Themen.
Mhm.
Sie sagt jetzt auch Folgendes.
Ich sehe viele gleiche Aktivist-Gruppen und gleiche politische Gruppen,
die die Telefon-Bans in der Schule verletzten, als eine Art Test-Case,
um diese größere Restriktionen auf Technologien in den jungen Leuten aus der Schule zu verletzten.
Es gibt also so eine Strömung, die geht sehr häufig über diese Frage,
was tun wir unseren Kindern mit den sozialen Medien und dem Smartphone an.
Es wird gar nicht voneinander getrennt. Und dann auch nochmal,
wie verderbt ist die Gesellschaft sowieso durch soziale Medien und welche Inhalte
werden da eigentlich verbreitet?
Sie erwähnten zum Beispiel die Heritage Foundation, eine sehr konservative,
reaktionäre Foundation in den USA.
Wir haben auch orchestriert mit dazu beigetragen, dass der Irakkrieg so dann
kam, wie er gekommen ist.
Seeking to cut off young people's access to smartphones and technology and the
broader world, especially among marginalized kids and LGBTQ youth.
There is a moral panic around kids using technology. You had Marsha Blackburn
saying that she wanted to pass the Kids Online Safety Act and ban kids from
social media to eradicate the transgender in society.
I talked to the wife of a friend recently who believes truly that Instagram
has turned children in her son's class gay.
Also diese Idee ist jetzt da. Man hat diesen ganz harten Anti-LGBT-Punkt bei
den ganzen Konservativen dort.
Und die sagen jetzt, ja, die werden alle Transgender oder werden schwul durch
die sozialen Medien. Deswegen verbieten wir jetzt mal die sozialen Medien.
Frühsexualisierung der Kinder, das ist ja auch was, was Elon Musk dann als Vogue
Mind Virus beschrieben hat.
Und da habe ich nämlich dann schon plötzlich Bedenken, wenn man sich also für
so einen Smartphone-Bann ausspricht, dass man plötzlich da in einer Reihe steht mit diesen Leuten.
Wenn gleich mir der Relativismus von diesem KD Hernandes, ich habe das jetzt
nicht rausgeschnitten, aber das kann man dann, wenn man will, nochmal nachhören,
auch fremd ist, der dann einfach sagt, ja das hilft allen weiter und das hat
ja auch bei Corona doch bei uns Erwachsenen so gut geklappt mit Zoom,
warum soll das nicht für Kinder gut gehen?
Da haben wir ja gerade gesehen, dass das alles nicht gut funktioniert hat und
wir sehen ja, wie groß die Bildungsdefizite durch diese Lockdown-Unterrichtseinheiten geworden sind.
Und ich würde auch immer sagen, dass das direkte Wort von Schüler zu Lehrer
wichtiger ist, als jetzt nur irgendwas in Gamification-Modus rumgedaddelt und
dann auch noch als Unterrichtseinheit verkauft bekommen.
Aber ich sehe durchaus so eine gewisse Tendenz.
Wir haben jetzt eben schon bei Elon Musk gesagt,
Der ist ja nicht für Meinungsfreiheit. Das wäre ja noch eine wirkliche Position,
die ich erteilen würde, wenn er sagen würde, wir machen hier mal absolut Free Speech.
Aber der ist ja nicht für Free Speech, sondern nur für eine bestimmte Form von Free Speech.
Für seine.
Und da hält er dann auch jedes Auge zu, wo es über das Strafgesetzbuch weit
hinausgeht. Da ist dann alles okay.
Bei anderen hingegen, die dann vom sogenannten Vogue Mind Virus befallen sind,
da zensiert er ja alles weg und wäre ja auch Springer bereit,
alles weg zu zensieren, wie wir wissen.
Und deswegen habe ich da so das Gefühl, dass es hier um mehr geht.
Und Lawrence spricht jetzt über die 50er Jahre.
It is the America that we live in. And I mean, we saw this with like comic book
bans, right? Or banning novels or trying to ban children from reading newspapers.
I feel like we do see these moral panics and we know how it plays out.
And we know how devastating the consequences can be.
And yet you have these parents groups building, like you said,
coalition with these extreme right-wing special interest groups to push laws
that would restrict kids.
Ja, man geht über die Kinder, um so eine Mehrheit herzustellen.
Eigentlich sind sie vielleicht für vielmehr Meinungsfreiheit,
aber indem man sagt, die Kinder sind generell gefährdet.
Auch wenn du was, also das müssen dann nicht Leute sein, die alle Transgender,
Anti-Gender-Politik oder so sind, dass man aber so über die Kinder doch da rankommt
und sagt, ja wenn du deine Kinder schützen willst,
dann stehst du mit uns auf der richtigen Seite.
Und sie bringt diese Comic-Bands, die es dann in den 50er Jahren gab und das
ist ja interessant, das kann man ja in den Comic-Verfilmungen heute nicht mehr
nachvollziehen, dass diese Comics damals wirklich so eine subversive Kraft hatten,
also dort Themen verhandelten,
Dinge aussprachen, die sonst im Mainstream nicht stattgefunden haben.
Und wir können das auch sehen im Horrorfilm der 80er Jahre, hat man auch immer
unter dem Vorwand, die Kinder zu schützen, wahnsinnig viel zensiert.
Das waren aber eben nicht Filme, die gewaltverherrlichend sind,
in dem Sinne, diese Kinder sehen die Filme und ziehen dann los mit dem Messer
und werden zu Mördern, sondern in diesen Filmen wurde sehr häufig Subversives
gezeigt in Bezug auf Geschlechtlichkeit, in Bezug auf die bürgerliche Gesellschaft.
Und davor wollte man sich schützen und nicht die Kinder.
Und deswegen bin ich eigentlich an so einem Punkt, wo ich sage,
ich finde diese Art der Bands problematisch.
Nun ist das ja so, dass man das ja, wie du das sagst, viel differenzierter sehen
kann und sagt, es muss auch am Tage möglichst möglich sein, dass man Stunden
ohne dieses Ding verbringt.
Und ich halte das auch für sehr wichtig für die Entwicklung nicht nur von Kindern,
sondern für die Entwicklung aller Menschen.
Jetzt haben wir zugleich neben diesen Bands noch Ja.
Aber da lass uns noch kurz bei dem Band bleiben. Gerade in dem historischen Vergleich,
Also Taylor Lawrence wird ja von uns, wir haben ja ihr Buch auch besonders gelobt,
immer dafür, dass sie nah am Zahn der Zeit sozusagen ein bisschen weiter vorne als und so.
In dem Falle hier denke ich aber, dieser historische Vergleich geht,
also der ist auch sehr instruktiv, denn diese Kinder haben,
sagen wir mal, abseits von Schule und schlafen ja nicht allzu viel Tageszeit
und die Frage, mit was befassen sie sich dann vier, fünf Stunden,
ist einfach super relevant.
Ja.
Nur damals ging es ja um Medienträger, Tonträger, wie auch immer.
Also man wusste so, okay, jetzt nehme ich die Comics raus und damit sind die
bunten Bildchen weg. Das Smartphone geht ja sehr viel weiter.
Also man sollte ja auch, wenn ich jetzt einfach sage, keine Smartphones in der
Schule, dann bedeutet das ja,
dass nicht nur irgendwelche bunten Bildchen fehlen, sondern die ganze Idee,
wie man heute sein Leben führt, wie man sich mit Menschen connectet,
wie man mit den Eltern in Kontakt steht.
Das ist ja alles damit weg.
Kein Smartphone heißt kein Leben, keine Welt, kein irgendwas.
Es gibt ja auch immer weniger andere öffentliche Räume, keine Jugendclubs,
wo man sich trifft oder wie auch immer.
Man pendelt ja nur zwischen Klassenzimmer und Kinderzimmer hin und her und da
ist es das Mobbing und dann findet das Cybermobbing auch noch zu Hause statt und so der ganze Kram.
Also die Tragweite.
Aber ist gar nicht gerade das Internet für zum Beispiel gemobbte Personen eine
gute Möglichkeit, andere Menschen als die, die aus der Klasse kennenzulernen.
Also ich bin jetzt nie gemobbt worden, aber ich bin natürlich mit meinen speziellen
Interessen, die ich habe, eher in einer Klasse, in die ich so reingeworfen bin,
jemand, der dann nicht so viel Leute findet.
Also würde ich jetzt gerne Fußball spielen, dann wäre das halt leichter gewesen.
Und ich kann aber im Internet natürlich Leute kennenlernen, die sich auch für Wagner interessieren.
Und sie bezieht das ja jetzt zum Beispiel darauf, dass man eigentlich Minderheiten,
also gerade die LGBT-Community spricht sie da an,
wieder einfercht, indem man ihnen das Smartphone abnimmt, weil für die ist das
natürlich eine entscheidende Entwicklung, dass sie dort auf Gleichgesinnte treffen.
Habe ich vor 15 Jahren schon von Mark Zuckerberg gehört, das Argument,
man trifft seine Community, ich bin in einem Dorf aufgewachsen,
wo es keine anderen gab und so, stimmt.
Aber diese Form von Eskapismus, die bedeutet, lieber 2% der Intensität einer
sozialen Beziehung Medien vermittelt,
sehr viel mehr steckt nicht drin. Also dir nützt es als 15-Jähriger,
der sich gar nicht mal verlieben möchte, aber,
gleichgeschlechtlich auf der Suche nach einem Mann ist und gar nicht genau weiß,
wie jetzt diese Ansprache funktioniert, nützt es dir gar nichts,
irgendwo ein Forum zu finden, wo die sich austauschen.
Also du wirst dich da nicht verlieben und falls eine Reise möglich ist,
ja, dann ist das so ein Wochenende.
Alle Beziehungen heute gehen über online.
Ja, aber die Beziehungen finden trotzdem im sozialen Nahfeld statt.
Klar, aber ich glaube, dass das jetzt für das Internet doch einfach gilt,
dass das die Möglichkeiten, Beziehungen zu schließen, erweitert.
Zum Teil dann so sehr erweitert, dass man gar nicht mehr weiß,
man ist dann in einer Multioptionsgesellschaft und bleibt irgendwann derjenige,
der sich gar nicht mehr entscheiden kann, weil zu viele Wahlmöglichkeiten da sind.
Aber grundsätzlich ist es ja so, dass wir hier eine Situation haben von Leuten,
die eher in engen Verhältnissen sind und die dann durch das Smartphone,
durch irgendein Forum oder so an Gleichgesinnte geraten.
Verstehe ich alles. Auch politisch.
Also stell dir vor, du bist da in so einem erzkonservativen amerikanischen Kaff,
wo alle Republikaner sind.
Du selbst aber bist 15 und denkst, nee, ist vielleicht doch nicht so richtig
und Klimawandel scheint doch eher schaltende Gefahr zu sein.
Dann findet diese Person ja im Internet möglicherweise gleichgesinnte,
aber findet die niemals im Dorf.
Und wenn sie im Dorf auch sind, dann werden die sich über das Internet connecten
können, weil die sich so ja nicht auf der Straße erkennen.
Genau. Und das ist eben der Unterschied zwischen offline und online und online.
Kein Social Media heißt, du kannst dein soziales Nahfeld in Chatgruppen dubeln.
Also sozusagen die Klassenraumgesprächsituation auch nach Hause weiterziehen,
Verabredung treffen, sodass es am nächsten Morgen gleich intensiver weitergeht, wie auch immer.
Nur diese Idee von, wir brauchen diesen Online-Teil für Jugendliche,
auch jenseits des sozialen Nahfelds, weil ja eine, wie auch immer,
wo sie herkommt, Vorliebe für Wagner,
dort durch eine Person, aber halt 70 Kilometer weit weg, gespiegelt wird,
das ist so eine verträumte Darstellung, die gilt nicht mal in Forschungsgemeinschaften,
wo Menschen sich von Universität zu Universität verknüpfen und ein Thema dort
die ganze Sozialität prägt.
Wo man dann sagt, jetzt machen wir aber auch noch eine Konferenz und treffen uns sogar zum Thema.
Aber ich weiß zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt Veranstaltungen mache oder so,
treffe ich ja viele junge Leute.
Das sind sehr viele, deren Bekanntenkreis speist sich zum großen Teil aus Twitter-Bekanntschaften.
Das hat sich jetzt auch verändert. Das ist aber Elon Musk geschuldet.
Aber das ist schon interessant, dass also 17-, 18-Jährige, wenn sie nicht gerade
schon an einem Ort wie Berlin oder Leipzig sind, wo man ganz viele Gleichgesinnte trifft,
dass diese linke Sozialisierung über das Internet geschieht und auch über das
Internet dann gewisse Freundschaften entstehen.
Das passiert dann über WhatsApp, über Discord oder sonst was.
Stimmt. Aber warum muss diese verwandelungsthemengetriebene soziale Geschichte,
die da abläuft, auf der Hochpause ablaufen?
Das Schulsystem in Deutschland ist so organisiert, dass du mit fremden Kindern
in einen Klassenzusammenhang geworfen wirst.
Du hast also einen Klassenzusammenhang und darüber nochmal einen Jahrgangszusammenhang.
Der ergibt sich einfach und dem wirst du nicht entfliehen können.
Nein.
Wenn du eine Vorliebe hast für irgendwelche Musiken oder irgendwas anderes,
lebe es gerne aus, aber nicht in der Schulhofzeit, wo du dich mit deinem sozialen Nahfeld.
Und zwar ist es ganz wichtig, dass du dort nicht alle mögst und dass die dort
auch andere Meinungen haben und deine Vorlieben nicht teilen.
Weil das Ziel der Bildung ist ja, dich mit denen zu verständigen, trotz allem.
Ja, richtig.
Vorlieben, gerne zu Hause dann. Der Tag ist noch lang genug.
Such dir einen Verein aus.
Von mir aus auf dem Weg zum Verein. Sitze im Bus 20 Minuten,
gehst du durch deine Chatgruppe durch, mit denen du was auch immer für Vorlieben,
aber den sozialen Zusammenhang, den du schon hast und in dem nicht alles nach
deinen Vorzeichen läuft.
Das ist Integration und Sozialisation. Dieses Problem muss gelöst werden und
da stört das Smartphone.
Das glaube ich schon, ja.
Und die Schule ist eben dieser Ort und diese Zeit.
Also ich glaube, dass das der Punkt ist, den Taylor Lawrence dann nicht erkennen
will, weil sie wahrscheinlich dann doch so sehr in diesem Digitalen als das
eigentliche Leben lebt.
Und Taylor Lawrence Problem ist, und wir spekulieren hier nur, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Mein Eindruck ist, und jeder der Kinder hat, weiß, was ich jetzt meine,
wenn du selber Kinder hast und du überantwortest sie und seist nur ganz peripher,
weil sie auch anwesend sind, einem anderen Erwachsenen, der keine Erfahrung mit Kindern hat.
Siehst du das sofort. Diese Leute haben keine Ahnung von den Bedürfnissen der
Kinder, von den Vorlieben, wie auch immer.
Selbst Großeltern, die eigentlich wissen, wie es ist mit Kindern.
Kommen mit ihren Enkeln nicht klar, sondern fallen in dieses,
ach, zum Glück kann ich sie wieder abgeben.
Wenn mein Enkelkind da ist, das ist mir doch egal, ob das jetzt fünf Stunden
im Auto gefahren hat. Ich möchte, dass es jetzt reagiert, wenn ich es am Fuß ziehe und so weiter.
Und dann fängt das Kind an zu weinen und die Tochter des Großvaters so,
kannst du es mal in Ruhe lassen, kannst du es mal akklimatisieren,
es ist gerade in der neuen Umgebung und so, selbst Großeltern, ja, blenden sowas aus.
So, also dieses Gespräch, was findet in der Schule statt, jetzt über das Smartphone
noch hinaus, ja, was findet in der Schule statt, macht einfach einen Unterschied,
ob das betroffene Eltern,
grundsätzlich Eltern oder halt Menschen ohne Kinder, ob die darüber reden,
weshalb ich auch finde, es macht einen riesen Unterschied,
wer Corona-Politik macht, ob das einfach ein Finanzminister,
eine Kanzlerin, Gesundheitsminister, Und ein Wirtschaftsminister ohne Kinder sind.
Oder halt, ob da mal irgendwo auch mal ein Kind eine Tagesordnung bestimmt.
Und das Zweite ist, Taylor Lawrence redet jetzt hier über Schule,
über Kinder, über Smartphones.
Okay, aber dieses Gespräch, wie bei so vielen Gesprächen mit Kindern, die Eltern.
Man sollte erstmal über die Eltern reden. Ich bin immer wieder überrascht und
ich finde es auch grotesk, aber ich finde, es ist nicht zu viel verlangt,
dass grundsätzlich erwachsene Menschen, die ihr ganzes Leben mit einem Smartphone verbringt,
jede einzelne Einstellung ihres Smartphones kennen.
Ich finde, jeder hat die Pflicht, es kommt ein neues iOS-Update oder von Android.
Bitte schaut euch bei YouTube diese 10 Minuten an, wo euch die neuen Funktionen vorgestellt werden.
Wie Leute ihre E-Mails benutzen, wie sie sich Erinnerungen per E-Mail selber
schreiben, wie sie nicht verstehen, wie ihr Kalender funktioniert.
Der ganze Scheiß, das ertrage ich mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Also gerne Gespräch über Kinder und Smartphones, aber Erwachsene und Smartphones,
Das ist, wir haben in Deutschland, diese Kurzmeldung spiele ich jetzt nicht,
PISA gibt es auch für Erwachsene. Lesen und Rechnen.
20% der erwachsenen Menschen lesen unter dem Niveau von 10-jährigen Kindern.
Zehnjährige Kinder haben keine Lust auf Lesen, werden nur gequält damit,
haben vielleicht mal so ein Buch geschafft in ihrem Leben bisher und so weiter.
Das ist das Niveau, auf dem die Leute ihre Smartphones bedienen.
Und das geht einfach nicht.
Weshalb ich nichts dagegen hätte, wenn es überall Smartphones gäbe,
schon ab Geburt, wenn die Eltern in der Lage wären, mal ihre scheiß Smartphones
selber ordentlich zu benutzen.
Aber dieses Ausgeliefertsein an irgendwelchen Silicon Valley Ideologien,
wo es einfach heißt, wir müssen das nur als Default einstellen,
die Leute gehen da eh nie rein und am Ende regieren wir einfach kognitiv durch
und verankern sozusagen das geistige Eigentum in den Köpfen der Leute,
weil wir ihnen einfach über Muscle Memory zeigen, wie die Welt funktioniert,
das finde ich skandalös und das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Das heißt, wir brauchen eigentlich einen Smartphone-Führerschein,
denn beim Auto haben wir es ja so.
Da kann ich nicht einfach sagen, ich fahre jetzt mal los in so ein Ding,
sondern ich brauche einen Führerschein und wenn ich ein neues Auto kaufe,
werde ich auch eingewiesen, wie ich das verwende, sonst habe ich ein großes Problem.
Wir brauchen einen Idiotentest. Leute müssen angehalten werden dürfen auf der Straße.
Und wenn sie es nicht schaffen, innerhalb einer Minute einzustellen,
dass ihr Handy nur von ihren engen Familienmitgliedern von 20 bis 24 Uhr anrufbar ist.
Sondern wenn sie so rätselnd davorstehen, gibt es so eine Einstellung?
Weiß ich nicht. Habe ich noch nie darüber nachgedacht. Wäre eigentlich ganz
cool, wenn es das gibt. Sofort das Handy wegnehmen.
Wirklich.
Die Leute können ihr Smartphone nicht bedienen.
Das ist ein ganz großes Drama.
Es ist ein Wunder. dass wir an der Oper so selten unterbrochen werden von Klingeltönen.
Ja.
Weil dieser eine Schalter es einfach komplett ausmachen. Ja,
das haben die Leute irgendwie jetzt begriffen. Nach 20 Jahren iPhone so.
Aber der Rest ist wirklich, also es ist schlimm.
Wir gehen zu TikTok über. TikTok ist gerade nahe dem Abgrund in den USA.
Es gibt eine Entscheidung. 19. Januar. Die müsste eigentlich am 19.
Januar dann fallen, dass also dann der TikTok-Bann da ist.
TikTok müsste sonst, also Bitons müsste TikTok verkaufen an Amerikaner.
Donald Trump, wir werden ihn gleich hören, sieht es vielleicht doch wieder etwas
anders. Ich bin inzwischen TikTok-Fan.
Also ich will, dass TikTok bleibt. Also ich bin ganz gegen diesen Bann.
Also das kann ich jetzt schon mal ganz klar sagen.
Am 19. Januar greift dieses Gesetz. Am 20. Januar kommt der amerikanische Präsident auf.
Macht eine Rede entsprechend, dass TikTok doch nicht verboten wird und die Jugend
Amerikas wird ihm zu Füßen liegen.
Sehr gut, ich werde dir gleich einen Clip spielen, der genau diese These unterstützt.
Aber wir nähern uns dem langsam nochmal mit Taylor Lawrence.
Wieder neue Podcast-Folge. Sie sagt folgendes.
Last week, TikTok lost its challenge to stop a ban of the app in the United States.
I've been in deep denial about this and a lot of creators have been too.
But the ban is looking more and more likely.
My guest today is honestly the best person to talk about this.
Louise Metzikas reports on China and tech for Wired.
Also wir haben diese Wired-Journalistin, Louise Matsakis, und sie erklärt die Situation.
In the middle of 2020, okay, so maybe four years since we started talking about this.
And I kind of feel like the girl who cried wolf, like I've talked so many times
about TikTok maybe, you know, not being available in the US or the app getting
banned here or what have you.
But maybe not all listeners will believe it this time, but it's for real.
Das ist wirklich die Zeit, die es wirklich wirklich, wirklich,
wirklich bad. This is not just like something that Trump is tweeting or whatever.
Like this is really like the courts have made a really important decision.
So the specifics are that last week there was a decision in this case where TikTok sued,
the US government for passing a law that would basically force either TikTok's
parent company ByteDance to sell its US operations to an American company by
January 19th or the app would be banned.
Die Frage ist jetzt, wie der Supreme Court darauf reagiert, wird er das annehmen?
Man ist aber auch da, wenn es
annimmt, sich nicht klar, wie er entscheiden wird. Könnte sein, dass dann,
Ähnlich wie da rauskommt. Wir haben jetzt Teladons, die, man fragt ja,
warum soll denn das überhaupt verbannt werden?
So speaking of the national security stuff, I feel like one thing that's really
concerning to me is that there doesn't seem to be any proof.
We still don't have this like smoking gun of all of the allegations,
I guess, that are made against TikTok.
And of course, American companies also have been involved, like Facebook,
in foreign interference and election sort of schemes and stuff. So has the U.S.
Government come with anything new? Is there a smoking gun at this point?
Matt Sackis?
No, and actually if you read the court's opinion.
Man hat,
Man hat das keine Beweise, geht aber irgendwie davon aus, weil China unser Rivale ist.
Wir werden gleich einen Demokraten noch hören, der das auch nochmal so sagt,
aber der auch keine Beweise liefert.
Was wir aber jetzt sehen in der Presse, wann immer irgendwo jetzt Wahlen sind
oder sonst was, dann warnt man vor TikTok.
Also wir haben ja auch hier schon gesagt, die AfD hat TikTok verstanden und
haben ja auch schon darüber sehr ausführlich gesprochen.
Allerdings haben wir nicht gesagt, TikTok lenkt den Erfolg der AfD.
Also TikTok ist nicht dafür verantwortlich in dem Sinne, dass jetzt Peking sagt,
mach die AfD groß, sondern die Frage, die wir uns ja hier stellen müssen ist,
kann es vielleicht sein, und das wäre jetzt wieder die Sache Paradigmenwechsel,
die alten Muster greifen nicht
mehr, kann es sein, dass diese App eine Popularität nach vorne bringt?
Aus ihrer Art, wie sie ist, die nicht gesteuert ist von irgendjemandem,
sondern die sich daraus erst ergibt.
Also eine gewisse Art zu singen, funktioniert halt erst, wenn man ein elektrisches
Mikrofon hat, sonst geht es nicht.
Ja, in der Oper muss man anders singen wie auf einer Rockbühne.
Das ist so. Wenn ich jetzt eine App habe wie TikTok, dann funktioniert Ansprache
fundamental anders als in der Tagesschau.
Und die Frage ist, wer bedient die wie und welche neuen Politiken bringt diese Technik hervor?
Also der Volksempfänger, das Radio, ist ja natürlich auch etwas,
was der Faschismus, vor allem eben der Nazifaschismus, sehr gut einsetzen konnte, um zu agitieren.
Das heißt aber, es ist ja nicht so, dass die Radioanstalten es gesteuert haben,
sondern das Radio bringt eine Art der Ansprache und auch eine Art der Politik dann erst hervor.
Und hier frage ich mich jetzt, wenn wir über diesen TikTok-Bann reden.
Dann werden doch hier Dinge miteinander verwechselt.
Nämlich es wird eigentlich so getan, als ging es darum, dass man die Chinesen
hat, die nicht nur Daten abgreifen, sondern auch Fake News verbreiten können,
die dies und das tun können.
Ich halte das alles für möglich, dass die das auch tun würden oder auch schon
getan haben, das weiß ich nicht, ich habe ja auch keine Beweise.
Ich traue Staaten untereinander generell sehr viel zu und wir hatten ja hier
auch schon die ganzen Affären gehabt, Snowden etc.
Insofern, warum nicht? Ich glaube nur, die Wirklichkeit ist eine andere.
Ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich etwas in der Gesellschaft auch vorzufinden,
was dann gut connectet mit TikTok und da braucht nicht nochmal ein Einfluss
von außen her zu kommen, der sagt, so jetzt steuere ich das mal.
Ja, zumal wir ja gerade große Steuerungen erleben.
Offenbar hat Elon Musk, so jetzt die jüngsten Zahlen, 250 Millionen Dollar für
Donald Trump ausgegeben, dafür, dass der Präsident wird.
Wir können uns jetzt auch nur annähernd vorstellen, wie einflussreich er in
Elon Musk werden könnte, wenn ihm jetzt wirklich daran gelegen wäre,
dass in Deutschland eine andere Regierung kommt.
Er hat ja getwittert, only AfD can save Germany.
Und wenn wir wissen, dass die gesamten Parteispenden in Deutschland für den
Wahlkampf beim letzten Wahlkampf gerade mal bei 100 Millionen Euro lagen,
für alle Parteien, dann weiß man also, wie...
Elon Musk quasi mit einem Taschengeld beeinflussen könnte. Und jetzt sagen manche
natürlich, ja, so einfach ist das ja nicht, vom Ausland eine deutsche Wahl zu beeinflussen.
Naja, man kann es ja über Umwege eben tun. Man muss ja nicht der Partei direkt was spenden.
Man kann vielleicht irgendein Startup aufziehen, das einfach toll plakatiert
und sagt, fühlen sie sich eigentlich in diesem Land noch sicher.
Da brauchst du nicht AfD draufschreiben, da weiß jeder Bescheid, was gemeint ist.
Genau.
Vor allem wohl Russland nennt man, denn dieser Erfolg, der resultiert her von
TikTok und dass dieser Georgescu.
Dieser parteilose Kandidat, der früher mit einer anderen rechtsextremen Partei
zusammengearbeitet hat, dass der jetzt so parteilos einen solchen Überraschungserfolg
erzielen konnte, liegt an TikTok, liegt an seiner Performance dort.
Und deshalb muss es so sein, dass es eine Einflussnahme gab und deswegen kann
also die Wahl so nicht als ordentlich angesehen werden.
Sonneborn sagt jetzt folgendes.
Am vorvergangenen Sonntag, 8.12. wurde in Rumänien die zweite und entscheidende
Runde der Präsidentschaftswahlen stattgefunden haben, wenn das höchste Gericht
sie nicht, Hüstel, durch Annullierung der Ersten abgesagt hätte.
Warum ein und dasselbe Gericht die erste Wahlrunde vom 24.
November zuerst als rechtmäßig bestätigt, nur um seine eigene Bestätigung vier
Tage später wieder aufzuheben, zwei Tage vor dem Wahltag, ist mit Mitteln von
Demokratie und Logik schwer zu erklären.
Das meinte er.
In den vier Tagen dazwischen war eigentlich nichts Besonderes passiert.
Außer, dass ein gewisses State Department, USA,
am Mittwoch, sowie ein Außenminister namens Blinken, ebenfalls USA, Donnerstag,
begleitet vom gewöhnlichen NATO-Partnerschaftsgefasel und der einen oder anderen
schlecht versteckten Drohung, plötzlich vor einer Einmischung Russlands in diese Wahl warnten,
von der bis dahin nicht die Rede gewesen war.
Dieser Georgesko, man wird sich nicht wundern, steht natürlich Russland in gewisser Weise nahe.
Also er leugnet natürlich irgendwas mit Russland zu tun zu haben und er denkt
nur an das Interesse seines Volkes und sowas.
Ja, aber wenn man es jetzt mal ein bisschen herunterbrechen will,
weil wir uns wahrscheinlich, also wir beide zumindest uns in Rumänien nicht
wirklich auskennen, alles was ich jetzt gelesen habe, da können wir vielleicht
das ein bisschen übertragen. Wir haben ja in der AfD zwei Flügel.
Der eine Flügel ist der eher transatlantische mit Alice Weide.
Und dann haben wir den eher russlandnahen und ja sowieso vom transatlantischen
Verhältnis recht unberührten Flügel mit Maximilian Krah unter anderem.
Dieser Thüringer.
Und diese, die sind sicher nicht grün, wie wir wissen und das führt ja auch
dann dazu, dass also auf der europäischen Ebene die ganzen Rechtsradikalen nicht
so gut zusammenarbeiten können,
wenn nicht dieser transatlantische Flügel auch der stärkere ist.
Also das ist ja ganz interessant.
Meloni zum Beispiel ist ja auch stark transatlantisch ausgerichtet.
Und hier in Rumänien, das ja einen riesen Armutscode hat, da sehen wir jetzt
auch, es gibt also diesen nicht transatlantischen oder antitransatlantischen Flügel.
Und das gibt es natürlich auch dann in der Bevölkerung, spiegelt sich das auch wieder.
Das sind eigentlich, sind es nicht drei Flügel, kann man das mittlerweile so sagen?
Wir haben so diesen Höcke russischen Flügel, diesen Krah chinesischen Flügel
und dann diesen Südwestflügel, der im Grunde so ein libertäres Programm fährt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Man macht aber dann doch auch wieder teilweise wohl gemeinsame Sachen,
also es ist ein bisschen diffus.
Jedenfalls die ideologische Differenz ist zum einen die Russlandfrage,
also da ist die AUR eher antirussisch eingestellt.
Und was die Nazi-Vergangenheit, die Nazi-Kollaboration anbelangt,
da versucht die AUR auch sich zurückzuhalten,
während jetzt Georgesco jemand ist, der die als Helden glorifiziert.
Also ganz ähnlich, wie wir das ja auch erlebt haben bei der AfD,
dass Maximilian Krah dort nochmal
sagt, ja, auch die Nazi-Soldaten waren ehrenhafte Soldaten und sowas.
Also diese Konflikte sind wohl jetzt ganz stark da und es ist aber doch immer
sehr stark zurückzuführen auf diese transatlantische Linie, ja oder nein.
Sonnenborn führt jetzt weiter aus.
Wenn ausgerechnet Kollege TikTok an einer nun angeblich vermurksten Präsidentschaftswahl
schuld sein soll, dann stimmt mit dieser Moderne etwas nicht.
Denn entgegen dem Eindruck, der bei Ihnen da draußen erzeugt wird,
nämlich dass TikTok den bösartigen Nestern von Terrorismus und Autokratie,
Unterschlupf und Verbreitung biete, was wahlweise von Lucifer,
Russland, Beelzebub, China oder Mephistopheles,
zur Manipulierung unserer ansonsten völlig intakten Vorzeigedemokratie missbraucht werden könne,
steht die Plattform selbst längst unter hinreichender Kontrolle derer,
die nun schlagzeilen ergreifend behaupten, eine Gefahr in ihr zu sehen.
Und was er jetzt ausführt, wundert mich, weil diese Maßnahmen,
die Trump gegen TikTok ergriffen hat und die beiden dann weitergeführt hat,
sind ja ganz erheblich, weshalb mich diese Debatte jetzt gerade um TikTok erst
einmal verwundert, aber vielleicht dann wiederum nicht, wie wir später hören werden.
Seit die US-Regierung unter einem Präsidenten, der der einen Milliarde weltweiten
Nutzer durch seine unterhaltsameren Stolper, Stotter und Demenzunfälle bekannt sein dürfte,
ganz offen gegen die Plattform vorgeht, also seit 2020, darf man mit Fug und
Recht davon ausgehen, dass der Laden nicht mehr ist, was er mal war. Falls überhaupt je.
Seither hat TikTok nämlich nicht nur in großem Umfang Konten gelöscht,
Videos entfernt waren Hinweise an Medienhäuser der Staatsfeinde von Washington
geklebt, sondern vor allem das 1,5 Milliarden Dollar schwere Projekt Texas umgesetzt.
Entgegen der von diesem Begriff ausgelösten Assoziation bestand dieses Projekt
nicht in der halsbrecherischen Ausführung ortsüblicher Rodeo- oder Lasso-Manöver,
sondern erstens in der Datenumsiedlung nach Boston und der Zusammenarbeit mit Oracle,
einem Unternehmen mit außergewöhnlich guten Beziehungen.
Also man hat schon eine Verbindung zu Oracle, man hat da das Datenzentrum und dann?
Es bestand aber zweitens und vor allem in einem umfassenden Personalaustausch,
nämlich der Einstellung Dutzender US-Staatsbeamter, State Department und CIA,
sowie der Rekrutierung von Geheimdienstagenten der berüchtigten Einheit 8200.
Und diese Einheit kennen wir durch die Pager-Angriffe, also die israelische Einheit.
Wir sehen, also hier ist doch bei TikTok es längst so, dass das nicht in chinesischer
Hand komplett ist und die Chinesen da in so einer Blackbox irgendwas machen
und wir wissen nicht, was da los ist, sondern die sehen das also auch.
Und Sonnebarn sagt jetzt, also wenn die jetzt nicht, die dort alle schon sind,
gesehen haben, dass es da eine große Einmischung in Rumänien gibt,
wenn die nicht davor gewarnt haben und so weiter, dann wundert es doch,
dass das plötzlich jetzt so gesehen wird.
Wir kommen auf Rumänien gleich nochmal zurück.
Ich will, dass wir das jetzt im Hinterkopf behalten, denn es ist doch ganz erstaunlich,
wenn man jetzt sich fragt, warum wollen die eigentlich TikTok verbannen?
Geht es vielleicht auch nochmal um mehr als um diesen Systemstreit?
Denn zugleich wird in den USA wenig gegen Temu oder so unternommen.
Das ist ganz erstaunlich. Da kann man ja auch sagen, das ist ja auch ein Einfluss auf China.
Erstmal sagt Matsakis jetzt bei Taylor Lawrence, naja, die können sich ja Daten
von überall her beschaffen, die Chinesen. Die brauchen ja gar nicht TikTok dazu.
But that's not because the Chinese government is benevolent.
What we've seen time and time again is that they're able to get information
that they want from Americans, their personal data, their social security numbers,
you know, where they come and go through other means.
Right. Right now. Like third party Facebook vendors.
Ja, es It's not that I'm trying to say, oh, the Chinese government doesn't have
an interest in sort of espionage and hacking.
It's that I don't think they need to do it through TikTok.
No, they can do it through any other data brokers and all of the data that's
being harvested on every American social app.
Well, good. übrigens gute Dienste mittlerweile. Incognito zum Beispiel ist einer,
den ich jetzt nutze. Oder andere, DeleteMe.
Da kriegt man einfach seine Adresse und seine E-Mail-Adresse ein und dann wird
man aus diesen ganzen Verzeichnissen mal gelöscht.
Ja.
Wo man so unter der Hand hin und her gedealt wird in so riesigen Paketsammlungen.
Ach ja.
Und das kannst du vor allem so ein bisschen nachverfolgen. Also ich weiß jetzt
nicht genau wie und so. Aber man sieht dann, okay, die haben jetzt auf 79 Datenbanken,
gesagt, bitte hier Recht auf vergessen und so.
Und dann wird man da überall gelöscht. Klar, man muss dann seine Straße und
Hausnummer erstmal angeben, damit die dann das abgleichen und sagen,
wenn es ein Match gibt, wird es gelöscht.
Aber es ist doch schon eine ganz schön lange Liste von sehr obskuren Namen,
wo man so auftaucht in den Datenbanken.
Und das kostet Geld?
Das kostet so 5, 6, 7 Euro im Monat. Ich denke aber, das reicht einmal im Jahr
einfach so ein Monatspaket zu buchen, um das mal durchlaufen zu lassen.
Die Versprechen halt, dass sie sich immer beobachten, also dass sie die ganze
Zeit mit dich abgleichen, aber ich will ja auch nicht, dass jeden Monat in diesen
Zentren Bescheid gesagt wird, dass meine Sachen gelöscht werden sollen,
also einmal im Jahr reicht wahrscheinlich, wie auch immer.
Aber da kann man das alles mal, zumindest auf so einem halböffentlichen Teil,
wir wissen natürlich alle nicht, was auf den Servern im Hintergrund dann abläuft.
Gerade dieses Projekt Texas, also dass das alles bei Oracle läuft,
Oracle da auch noch 5, 6 Milliarden im Jahr verdient und gleichzeitig natürlich,
unterstelle ich jetzt mal so eine eins zu eins Kabellage zur NSA hat.
Aber wie kann das sein, dass man trotzdem über TikTok redet?
Ja. But generally,
TikTok Und eine progressive Userbase.
Ja, und eine sehr progressive Userbase.
Ja, progressive weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Na, wir haben das hier die ganze Zeit immer so geframed mit,
die AfD ist da stark. Und jetzt kenne ich aber auch mehr und mehr Leute,
die linkssozialisiert werden über TikTok.
Und ich höre von Taylor Lawrence dann das hier.
The impetus for bringing back this ban last year from Rep Gallagher,
who really spearheaded this effort, was around speech on the app.
And young people, especially, espousing progressive values and pro-Palestinian sentiment.
And that was sort of what put it back on his radar. And that seems really concerning,
that so much of the, even the hearings about TikTok were, it wasn't really about
China. It was about the speech happening on the app and the desire to censor speech.
Wir haben jetzt schon häufiger erlebt, dass es eigentlich so mit Bertelsmann
Stiftung, irgendwelchen Bürgerräten und dann Konstantin Notz von den Grünen darum geht zu sagen...
Wir sind für die Meinungsfreiheit, aber wir brauchen schon mal so klare Kontrollen
und wie man das dann noch alles nennen kann, wir brauchen mal Leitplanken,
aber eigentlich geht es dann doch darum,
dass man einschränken will, dass man doch eigentlich auch gewisse Hegemonien
wiederherstellen will, beziehungsweise nicht weiter zusehen will, dass sie bröckeln.
Du hast ja als ich nochmal vor ein paar Folgen betonte, wie groß der Einfluss
und die Macht von Springer ist, nochmal gesagt, naja, aber in gewisser Weise
stehen die doch auch schon am Rande.
Zwar haben die jetzt sehr viele finanzielle Kapazitäten, aber so der Meinungsumschwung,
der in der Gesellschaft stattgefunden hat, gerade auch mit Blick auf den Krieg hinaus.
Da kann man dann sehen, da hilft das nicht, wenn die noch so sehr ihre Linie
versuchen durchzuboxen.
Es kommt einfach da in der Bevölkerung nicht mehr an.
Und wir sehen ja jetzt auch gerade, wie so eine, sagen wir, Öffnung von Schleusen stattfindet.
Bei diesem Fall Luigi erschießt den CEO.
Wir sehen generell, dass in der Gesellschaft sehr anders gedacht wird.
Ich meine jetzt eben nicht mal nur, dass rechts anders gedacht wird,
sondern dass generell ein Unbehagen da ist, dass sich nicht mehr abgebildet
findet in den öffentlich-rechtlichen und schon gar nicht in den privaten Medien.
Und von den großen Medienhäusern kommt da auch wenig.
Und dass eigentlich da doch progressive Inhalte stattfinden.
Und dass man jetzt eigentlich versucht, gerade in den USA, das wieder einzuhegen,
dass das bitte nicht zu weit geht.
Also ja, dennoch, das ist ein
sehr politisches, nicht sehr funktionales Argument, ich mache es trotzdem.
Ich könnte es natürlich unendlich ausbauen.
TikTok als Vorreiter für...
Diese Art von Free Speech durch die kommunistische Partei.
Das passt nicht zusammen und ich sympathisiere da sehr mit der Argumentation
von Scott Galloway, der sagt, TikToks Funktion ist,
dass junge Amerikaner jeden Abend, nachdem sie 90 Minuten TikTok gesehen haben,
ein bisschen schlechter über Amerika denken.
Jetzt können wir natürlich eine unendliche Diskussion führen,
aber die soziale Ungleichheit, aber das Bildungssystem und so weiter.
Wir können also durchaus sagen, ja zu Recht, es wird halt nicht mehr verdeckt.
Trotzdem ist dieses jeden Tag ein bisschen schlechter über Amerika denken ein
dann entsprechend gefundener Weg der kommunistischen Partei in China,
sich unangreifbar zu machen, indem sie so leicht den Schleier jetzt enthüllen lassen.
Und die Amerikaner schlagen zurück und sagen, diese Server stehen bitte bei
uns, wo wir sie unter Kontrolle haben.
Genau, und dann werden aber solche Leute gemutet, die darauf hinweisen.
Und das sind aber, müssen wir sagen, denn das ist auch bei Scott Galloway,
geht das oft durcheinander.
Die Leute, die sagen, wie katastrophal es in den USA ist, das sind nicht Leute,
die Geld bekommen haben aus Peking, um das zu sagen.
Nee, genau.
Die sagen das. Und es gibt genügend Leute, die dem zustimmen und sagen,
ja, so ist es aber auch. Deswegen ist es nicht so, dass wir eine Manipulation haben.
Wir haben nicht quasi ein Staatsmedium, Peking ruft an, TikTok produziert Videos oder so etwas.
Das ist nicht der Fall. Und wenn man nämlich damit argumentiert,
ja, dass dann die amerikanische Moral und so unterkramt wird,
das ist exakt die Argumentation während der McCarthy-Ära, wo man eben für unamerikanische
Umtriebe sich verantworten musste.
Trotzdem ein Hinweis an der Stelle.
Auf diese Art und Weise, wie wir ja auch hier alte Sehgewohnheiten und Denkmuster durchbrechen wollen.
Es macht einen ganz großen Unterschied, aber man erkennt es kaum,
ob jemand Vertrauen in Personen oder Vertrauen in Systeme erschüttert.
Also gerade bei so Sachen wie Magdeburg oder so, sagen wir jetzt einfach,
Dunja Hayali hat sich falsch verhalten, der Ministerpräsident steht ja,
also das ist ja völlig absurd, wie der das macht und so weiter und so fort.
Oder sagen wir, seht ihr, wir haben doch immer gesagt, Deutschland funktioniert
nicht. Das muss alles neu gemacht werden.
Und dieser kleine Unterschied, den zu betonen, reicht ja für China schon.
Ja, nur ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass die Algorithmen jetzt daraufhin programmiert
sind, das zu machen, sondern ich würde sagen, dass diese Stimmung,
die kannst du jederzeit draußen abrufen auf dem Marktplatz, im Supermarkt, sonst wo.
Kannst du sagen, hier in Deutschland funktioniert ja gar nichts mehr.
Hat man jetzt doch gerade in Magdeburg gesehen. Und dann wirst du dafür Zustimmung
bekommen. Da muss China nichts machen und da muss auch nicht TikTok kommen. Das kann ich mit Leuten.
Naja, China muss nicht nichts machen. China muss einfach nur TikTok betreiben,
aber dann nicht weiter eingreifen.
Genau, aber es kann ja nicht jetzt die Lösung sein, dass wir jetzt sagen,
wir lassen jetzt Leute eingreifen.
Also ich möchte nicht, dass mir die Demokraten, Joe Biden, oder ich möchte auch
nicht, dass Konstantin von Notz mir meine Timeline organisiert.
Also ich finde das auch schlimm, dass Elon Musk das macht, nur ich will das
auch nicht von denen haben, dass die mir das jetzt irgendwie sagen und mir sagen,
aber da ist es jetzt fake und so weiter.
Das finde ich ja so interessant, dass wir durch Elon Musk jetzt sehen,
wie weit es Milliardäre treiben können.
Dass uns Amerikaner darüber aufklären, wie ein im Grunde illegaler Migrant in
Amerika einfach eine Plattform übernimmt und dort so ein eigenes Drehrad bekommt,
um die Temperatur seiner Beiträge in der Reichweite einfach hochzudrehen.
Technisch geht es, sogar mit nur 20% der Belegschaft Elon Musk hat es uns gezeigt.
Wovon reden wir? Also wenn der das macht, dann kann ich doch nicht hier in Deutschland,
weil das machen ja jetzt so viele Politiker, Kiesewetter und Co,
die ganze Zeit sagen, TikTok ist unsere große Gefahr.
Wenn ich zugleich einen Elon Musk habe, der sagt, nur die AfD kann uns noch retten.
Naja, für uns in Deutschland ist es eine interessante Diskussion,
weil, dass die Amerikaner, nachdem alle sozialen Netzwerke amerikanische sind
und wir vor elf Jahren von Snowden die Aufklärung bekommen haben,
wie das mit der Politik zusammenhängt,
so, dass die sich sozusagen fremdbestimmt kolonialisiert, also kognitiv kolonialisiert
für den Türchen TikTok und sagen, nee, nee, das muss hier in unsere Hoheit. Das verstehe ich.
Warum deutsche Politiker überhaupt irgendwas dazu sagen, während wir,
also entweder aus Amerika oder aus China, ihr Social Media für alle und bitte
schaut nicht hin und die Aufklärung gibt es dann mal in drei Jahren und so.
Das finde ich natürlich besonders albern.
Wir hören mal weiter.
Comes this boogeyman or this thing that we can talk about that is actually a
vessel for our own anxieties.
So I think towards the end of the TikTok saga, you know, as the bill was passing,
I saw a lot of lawmakers, and I think you probably saw this too,
Taylor, when the CEO of TikTok testified before Congress,
a lot of those questions weren't about China.
They were about kids and social media, right? They were about,
you know, like fears about like what kids are learning online.
Ja, es geht nämlich da offenbar darum, dass man es besser wieder orchestrieren will.
Also ich glaube, dass diese Nähe, du hast ja eben gesagt, wir müssten eigentlich
mal sehen, dass Journalisten und Journalisten,
Politiker sich in einem Antagonismus gegenüberstehen. Und ich glaube aber,
dass wir doch sehr stark haben, über das Öffentlich-Rechtliche hinaus,
also auch mit den privaten Medien,
dass es eigentlich so eine Art der Zusammenarbeit zu geben scheint.
Und jetzt ist man ganz verstört, wenn plötzlich Leute über TikTok eine Reichweite
generieren, die man mit einer FAZ oder so natürlich nicht mehr hinbekommt.
Und dann plötzlich die Meinung, die bei TikTok gesagt wird, viel wahlentscheidender ist.
Stichwort Rezo und sein Video damals, als irgendein FAZ-Herausgeber schreibt
nochmal einen Kommentar auf, wen er als nächsten Kanzler haben möchte.
Das hat natürlich überhaupt keinen Einfluss mehr, das schreibt er für sich und
die seinen, aber das ist etwas, was niemand mehr interessiert.
Ich kann jetzt sagen, ach, das war aber schade, ist aber schade,
dass es so gekommen ist. Ich finde es aber an sich nicht schlecht.
Also ich kann ja jetzt auch, also entweder bin ich grundsätzlich für diese Pluralisierung,
dann muss ich dafür sein.
Oder ich bin halt nur dann für eine Pluralisierung, wenn sie meiner Position
hilft. Und das ist etwas, was wir, glaube ich, gerade beobachten.
Also wenn man irgendwas hat, was, das wird dann als Zusammenhalt geschrieben,
aber wenn es darum geht, dass alles stabilisiert wird,
dann findet man das gerade toll und dann ist das auch super und dann ist plötzlich
jetzt auch Google und Mark Zuckerberg, sind jetzt unsere Freunde,
weil die ja gegen TikTok sind, aber die sind nicht, weiß ich nicht was, aber sobald es dann.
Mir schaden könnte oder so, dann bin ich dagegen.
Also man muss sich jetzt, das ist auch ein bisschen so mit diesen ganzen Debatten um die Demokratie.
Also wenn ich sage, dass jede Stimme gleich viel wert ist und jeder soll wählen
können, dann muss ich aufgrund dieser Prämisse Dinge mitgehen.
Ich kann aber nicht dann sagen, wenn gewählt wird, das hat mir jetzt aber gar
nicht gefallen, können wir mal was am Modus der Wahl ändern,
damit so Ergebnisse nicht zustande kommen.
Dass die Ergebnisse dann nicht zustande kommen, dass nicht solche Videos bei
TikTok millionenfach geklickt werden, in denen gesagt wird, Deutschland ist
am Ende, sondern wo man vielleicht eher mal sagt,
die CDU und die FDP ruinieren unsere Wirtschaftspolitik mit ihrer Austeritäts,
mit ihrem Austeritätsfetisch das ist eine Sache, die muss ja gesellschaftlich
hergestellt werden kann.
Also der Erfolg von Rechten zum Beispiel bei TikTok ist ja nicht einfach nur
durch die Plattform entstanden, sondern auch das resoniert ja mit dem,
was auch gesellschaftlich vorzufinden ist.
Also es hat das ja nicht alles nur produziert, nur es produziert einen anderen
Modus des politischen Sprechens.
Wir kommen ja darauf zurück, indem wir Eva Ilus Buch lesen.
Ja.
Die Moderne trägt eine neue Bindestrich vor, aber es ist ja nicht die Postmoderne
oder sowas, sondern die explosive Moderne.
Explosionen haben typischerweise zwei Ausprägungen.
Entweder Explosion ist Zerstörung und man kann noch so ein bisschen Contained-Zerstörung
machen, indem man sich so einen
Stollen frei ballert, damit man dann an Goldkohle oder was auch immer,
Nur ich glaube, und da hätten wir klügere Bücher gebraucht, als zum Beispiel von Blüdern oder Selk,
diese Idee von die Demokratie, wie wir sie hatten und wie sie sich angebahnt
hat in den letzten 400 Jahren, um dann in den letzten 70 Jahren sozusagen zur Blüte zu kommen,
wurde begleitet von verschiedenen Paradigmen der Gesprächsführung,
wie du sie eben betont hast,
Freiheit, Gleichheit, was auch immer.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie wir schon nächstes Jahr, sagen wir mal Dezember 2025, darüber denken.
Denn ja, TikTok entfesselt jetzt viel. Aber ich will an die Gutenberg-Parenthese erinnern.
Ich habe es ja im Redaktionsschluss vor mittlerweile auch zehn Jahren mal beschrieben.
Jeff Jarvis hat mittlerweile ein ganzes Buch darüber geschrieben,
das ich aber nicht gelesen habe.
Wir möchten jetzt Sachen gestalten, die zwingend organisiert werden müssen.
Also wir brauchen textbasierte, zeitliche Entkernung, Hierarchisierung.
Der Befehl spielt eine ganz wichtige Rolle in der Demokratie.
Also Robert Musel, wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, kam ja damals mit diesem
Spruch, wenn du eine Gesellschaft demokratisch organisieren willst,
musst du die demokratischen Parteien wie Armeen aufstellen.
Also die SPD braucht natürlich einen Führer, der sagt, wo es lang geht.
In Amerika haben wir auch jetzt, Patrick Barnas hat dazu sehr gut in diesem
Einspruch-Podcast geredet, auf die Frage hin, darf der Joe Biden so viele Leute
begnadigen oder commuten, also ihnen die Strafe nehmen, aber dieses Urteil lassen.
Und dann ist er diese Genese durchgegangen, wie die amerikanische Verfassung
damals gebraucht wurde,
als Gentlemen im Raum waren und sie trotzdem entscheidungsfähig sein sollten
und dann gesagt haben, na gut, der Präsident darf durchgreifen.
Also alle Minister sind dem Präsidenten gegenüber rechenschaftspflichtig.
Und so wie sie ihn informieren darüber, was sie tun, darf er ihnen Anweisungen
geben, was sie zu tun haben.
Das kennt man in Europa nicht. Unsere Demokratien sind sozusagen ein bisschen
fortschrittlicher. Wir haben überall das Justizsystem mit eingebaut.
Weshalb es in Deutschland immer heißt, ja, das muss dann das Verfassungsgericht
überprüfen und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist in Amerika nicht so, sondern es gibt einen herausgehobenen Gentleman,
der selber den Staat verwirklicht.
Also er steht nicht über der Verfassung, sondern er ist quasi die Verfassung.
Der erste Satz der Verfassung gibt dem Präsidenten die Rechte,
die Verfassung auszulegen.
So, und das muss natürlich erstmal alles jetzt Bestand haben,
unter der Bedingung, dass Menschen, die an diesem politischen Geschäft teilnehmen,
weil man sie als Wähler braucht.
Zwölf Stunden am Tag mit sozusagen Gefühlslagen aus dem sozialen Nahbereich
konfrontiert werden, wo Organisation,
Hierarchie und alles ausgeblendet wird, wo man die Politik wie so ein Pizzaservice,
aber es gab doch einen Anschlag in Magdeburg, warum sind hier noch Ausländer?
Es war doch ein Ausländer, der das gemacht hat, oder?
Und dann ist doch klar, dass wir jetzt die Ausländer und so weiter.
Und diese neuen emotionalen Kurzschlüsse, die man ganz schnell hoch abstrahieren
kann auf, das haben jetzt 15 Millionen Leute heute gesagt, die Kommentarspalten
quellen über, wir müssen das machen.
Also wir haben sozusagen ein Gespräch über Demokratie, das die Demokratie,
wie ich ja meinte, die ganze Zeit verherrlicht hatte, auch wenn sie gar nicht funktionierte.
Und dieses Verherrlichungsding nehmen wir jetzt mit in diese neue Form von Demokratie,
in der wir einfach alle Organisationen ausblenden.
Die Verherrlichung funktionierte ja auch deshalb so gut, weil diese Meinungen,
die du jetzt gerade erkundgetan hast, in dieser Weise nicht präsent waren.
Also man hat das ja alles sehr runtergedämpft. Man hat ja nur Gewisses zugelassen.
Millionen Menschen haben so gedacht, aber haben es für sich behalten.
Ja.
Haben abgewartet, bis in drei Jahren eine Wahl ist.
Beziehungsweise es ist schon auch so, dass Denkweisen entstehen dadurch,
dass ja medial etwas da ist.
Also man muss ja immer da schauen, wie kommt was zustande. Und ich würde schon
sagen, es werden auch Meinungen generiert durch die Medien an sich,
die sind vorher nicht da.
Es gibt irgendein Gefühl, das man vielleicht mitnehmen kann,
das man abholen kann, aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass wir ja eine lange Zeit
in der Bundesrepublik zumindest,
man versuchte einen Kurs der Mitte zu fahren, was immer dann bedeutete,
dass also gewisse Meinungen nicht einfach repräsentiert waren,
weder im Fernsehen noch in den Zeitungen.
Und zwar, und das ist das, was wichtig ist zu betonen, aus Gründen,
die richtig und nachvollziehbar sind,
weil nämlich dieser emotionale Kurzschluss von irgendwem niemandem hilft und
auch niemanden über irgendetwas informiert, wo es unbedingt Aufklärungsbedarf gibt.
Richtig. So und jetzt erleben wir, dass aber diese emotionalen Kurzschlüsse
in den sozialen Medien sich gut
klicken und dann strukturieren auch alle etablierten Medien um und sagen,
Dunja Hayali muss jetzt noch eine Live-Schalte machen und wir zeigen,
wie das Auto da reinbrettert.
Das ist genau diese Reaktion dann darauf, die falsch ist.
Nur falsch wäre auch eine Reaktion, die sagt, wir müssen jetzt die sozialen
Medien so stark reglementieren, dass wir eigentlich da Medienhäuser haben.
Weil dann kann man am Ende sagen, gut, dann geben wir jetzt die sozialen Medien
in die Hände von Bertelsmann, Springer und weiß ich noch, einem öffentlichen
Gremium und dem katholischen Landfrauenverband und die gemeinsam kuratieren
uns dann die Inhalte. Wollen wir das?
Nein, auf keinen Fall, dann finden wir wahrscheinlich auch bald da nicht mehr statt.
Weshalb ich ja sehr dafür plädiere, dass die Politik ihre Aufgabe jetzt ernst
nimmt und ihr Arsenal dem Publikum zeigt.
Statt immer windelweichgeschlagen in der Straße rumzustehen und sagen,
ja das ist wirklich ganz schrecklich, was hier passierte.
Und nicht nur braucht die Politik ein sozusagen verfeindetes Verhältnis zu den
Medien, sondern auch eine neue Vormachtstellung vor dem Publikum.
Es darf sich nicht einreihen im Publikum. Also eine Demo, die angeführt wird
von einem Politiker, haben wir schon häufiger besagt, das ist einfach falsch.
Der Politiker steht von uns legitimiert, alle möglichen Sachen einsetzen,
die wir nicht einsetzen können, in der Öffentlichkeit und er muss stellvertretend
für uns handeln und nachdenken.
Einfach nur das Denken des Publikums zu übernehmen und dann irgendwas zu machen.
Also wir haben das erlebt, wir hatten die Corona-Pandemie, sie hat sehr viele
Leute aufgeregt und dann kam Kevin Kühnert und hat gesagt, ihr habt ihn euch
gewünscht, ihr habt ihn, unser Gesundheitsminister ist Karl Lauterbach.
So, wir wissen heute, das war keine gute Entscheidung. Also die Ärzteschaft
steht da, er sitzt in der ersten Reihe und es gibt Standing Ovations dafür,
ihn in Grund und Boden zu reden und die Leute gehen tränenüberströmend raus,
weil sie einfach sich freuen darüber, dass sie dabei waren, wie ihm mal die
Leviten gelesen wurden.
Also schlechter kann man wahrscheinlich Gesundheitspolitik gar nicht machen,
als das, was Karl Lauterbach die letzten drei Jahre da gemacht hat.
So, in Amerika funktioniert es gerade nur so.
Jeder einzelne Posten dieser Regierung ist nach diesen, ihr habt ihn euch gewünscht, hier habt ihr ihn.
Robodef Kennedy. Also es läuft alles, auf jeder Ebene wird einfach nur so Showmaster hingesetzt.
Darunter kann die Verwaltung nicht das machen, was sie eigentlich macht,
weil die Weisungsbefugnis kommt
von diesen Leuten. Das sind alles jetzt Handlanger des medialen Betriebs.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du diesen einen Clip gehört hast, wo Trump so betont in diesem
60 Minutes Gespräch, warum er jetzt doch TikTok wohlwollend gegenüber eingestellt ist.
TikTok hat für mich Gutes getan. Ich habe da so einen TikTok-Joe.
Es ist ja absurd. Das ist die Argumentation.
Also du kannst dir jetzt Mühe geben, wie du willst. Der amerikanische Präsident
sagt einfach, er hat da so einen Typen, der macht für ihn Videos.
Das ist so gut, das darf man nicht verbieten.
Ja, das ist einfach absurd.
Die Demokraten waren ja selbst bei TikTok.
And that they have a really sophisticated sort of espionage operation and they're
very interested in getting data from Americans.
But if that was surely the case, then why is the Kamala Harris campaign posting
on TikTok every day and like why is she risking her staffers,
you know, logging in and out of the app, right? Like it doesn't actually make sense.
Wenn die Spionage betreiben.
Ja, ja, ja, das stimmt alles.
Dann kann das Personal nicht auf TikTok sein.
Wahlkämpfer müssen Publikum finden, egal wo es ist. Also da muss alles egal
sein. Aber das Weiße Haus beiden, es war in allen verboten.
Also in offizieller Funktion durfte niemand TikTok auf seinem Handy haben.
Das Weiße Haus war da wirklich sehr streng.
Ja, die wurden in China natürlich nicht mehr dann zugelassen, aber Lorenz sagt auch.
We've always criticized China as a country for being so closed off.
And like you said, they don't allow our apps, so why should we allow their apps or whatever?
But it does seem like this focus on China is ironically making us more kind
of China-like, where it seems like we're cracking down, we're developing our
own tech ecosystem, where we're further cut off from the world-ing.
Dieses Argument, Meta wurde aus China rausgeschmissen, warum schmeißen wir nicht
ByteDance raus, faktisch völlig richtig, aber funktional lässt sich das nicht auflösen.
Außer in diese Richtung, dann werden wir halt wie China.
Ja, und sie geht da weiter, erzählt von einer interessanten Sache.
We don't have it yet, but I think that's the whole issue, right?
Is that there is this desire to create and replicate that surveillance machine
through bills like COSA that require age verification, right?
Or like facial scans or just all of these efforts to tie your offline identity to your online.
I actually think this was like one of the most terrifying moments of my career
was at the White House Content Creators Day or whatever back in August that they had it.
Mit biden yeah i remember this neera tanden's a
biden admin official and she was asking this crowd
of hundreds of content creators who wants to remove anonymity
from the internet raise your hand if you wish that basically all your trolls
could be unmasked and we could eliminate anonymity from the internet and everyone
pretty much raised their hand and cheered and was rooting for this and then
she proceeded to give this whole q a basically the entire day was about removing,
Diese.
Jungen Content-Creator haben überhaupt kein Geschichtsbewusstsein für die Idee des Internets.
Wir wissen natürlich, wie viel da korrumpiert wurde, aber die Idee des Internets,
dieser Freiheit, liegt natürlich in der Anonymität.
Und das wäre vor 15 Jahren natürlich nicht so gekommen, hätte man dort gefragt.
Leute, die im Internet tätig sind, wollt ihr alle auf Anonymität verzichten,
soll man nur noch Klarnamen haben.
Aber diese jungen Content-Creator sind der Ansicht und man konnte das auch sehr
gut sehen, dass ja diese ganzen jungen Content-Creator laufend im Fernsehen
und sonst wo zu Gast sind und sagen,
ja es gibt so viel Hass im Netz und da müssen wir also dringend mal ran und
die wollen eigentlich dann über diese Schiene Hass und Netz und so die Anonymität
vollkommen zum Verschwinden bringen.
Aber es gibt halt keine anonymen Business-Modelle.
Nein, aber dass User im Internet anonym sich rumtreiben können,
dass ich jetzt mir zum Beispiel einen TikTok-Kanal machen kann,
um dort Leuten zu folgen, ohne dass ich dort meinen Klarnamen angeben muss.
Das ist schon sehr wichtig, dass ich mich im Internet, in der Google suche und
sonst wo herumtreiben kann, ohne dass dort sichtbar ist für alle.
Da bin ich jetzt gerade unterwegs.
Na gut, Sichtbarkeit für alle ist ja nochmal was anderes. Also ein transparentes
Internet, aber ein anonymes, sobald du was hinter einer Paywall verkaufst,
sobald du eine gezielte Kundenansprache.
Wärst du mein Uber-Fahrer. Aber da ist sie ja nicht dagegen.
Also da ist ja jetzt nicht, dass Taylor Lawrence sagt, wir brauchen die absolute
Anonymität, dass wo eine Zahlungsdienstleistung oder sowas fertig ist.
Aber auch da ist ja die Frage, wie weit kann das gehen?
Anonymität ist überhaupt kein Wert mehr.
Und ich denke, dass sie diese Content-Creaturen aufbaut mit es,
die nicht mehr wissen, ist wirklich verrückt.
Er ist sehr schlecht. Wir wissen, dass es nicht mehr gibt.
Wir wissen, dass es nicht mehr gibt. Wir wissen, dass wir das.
Wir sehen, dass wir auf das. Aber also, es ist genau das wir,
was China für das deep surveillance state.
So, es scheint zu disingenierend.
Weiß gerade trotzdem nicht genau, was ich hier will.
Naja, aber es gab doch eine lange Zeit, es gab doch mal die Diskussion,
braucht man eine Klarnamenpflicht bei allen sozialen Medien zum Beispiel.
Generell bei sozialen Medien.
Aber man kann sich doch anmelden und die nutzen. Bis zu einer gewissen Grenze.
Ja, nur die Amerikaner hätten ja gerne, also die Demokraten hätten ja gerne,
dass die Anonymität ganz aufgehoben wird.
Und da sind die Content-Creator sofort dabei, weil die sagen,
ja stimmt, dann bekomme ich auch keinen Hass im Netz mehr ab.
Und Matsakis liest dann das Buch über Putins Aufstieg von Masha Gessen und sagt, ja,
der hat auch dann angefangen, vor allem die jugendlichen Diskurse zu kontrollieren
und zu kanalisieren. und sie sagt.
I think if we just look at this for what it is, it's a very troubling idea.
And it's not good that I'm like, oh, I'm reading this book about the rise of
Putin and I see similarities of what's happening in the US. That should set off alarm bells.
And I think that using China or using some sort of scary other place that you
can't really imagine and that you have to listen to our description of is a
really great way to sort of mask what's going on here,
which is more government control of speed mehr government control,
of what kinds of content, what kinds of apps are available.
And it's in this context of we have to protect you from China,
we have to protect the children, just sort of like, you know, overall.
Those are really nice justifications for something that I think fundamentally
is really questionable.
Yeah, and of course they don't want to protect the vulnerable children who would
suffer under these types of laws, the LGBTQ kids that rely on the internet,
you know, for community. And it's a lifeline.
Wir springen jetzt mal zu CNBC. Dort war Josh Gottheimer zu Gast.
Der ist Demokrat und für ein TikTok-Bahn.
Listen, I'm all for protecting people's livelihoods and obviously,
first and foremost, I want to make sure people are okay.
But that's why we've given plenty of time to TikTok to sell the platform and
to an American company, to any other ally,
to anyone who's not focused, as you know, the law says, on actually disrupting
America and pushing anti-American or hateful propaganda on our platforms in
the United States to the 150 million Americans or so who are on TikTok.
Ja, was ist anti-amerikanisch? Das sind alles so schwache Kategorien.
Es ist wirklich so 50er Jahre, Sprech.
A lot of us haven't really thought a lot about what TikTok might be pushing
since the very difficult days during the pandemic, the George Floyd era,
when a lot of people said they were trying to foment further sort of problems in this country.
Is there stuff going on every single day that you see that you're aware of where
you think that they're pushing misinformation at those who are using the app?
Well, obviously, you know, I've received many on the Intelligence Committee
can't share what I learned in those rooms. Right.
Es ist alles geheim. Ich habe im Geheimen was erfahren. Ich kann es mit Ihnen
nicht teilen, aber irgendwas scheint schon zu stimmen.
Broadly speaking, we believe this is a threat to America's national security overall,
literally handing over the keys of a major communications platform,
like the keys of CNBC or ABC or another major channel,
to a number one adversary and letting them have complete control of the algorithm
and the disinformation they can push out, whether that's on election issues,
whether that's on, as you pointed out during the pandemic,
whether that's on hate or antisemitic rhetoric, you name it,
Die concern on the anti-American stuff.
Im Übrigen kann man jetzt gerade bei,
Twitter wahnsinnig viel Antisemitismus erleben.
Und du kannst alles Negatives erleben.
Und zwar zum Teil von Elon Musk mit angestachelt, wenn dann so getan wird,
als sei George Soros doch der geheime Strippenzieher der Welt und so weiter.
Solche Posts findet man bei Twitter zuhauf. Also man müsste sich vielleicht
mal mit Twitter auseinandersetzen und hier zu sagen, naja, und während der Pandemie und so weiter.
Ja, aber das ist doch nicht, was von China aus kam, sondern die Leute haben
das in Amerika ohne chinesischen Einfluss dort reingeschrieben und diesen ganzen Stoß.
Also hier diese ganzen Querdenker-Demos sind doch nicht von China oder Russland gesteuert.
Das ist ja so eine interessante Vorstellung immer, dass das Böse muss wohl außerhalb sein.
Nein, wir haben hier auch genügend Leute, die offenbar davon ausgegangen sind,
dass sie mit dieser Impfung geschippt werden.
Ich will jetzt mal ganz deutlich markieren, Mein Wunsch der smartphonefreien
Schule und mein Wunsch des totalen TikToks-Verbots für alle Minderjährigen hat nichts damit zu tun,
dass ich irgendwie glaube, das ist von China gesteuert oder so.
Sondern mir geht es um die generativen Mechanismen von TikTok selbst.
Die Antwort auf, da steckt ja China nicht dahinter, ist auf gar keinen Fall
ein Freifahrschein für, alle Kinder sollten ungehindert Zugang zu TikTok bekommen,
weil China ist es nicht. dass es steuert. Ganz wichtig.
Ich sprach mit einem Vater von zwei Kindern. Ein Kind ist sechs Jahre,
das andere Kind ist zwölf Jahre.
Sind also beide in der Lage, ein iPad zu bedienen.
Sind nicht bei TikTok, ist auch nicht darunter geladen, aber sie sind bei YouTube.
Diese Kinder, wenn man sie nicht kontrolliert, gucken in Endlosschleife YouTube Shorts.
Geraten da in ganz verrückte Strudel hinein. Die haben Inhalte,
die nicht für 60 Jahre gesetzt, ist das große Problem.
Darüber müssen wir reden, das ist was anderes. Wir blicken nach Albanien,
Entscheidung, wenige Tage alt.
In Albanien wird das besonders bei Kindern und Jugendlichen beliebte Online-Netzwerk
TikTok komplett abgeschaltet.
Die Videoplattform werde ab Anfang 2025 für mindestens ein Jahr gesperrt,
verkündete der albanische Regierungschef Edi Rama.
Er bezeichnete TikTok als den Gauner im Viertel, den Albanien verjagen werde.
Dafür wurden Bildungsprogramme für Kinder gestartet und Eltern sollten dabei
unterstützt werden, den Werdegang ihrer Kinder zu begleiten.
Der Schritt erfolgt wenige Wochen, nachdem ein 14-Jähriger bei einem in Online-Medien
begonnenen Streit zwischen Schülern in Tirana getötet und ein weiterer verletzt worden war.
Die Videoplattform TikTok, die zur chinesischen Gruppe ByteDance gehört,
ist in vielen Ländern hoch umstritten.
So beschloss das australische Parlament Ende November ein Social-Media-Verbot für unter 16-Jährige.
Spanien hatte dies schon im Juni getan.
Das ist jetzt was anderes, dieses Verbot für Minderjährige. Wir haben aber hier
so ein generelles Verbot in Albanien.
Die Opposition in Albanien schäumt.
Für die wäre TikTok interessant. Und die sagen jetzt, nee, das ist der Versuch,
andere Wahlkampagnen nicht zuzulasten. die öffentliche Meinung einzuschränken.
Und der Vorwand ist jetzt, dass da tatsächlich wohl sich Leute verabredet haben
für irgendeine schlimme Tat, bei der man aber sagen muss, dafür hätten die jetzt
sicherlich nicht TikTok gebraucht.
Das ist jetzt noch nicht mal ein TikTok-übliches Vergehen.
Bei TikTok hat man ja solche Grenzüberschreitungen gesehen oder auch irgendwelche
Gewalttaten, weil man ein tolles Video davon anfertigen wollte oder so etwas.
Das hat ja jetzt hier offenbar noch nicht mal stattgefunden.
Wir gehen noch einmal zu Karlin Giocesko.
Zurück nach Rumänien.
Wir werden uns jetzt kurz einen TikTok-Clip von ihm ansehen.
Alle anderen werden ihn hören. Ich werde dann übersetzen, was wir da gehört haben.
Wir sehen hier so einen etwa 60-jährigen alten Mann, der in Badehosen schwimmt,
auf der fährt, reitet, judo, ausübt.
Sport ist für mich ein eines der principale Programme der Christen.
Sport wird dich nicht renunzt, aber auch noch nicht, dass du dich in der Kopf bist.
Wir sehen hier eigentlich Putin, der vitale Mann.
Und in diesem Spot heißt es, ich habe es mir übersetzen lassen,
wir sprechen über die Bedeutung des Sports in unserem Leben.
Sport ist eine Liebesgeschichte, die jeden Tag geschätzt, respektiert und praktiziert werden muss.
Sport lehrt uns, niemals aufzugeben und den ganzen Weg zu gehen,
den Wunsch zu haben, zu gewinnen und Meister zu werden.
Wir haben die Freude mit unserem großen Meistern im Turnen, Handball und so
weiter und werden die weiter unterstützen.
Ist das deine Rentenpolitik? Lange fit bleiben oder welchen Beitrag hat es jetzt
im politischen Gespräch in Rumänien gehabt?
Der Beitrag ist natürlich einfach
nur, ich bin vital und ich gebe euch Fitnesstipps, seid auch vital.
Das ist ein visuelles Medium.
Es richtet sich an junge Menschen. Das, was ihr die ganze Zeit in den Coachings
schon gehört habt, macht jeden Tag was,
lasst eure Träume nicht sterben, seid diszipliniert, ist das,
was ihr hier aufgreift und dann natürlich mit rechtsextremen Positionen verbindet.
Die sind aber nicht in jedem Video vorzufinden, deswegen habe ich das jetzt
hier rausgegriffen, sondern er macht natürlich auch auf diese Weise Metapolitik.
Dann war bei Tagesschau in einem Beitrag auf der Homepage eine Expertin zugeschaltet,
die über TikTok sprach und den Einfluss da auf die Wahl.
Und die sieht jetzt da die große Manipulation nicht. Ich würde das tatsächlich in Frage stellen.
Madalina Wojnear sitzt in ihrem Büro vor einem großen Bildschirm.
Ein verworrenes Datennetz ist darauf zu sehen.
Unterschiedlich große Kreise in verschiedenen Farben stellen die wichtigsten
Hashtags auf TikTok in Rumänien dar.
Der größte Kreis ist blau. Er steht für den Hashtag KELIN JOJESKU.
Der rechtsradikale Parteilose, der
völlig unerwartet die erste Runde der Präsidentschaftswahl gewonnen hat.
Die blauen Linien zeigen, wie sein Hashtag sich in fast allen Blasen auf TikTok verbreitet.
Diese Viralität, ich erwarte dafür immer noch eine Erklärung von TikTok,
wie das hier kein Problem sein soll.
Voynea ist Datenanalystin bei der nichtstaatlichen Organisation Expert Forum.
Kann es nicht einfach sein, dass der funktioniert auf der Plattform wie kein anderer?
Ich kenne jetzt nicht alle rumänischen Politiker, ich kenne in Wahrheit gar keinen.
Aber kann es sein, dass der einfach da wahnsinnig gut funktioniert?
Gut, es gibt irgendwelche Profile, die da noch aktiviert wurden.
Zwei Wochen vor der Wahl haben wir uns das genauer angeschaut und man konnte
sehen, wie er konkurrenzfähig wurde mit anderen Kandidaten, obwohl er in der
öffentlichen Diskussion sonst überhaupt nicht auftauchte. tauchte.
Gerade einmal gut 120 Konten folgten Georgescu zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
aber seine Videos wurden teilweise millionenfach angesehen.
Laut dem rumänischen Inlandsgeheimdienst SRI haben 25.000 Konten zur Verbreitung
der Inhalte beigetragen, Konten, die teilweise schon seit Jahren existierten,
aber erst kurz vor der Wahl aktiv wurden.
Ist ja eigenartig. Ich gebe aber Aber zu bedenken, dass jetzt so ein Rechtsextremer
dort so erfolgreich ist, ist nicht verwunderlich, wenn man sich ansieht,
welche Geisteshaltungen so in der Bevölkerung vertreten sind.
Ich zitiere aus einem Artikel aus der Taz aus dem Jahr 2022.
59 Prozent der Befragten in Rumänien vertreten die Ansicht, dass der als Kriegsverbrecher
hingerichtete Antonesco ein großer rumänischer Patriot gewesen sei.
Dabei war das rumänische faschistische Militärregime unter Antonesco nicht nur
zusammen mit Deutschland am Überfall auf die Sowjetunion beteiligt,
sondern hatte eigene Konzentrationslager und Ghettos für Juden errichtet.
Von denen nach Transnistrien ab Oktober 1941 Deportierten starben etwa 300.000
rumänische und ukrainische Juden sowie über 11.000 Roma.
Und 59% in der Bevölkerung sagen, das ist doch ein Held.
Das ist einfach da, in der Bevölkerung. Jetzt ist die Frage,
wie connected so ein Georgescu damit?
Ist das jetzt Russland? Es ist die Frage.
Für Madalina Wojneja sieht das nicht danach aus, als ob Georgescus Anhängerschaft
auf TikTok auf normalem Wege gewachsen sei.
Es gibt klare Anzeichen dafür, dass es eine Art koordinierte Strategie war,
um ihn zu bewerben. Die rechtsextreme Blase in Rumänien hat keine Werbung für ihn gemacht.
Er hat aus dem Nichts eine neue Unterstützerblase geschaffen.
Und es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass das organisch geschieht.
Wer sind diese Unterstützer in Wirklichkeit? Es gibt sie nicht.
Die rumänischen Behörden vermuten, dass Russland hier mitgemischt hat.
Nun gibt es von Politico dazu eine Meldung, die ist jetzt neu.
Es gibt ein Recherche-Kollektiv Snoop, heißt das, in Rumänien.
Eine Kampagne einer regierenden Mitte-Rechts-Partei könnte zugunsten des rechtsextremen
Kandidaten Carlin Georgesco missbraucht worden sein.
Die Mitte-Rechts-Partei Rumäniens, die Nationale Liberale Partei,
hat für eine Kampagne auf TikTok bezahlt, die letztendlich dem rechtsextremen
unabhängigen Kandidatin Carlin Georgesco zugute kam,
wie aus einem neuen Bericht des investigativen Portals snoop.ro hervorgeht.
Laut dem Snoop-Bericht hat die rumänische Steuerbehörde festgestellt,
dass die Liberalen eine Social-Media-Kampagne auf TikTok über Influencer und
durch die Bewerbung eines Hashtags finanziert hatten,
der schließlich zugunsten von Ceausescu zweckentfremdet wurde.
Die Nationalliberale Partei beauftragte die externe Firma Kensington Communication
mit der Umsetzung der Social Media Kampagne.
In einer Erklärung schrieb Kensington Communication, wenn die Kampagne geklont
oder zugunsten des einen oder anderen Kandidaten missbraucht wurde,
bitten wir die zuständigen Stellen, dies zu überprüfen und die erforderlichen
rechtlichen Maßnahmen zu ergreifen.
Also sehr fraglich, was hier eigentlich stattgefunden hat.
Fest steht jedoch, dass wir natürlich gerade in den USA erleben,
dass sich da einige Konzerne gesund stoßen könnten dadurch, dass TikTok verboten wird.
Bloomberg spricht über die Tech-Aktien und den TikTok-Bann.
Wir werden über die Marken Reaktion zu diesem News-Tik-Tock.
Faktor in den USA, hier in der Fall, der Appeals Court refusing zu blockieren, ein law auf das.
Und es ist wirklich interessant, weil die Magnificent Seven-Stocks,
sie haben bereits über 65% hier zu Ende.
Wir haben ein 4% Rally, ich glaube, über die letzten paar Tage.
Already hitting ein freshes Räckern, yesterday.
Und dann haben wir das News-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen-Tippen.
Ja, das könnte dann natürlich Kurssprünge verursachen. Wir hören jetzt zum Schluss Donald Trump.
Ich habe nicht das aus Sixty Mint, sondern er wird in einer Pressekonferenz
nochmal nach TikTok gefragt und erzählt jetzt eine Minute lang.
We'll take a look at TikTok. You know, I have a warm spot in my heart for TikTok
because I won Youth by 34 points.
And there are those that say that TikTok has something to do with that.
Now, Joe Rogan did, and some of the other people that were recommended by my
son Barron, who have Inu names, I said, Who is that?
Tell me, who's that? Dad, you've got to be kidding. I can't believe you don't know.
And I did those interviews, and it was actually sort of cute.
You want to know the truth, but we did them and that had an impact,
but TikTok had an impact and so we're taking a look at it, but you know, we won youth,
Republicans are always 30 points down in youth, I don't know why but we ended
up finishing, we were there was one poll that showed us down about 30,
we were 35 or 36 points up with young people,
so I have a little bit of a warm spot in my heart, I'll be honest.
Ein Herz für TikTok Ein.
Herz für TikTok.
Er beschreibt doch da nochmal seine Wahlkampfstrategie. Sein Sohn sagt ihm,
geh mal da zu den Streamern und zu den Podcastern, wer sind die?
Ja, Papa, die musst du doch kennen.
Aber TikTok war auch so wichtig, deswegen könnte es dann vielleicht doch jetzt bei TikTok bleiben.
Ich finde allerdings, wenn er sagt, wir haben da ein Problem,
wir erreichen die Jugend nicht.
Ich finde auch, dass man darüber sich Gedanken machen muss.
Man kann nicht einfach sagen, wir stellen mal TikTok und so weiter ab und hat
damit die Jugend wieder im Boot. Also das ist ja, glaube ich,
die Vorstellung bei vielen, dass wenn TikTok erstmal nicht mehr da ist,
dann werden die schon alle in die SPD eintreten oder so.
Das wird nicht der Fall sein. Insofern, man muss, wenn man das Problem,
das man jetzt mit TikTok assoziiert lösen will,
glaube ich politisch lösen und TikTok zu verbannen und Kurzvideos zu verbannen,
ist vielleicht eine pädagogische Maßnahme im Sinne von, da sollen die Kinder
nicht den ganzen Tag das gucken.
Aber inhaltlich zu glauben, man kriegt damit den Diskurs wieder eingefangen, ist völlig falsch.
Den müsste man politisch einfach einfangen dadurch, dass man eine andere Politik macht.
Aber das ist ja nicht, wir gehen ja wirklich dem schrecklichsten Wahlkampf aller
Zeiten entgegen, weil wir ja nicht so viele Optionen da bekommen.
Nur auf unterschiedlicher Rhetoriken.
Also, was soll ich sagen? Mein Finale zu diesem Thema ist wie folgt.
Diese Idee, dass die Politik irgendwann auch mal die jungen Menschen braucht,
nachdem man ihnen 18 Jahre lang ein Wahlrecht bei einer Bundestagswahl oder
in Amerika bei einer Präsidentin verweigert hat.
Fangen wir jetzt wieder mit dem Kinderwahlrecht an?
Und dann sind sie plötzlich 19. Und dann denkt sich die Politik,
ich brauche jetzt mal die Stimme der Jugend. und dann ist einem alles egal und
man stellt einfach nur fest, ach ja, die hängt bei TikTok rum.
Ja, dann spiele ich denen jetzt mal Clips bei TikTok aus.
Und man stellt fest, das ist die wahlentscheidendste Sache überhaupt,
die man machen kann für die Jugendlichen.
In dem endlosen Stream von Shorts mal eine politische Botschaft einzubauen.
Weil ansonsten gar nichts dort stattfindet in diesem erbärmlichen,
ärmlichen, wirklich elenden Leben der westlichen Jugendlichen.
Dann ist das eine ganz, ganz, ganz traurige Botschaft.
Ja.
Weshalb ich in meinem Buch natürlich ein sehr starkes Plädoyer für Demokratie
für alle. Wählen ab null.
Konsequent. Wenn wir eine Demokratie haben, dann bitte konsequent. Zweitens.
Wir haben uns nicht nur für diese Demokratie entschieden, sondern auch für die Marktwirtschaft.
Also muss alles eingepreist werden. Die Jugend braucht pro Jahr eine Billion Euro.
Punkt. und wenn die Billion nicht auf dem Tisch liegt, dann finden wir irgendwo
noch mal im Handgemenge so eine TikTok-Aufmerksamkeit und hoffen,
dass wir über den Hashtag die Jugend erreichen, damit sie bitte nicht die Nazis wählen.
Ich erinnere an El Maffalani, der hat ja einen Vortrag mit in Dortmund gehalten,
der hat jetzt auch ein Buch.
Das spielt mit der Mehrheit, Minderheit ohne Schutz. Genau, so ist der Titel.
Und er hat das kurz aufgeschlüsselt. Wenn du 2007 geboren bist,
also jetzt gerade volljährig wirst und das erste Mal an deiner Bundestagswahl teilnimmst.
Als du ein Jahr alt warst, Liemann-Pleite.
Staatsschuldenkrise. Olaf Scholz auch, aber damals Schäuble stellt die Schuldenbremse
scharf. So, immer noch Nachwirkungen des 11. September.
Pandemie. Krieg. Und dann wirst du plötzlich 16 und nimmst an der Europawahl
teil und das allererste Mal stellt die erwachsene Öffentlichkeit fest.
Was ist denn das für eine Generation?
Dann ist einfach alles zu spät. In der Hinsicht dieser New Yorker Aufschlag
von der Gouverneurin zu sagen, wir verbieten jetzt erstmal TikTok.
Und zwar nicht, weil wir das für eine gute Idee halten. Auch nicht,
weil wir das für zukunftsträchtig halten.
Also Smartphones in der Schule allgemein, darum ging es hier, nicht um TikTok.
Keine Smartphones in der Schule. Es ist die allererste der grundlegenden fundamentalen
Erste-Hilfe-Maßnahmen, die uns erstmal gar nichts verschafft,
außer ein Fokus auf, was machen wir eigentlich jetzt mit der Zeit der Jugendlichen,
in der sie nicht mehr einfach aus unserem Blickfeld verschwinden,
weil sie in der Ecke rumliegen, kognitiv halbtot.
Durch ihr Smartphone scrollen und deswegen nicht auffallen. Ja,
darum geht es sozusagen.
Es geht nicht um die Weltrettung, nicht um die Lösung irgendeines Problems,
sondern es ist die allerelementarste erstmal erste Hilfemaßnahme,
die sagt, komm, mit acht Jahren und jeden Tag drei Stunden TikTok, das geht nicht.
Ja, da bin ich ja sehr dafür, dass man das einschränkt.
Aber das ist ja quasi auch eine erzieherische Maßnahme, die zu treffen ist.
Also das muss, das jetzt einmal, das so über die Schule zu machen ist,
das ist ja gut und schön und dann natürlich auch im Elternhaus da in gewisser
Weise Acht zu geben, aber wenn wir jetzt darüber hinaus über TikTok reden,
dann kann es ja jetzt nicht darum gehen,
dass man, nur weil einem diese Plattform gerade mal nicht gefällt,
weil da Meinungen sind, die mir nicht zu passen sind, dass man das dann verbietet,
weil wir da wirklich so eine neue Zensur bekommen und dann ist als nächstes Twitch dran.
Dann sagen die, ja, die sitzen nur noch da und das ist auch so ungesund.
Die trinken so viel Eistee und essen Chips und gucken den ganzen Tag Twitch.
Jetzt müssen wir da ran. Und das ist immer eigentlich vom Establishment dann
so ein Versuch, die eigenen Fründe nochmal zu schützen.
Ja, aber schon, so wie du es jetzt argumentierst, zu sagen,
die Welt der jungen Erwachsenen, die Twitch gucken, darf auf gar keinen Fall
gestört werden, nur weil alle Minderjährigen halbtot in der Ecke liegen und
kognitiv verwahrlost sind, Und in allen Bildungs-, also Maffalani sagt, Jugend, freier Fall.
Egal, welche Kennziffer sie heranziehen, es ist alles freier Fall.
Bildung, freier Fall. Ökonomische Ausstattung, freier Fall.
Kulturelles Angebot, freier Fall. Es war noch nie so schlimm,
selbst die Nachkriegszeit war für die jungen Leute besser als das,
was sie jetzt, auf dem Acker die Kartoffel raussuchen und für den invaliden
Vater die Suppe zu kochen,
War für die Jugendlichen noch besser als das, was wir jetzt gerade haben.
Und dann würden wir aber doch uns sofort darauf einigen, dass das dann politische
Maßnahmen sind und vor allem finanzielle Mittel, die da sein müssen,
damit das nicht so aussieht.
Aber das ist ja dann nicht eine Frage von, welche Plattform muss ich abschalten,
damit es allen wieder besser geht.
Nee, genau. Deswegen ja. Es erfordert größere Maßnahmen, aber wenn jetzt erstmal
Erste Hilfe irgendwie in New York und man versucht mal was, man kann,
ja, wir schauen uns das jetzt mal an.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, ob die wirklich dann auch was anderes dann anbieten oder
ob die nicht einfach auch eine Politik des Verbots machen, aber nicht was anderes noch einem geben.
Weil ich würde sagen, wer irgendwas abstellen will und nicht zugleich drei Theaterhäuser
und fünf Bibliotheken errichtet, der versagt.
Ganz genau.
Und einen Aufbaudiskurs haben wir nirgendwo.
Nee.
Nirgendwo. Also das nächste Jahr wird das erste von vielen Jahrzehnten,
die düster sind einfach.
Und Leute versuchen jetzt immer noch sich zu wehren gegen Friedrich Merz und so weiter.
Nein, die Bundestagswahl ist schon eine geschriebene Geschichte.
Das ist alles schon gelaufen.
Naja, ob es jetzt Scholz oder Merz wird, ist egal. Wer soll sonst Kanzler werden?
Ja gut, das ist schon, das ist eine von den beiden wird es mir jetzt auch klar.
Geschriebene Geschichte.
Aber da ist schon, würde ich sagen, ein Unterschied, ob Scholz oder Merz regiert,
gerade außenpolitisch.
Also nachdem ich, wie gesagt, die Bilanz der familienpolitischen Maßnahmen der
Fortschrittskoalition, sage ich dir, keiner wird irgendetwas machen.
Meine 4000 Euro, die ich gespendet habe, sind mehr Familienpolitik,
als wir die nächsten vier Jahre erleben werden. Das ist meine These,
mit der gehe ich jetzt rein.
Was keine Verbesserung gibt? Könnte, ja.
Wir schauen jetzt mal, in welche Richtung wir gerade abbiegen.
Mark Zuckerberg sitzt auf einer Bühne. Wir haben ihn da schon gesehen.
Zu anderen Themen. Jetzt wenden wir uns diesem sozialen Nahfeld mal zu.
Soziale Verbindungen, Social Media, Meta, Facebook ist natürlich erster Ansprechpartner.
Er ist auf dieser Acquired-Konferenz.
You know, at Meta, we've been building social experiences for 20 years now.
And originally it took the form of a website, then mobile apps.
But the thing is, I never thought about us as a social media company.
We're not a social app company. We are a social connection company.
I mean, we talked about what we're doing is building the future of human connection.
So, Human Connection. Man könnte ja denken, das ist sehr gut.
Denn wenn der Paritätische Wohlfahrtsverband eine Studie macht, bei der herauskommt,
ja im Armutsbericht stehen 10 Millionen arme Menschen in Deutschland,
aber wenn wir die Wohnkosten mit einpreisen, sind es plötzlich 21 Millionen
Menschen unter der Armutsgrenze und wir wissen genau,
wen hohe Wohnkosten betreffen, die mit Kindern zu Hause, weil die Kinder tragen
nichts bei. Die gehen in der Schule und die haben nicht mal Einkommen.
In der Schule verwahrlosen sie noch und dann haben sie nicht mal Einkommen.
Also wir reden jetzt sozusagen über die, die eigentlich Social Connection brauchen.
Jetzt sagt er, nee, wir sind ja gar keine Social Media Company,
wir sind Connection, wir connecten.
Wir gehen jetzt mal dieser Frage nach, was connected oder wen connected Mark
Zuckerberg eigentlich?
Er kriegt hier so eine Frage, wir haben diesen Chloe Abrams Podcast auch schon
gehört, in dem sie ihnen die Fragen stellt.
Jetzt kommen die zu diesem Thema Aber wer braucht hier eigentlich Social Connection?
Die Antwort ist natürlich alle. Aber wie reagiert Mark Zuckerberg darauf?
Over the last 20 years, the amount of time American adults spend socializing
in person has dropped by nearly 30%.
For ages 15 to 24, according to the Surgeon General, it's nearly 70%.
And I look at that data and I think to myself, well, maybe if we're all socializing
digitally, that doesn't matter so much.
Maybe there's a future where that's actually fine.
But there's also data that suggests that we're struggling somewhat.
The number of Americans who say that they... Ja,
das ist wirklich sad.
Und ich frage mich, warum denkst du, dass das passiert? Ich meine,
es gibt vieles, um es zu verpacken.
Ein viel hat sich economisch und soziale verändert, und viele Trends zurückgekommen,
bevor die modernen Technologie.
Das ist etwas, was viele Akademiker und Leute studiert haben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung davon.
Sie bringt dieses Argument, das ist ja auch schon angedeutet.
Aber wir könnten doch das soziale Nahfeld ersetzen durch und dann viel passgenaue
Freunde, die wir irgendwo, dann haben wir so eine Community und dann reden wir
alle über Wagner, über Lieblingsspiele, was auch immer, Fußball und so.
Und man hört bei ihm schon raus, ja, ja, das findet er auch alles ganz traurig,
aber wahrscheinlich will er auch nicht in Teufels Küche kommen,
indem er jetzt irgendwie darauf
einsteigt und sagt, ja, ja, das können wir alles jetzt und so weiter.
Irgendwie unser Social Connection Ding wird hier Abhilfe sein.
Im Vergecast ungefähr so dieselbe Fragestellung, also Mark Zuckerberg wird ganz schön gelöchert.
But in addition to that, I mean, if the average person, I think,
maybe they'd like to have 10 friends,
and I mean, there's the stat that it's sort of sad, but I think the average
American feels like they have fewer than three real kind of close friends.
So, does this take away from that? My guess is no.
I think that what's gonna happen is it's going to help give people more of the
support that they need and give people more kind of reasons and ability to connect
with either a broader range of people Ja.
Die Online-Freundschaft nimmt von der Vor-Ort-Freundschaft nichts weg.
Das sind alles nur Ergänzungen und eben schon bei Abrams, er möchte auf gar
keinen Fall in Verbindung gebracht werden mit einem Trend der Entfreundschaftung.
Oder wie man das auch immer dann nennt. Das hat alles mit ihm gar nichts zu tun.
Trotzdem hat er Sachen im Angebot, die diesem Trend jetzt begegnen können.
Ich hoffe, die Hörer hören schon raus. Ich will jetzt keine Stunde Monolog darüber
halten, dass natürlich dieses Facebook-Phänomen die Leute aus ihrem sozialen
Umfeld kognitiv so ein bisschen rausnimmt.
Ich hatte das in dieser einen Studie, im Redaktionsschluss, da haben die einfach
so einen bewusstlosen Schauspieler quasi in so eine Bankfiliale gelegt.
Vielleicht war es auch ein echter Fall, die sind ihm nachgegangen.
Ebenfalls das Studiensetting war so, du willst Geld holen, gehst in deine Bankfiliale
und da liegt aber jemand in der Ecke.
Und dann beobachtet man die Leute und befragt sie, was sie da tun.
Und sehr viele steigen einfach drüber.
Wie in diesem Film, It's All About Love, wo die Leute einfach umfallen,
wenn die Herzenswärme nicht mehr da ist.
Dann liegen sie einfach so am Straßen, also im Straßenbild liegen einfach Leute
und wenn man sie darauf anspricht, sagt man so, naja, aber dadurch,
dass sie hier liegen, sehen wir ja, dass sie keiner vermisst,
also es ist nicht so schlimm. So ungefähr ist der Tenor des Films.
Und die Leute werden dann gefragt, warum seid ihr da einfach drüber gestiegen,
warum habt ihr denen nicht geholfen?
Und dann sind sie dem so nachgegangen und haben festgestellt,
umso mehr die Leute ihr Smartphone dabei hatten, hatten sie auch so ein Gefühl
von, meine mir wichtigen Leute sind ja gerade bei mir.
Ich habe sie entweder als online oder laufenden Chat oder wie auch immer.
Es reicht mir zu sehen, dass sie in meinem Adressbuch sind.
Ich muss mich um mein soziales, um die Situation, in der ich echt stecke,
in Realität, in Real Life sozusagen, gar nicht kümmern, weil meine soziale Aufgehobenheit
spielt ja woanders statt.
Also es gibt auch nachweisbar diese Verbindung aus, wenn alle Leute im Bus sitzen
und jeder sich mit seinem Smartphone beschäftigt,
Dann kommt irgendwann der Dings, wie heißt der, Manfred Spitzer mit einem Buch,
in dem steht, ja, ja, das vererbt sich dann.
Also der Zehnte fängt dann auch nicht an im Gespräch in der Bahn,
sondern, nee, der holt dann auch sein Smartphone raus.
Also wir haben eine Infizierung mit Einsamkeit durch Handynutzung,
Social Media, wie auch immer.
Weil man sich dann da schon aufgehoben fühlt, wo man gar nicht aufgehoben ist.
Machen ja auch viele ältere Leute, ich habe es ja häufiger im Gespräch dann immer so gesagt.
Leute verlassen ihren Arbeitsplatz und stellen dann viel zu spät fest,
dass ihre Arbeitskollegen gar nicht ihre Freunde waren.
Malte Welding betont, Facebook-Freunde helfen dir nicht beim Umzug.
Also es ist mittlerweile auch so im Sprichwort-Grundwortschatz angekommen,
dass es hier so ein Disconnect durch Social Connections gibt.
Sind wir denn grundsätzlich schiefgewickelt, wenn wir das Smartphone rausholen
und uns rauskatapultieren aus einer Gesellschaft, in der wir uns gerade befinden?
Also du hast jetzt das Beispiel Bahn oder Bus angesprochen.
Dort würde ich sagen, möchte ich ja mit niemandem sprechen. Da bin ich ja froh,
wenn ich entweder mit einem Gerät oder mit einem Buch kommuniziere.
Ja, also ich möchte anregen, ich habe es jetzt auch gemacht,
ich habe das erste Mal jemanden mit GPT chatten sehen in freier Wildbahn in der Bahn.
Schaut den Leuten ruhig mal aufs Display, was sie gerade tun.
Denn das Ausmaß an Zerstreuung und man schiebt irgendwelche bunten Platzebläschen
über seinen Bildschirm und ja, also so beschäftigt man sich halt.
Aber es ist halt dieses Abbiegen in Dopamin und nicht in Oxytocin.
Ja, vielleicht bin ich da anders, aber ich arbeite einfach.
Ja, da bist du sehr anders, Wolfgang, und das weißt du aber auch.
Die Leute kommen von der Arbeit und sitzen dann nicht da und lesen ein schwerfälliges
Buch, sondern sie zerstreuen sich.
Sie wollen die Ablenkung und es ist nichts Falsches daran.
Nur die Ablenkung in seiner Nachbarschaft ein Gespräch zu führen ist,
wir kommen wahrscheinlich nicht zu Thomas Fuchs, also ein großer Koryphäer,
Klinikleiter, der einen Vortrag gehalten hat vor ein paar Jahren beim Psychiatrackongress
zum Thema Körperlichkeit bei psychischen Krankheiten.
Ich habe nur zwei Clips, weil er jetzt zu Gast war im Philosophie-Radio bei
Jürgen Wiebeke, aber dieser Vortrag hatte leider keine Tonspur,
als er mir zugeschickt wurde und die ließ sich auch nicht wieder herstellen,
deswegen können wir diesen Vortrag leider nicht im Original hören.
Aber der neue Begriff von Intelligenz,
den wir brauchen, der hat sehr viel mit Körperlichkeit zu tun.
Das Gehirn ist nicht ein Computer, der einfach vor sich hin rechnet und der Körper führt aus.
Sondern es gibt so ein Resonanzverhältnis zwischen Körper und Gehirn.
Jeder Sportler weiß das, jeder Musiker weiß das.
Das gilt aber für alles. Das gilt auch im akademischen Betrieb.
Und es gilt vor allem für diese soziale Intelligenz, die wir einfach im Alltag brauchen.
So, und wenn wir keine Gespräche führen, wenn wir lieber schnell aus dem Fahrstuhl
raushuschen, wenn wir erleichtert sind darüber, dass wir im Smartphone was lesen
können, damit wir nicht mit dem Arbeitskollegen reden müssen,
sondern einfach, oh, ich hab grad zu tun, ja, keine Ahnung, so, ja.
Wenn uns so eine elementare Gesprächsführung so einfach fällt,
ist es nichts anderes als körperlicher Eskapismus, als einer sozialen Situation,
in der wir wirklich stecken. Ja.
So und das hilft nicht weiter. Also das ist einfach eine Ablenkung im Moment,
die zu null Resultaten führt.
Okay, also dann unterscheiden wir jetzt zwischen Situationen,
in denen man jetzt einfach seine Ruhe haben will und arbeiten möchte und den
Situationen, in denen man einfach sich abkapselt, um dann sinnlose Dinge zu tun,
wo also das zwischenmenschliche Gespräch und hätte es auch keinen besonderen
Tiefgang, immer mehr herstellen würde, als das, was stattfindet,
wenn man irgendein Online-Game spielt.
Und ich erlebe es ja auch, da ich ja gar kein Smartphone mit mir führe.
Und dann aber schon mal mit irgendwelchen Leuten, wo ich stehe oder sitze.
Mit mir dann keiner spricht, weil drei, vier Leute jeweils auf ihr Smartphone blicken.
Das fällt den anderen Smartphone-User nicht auf, weil die ja auch gerade bei
Twitter oder sonst wo unterwegs sind. Nur ich stehe dann alleine da.
Also ich gucke dann vier Leuten zu, wie sie auf ihr Smartphone gucken und muss
sie dann unterbrechen, damit sie dann wieder ihren Blick heben, um mit mir zu sprechen.
Der am meisten in der Geschichte der Soziologie zitierte Text von Kranowetter behandelt genau das.
Erfolge im Beruf, Erfolge in der Partnerschaft, längeres Leben.
Also das steht noch nicht in dem Text, aber es gibt die Psychologieanalyse dazu.
Längeres Leben. Es sind die losen Kopplungen.
Es sind nicht die tiefen, festen Freundschaften, auf die man sich immer verlassen
kann und nachts anrufen und so weiter und so fort.
Sondern das gelingende, spontane Gespräch, das sich einfach so ergibt.
Eine Minute oder drei dauert, fertig. Mit den Nachbarn am Gartenzaunen.
Aber du bist doch auch jemand, der sehr häufig zum Smartphone greift zum Beispiel,
um Fotos zu machen. Mir ist zum Beispiel was aufgefallen.
Ich muss das jetzt ein bisschen verklausuliert ausdrücken. Ich war in einer
Runde und diese Runde kommt immer mal wieder zusammen in einer Regelmäßigkeit,
so einmal im Jahr und dort werden dann von einer Person auch immer Fotos gemacht.
Ich habe mir nie was dabei gedacht, gucke dann, zur Kamera wird ein Foto gemacht,
also es geht ruckzuck und dann ist man da zusammen und das sind schöne Abende.
Jetzt fand aber statt, dass diese Person zeigte, dass sie jetzt ein Fotoalbum
gemacht hat mit den Fotos, die sie immer bei diesen Treffen gemacht hat und
dann gibt es irgendeinen Tool, dass das dann einem so vorgespielt wird,
mit einer Musik untermalt.
Und es trat auch sofort zu einer Erleichterung auf, oh, jetzt kommt ein Smartphone
auf den Tisch, jetzt können wir uns alle mal da drüber beugen.
Dann wurde also da diese Slideshow gezeigt, aus den vergangenen Jahren dieser Treffen.
Und es geschah etwas Interessantes, weil man das sich ansah und dachte,
ah, das war da schön und das war schön und das war schön und das war schön.
Aber man erlebt dann den Moment.
Im Modus der Nostalgie und nicht mehr als Moment. Das heißt,
die Fotos, als sie nur gemacht wurden und das Ding dann wieder verschwand,
da war es nicht störend, sondern hat man im Moment gelebt.
Sobald man aber in die Retrospektive dann geht, bei dem besagten Treffen,
wo eigentlich nur die Fotos gemacht werden, wo man also selbst dann plötzlich
sich in diese Lage versetzt, zurückzublicken,
Momente abzugleichen von früher, kommt man nicht mehr im Hier und Jetzt an.
Und man ist eigentlich in einer Situation, dass man sagen kann,
wir könnten auch zu Hause sitzen und jeder kann sich ja dann die Fotos anschauen,
die in den letzten Jahren entstanden sind.
Und das ist sehr interessant, dass wir eigentlich da,
sobald dieses Gerät hinzukommt, auch sehr schnell in so eine Retrospektivität eintreten,
die das Hier und Jetzt dann eigentlich zu einem nicht so interessanten Ort werden
lässt, beziehungsweise kann in dem Hier und Jetzt dann nicht nochmal ein Moment
produziert werden, der es wert ist,
fotografiert zu werden, um dort archiviert zu werden.
Und ich bin ja jemand, der nie Fotos macht. Ich mache einfach gar keine Fotos.
Ich weiß noch, als ich auf einer Klassenfahrt nach Prag war.
Haben meine Eltern mir ein Fotoapparat gekauft und dann den Film,
nee, das war natürlich digital, ich sollte also Fotos machen.
Und ich weiß noch, die Reise war fast rum, dass ich dachte, ach scheiße,
jetzt hast du gar keine Folie gemacht und wie ich wahllos einfach noch 15 Fotos
geschossen habe, um zu dokumentieren, ich war wirklich dort.
Aber was wäre das auch für ein Quatsch gewesen, jetzt da auf der Karlsbrücke ein Foto zu machen.
Ich mache gar keine Fotos, ich bin nur hier, nur jetzt und sonst bin ich da nicht für zu haben.
Also ich bin zumindest auch niemand, der sich Fotos nochmal ansieht.
Genau, also Fotos, das greifen wir kurz auf, weil wir jetzt direkt,
der nächste Clip passt dann dazu, wir können das als Hinmoderation nehmen.
Also diese Smartphone-Foto-Sache, die finde ich gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber was machst du damit?
Also ich lebe ja sozusagen alle zweite Woche mit Familie und dann jede zweite Woche ohne.
Also ich wechsle immer hin und her. Was bedeutet, dass ich zum Beispiel dazu
übergegangen bin, bei den Gute-Nacht-Drüsen meistens ein Foto mitzuschicken.
Also nicht nur zu schreiben, ich bin gerade in der Oper, sondern ich schicke
da ein Bild. Ich mache einfach ein spontanes hier und so weiter.
Man sieht das, was los ist. Schon allein, weil für die Kinder,
also die Bandbreite eines Fotos im Vergleich zu einem Text ist halt,
da kommt einfach mehr rüber. So, ja, was macht Papa eigentlich gerade?
Zweitens, aus der anderen Richtung, das Foto liegt vor.
Ich habe es sehr zu schätzen gelernt, ich bin zwar nicht allzu oft dabei,
so in der Runde, aber bei unseren Freunden hier, Human Mary 1789, die machen Check-ins.
Also man kommt aus dem Wochenende, eröffnet die Woche, wie auch immer und dann
gibt es erstmal ein Check-in. Mary ist dann sehr hinterher, dass jeder kurz
erzählt, was war am Wochenende so los.
Und zwar ganz niederschwellig, also man erzählt einfach, das kennt man so ein
bisschen, Stuhlkreis, erste Klasse, die Lehrerin fragt, wie war es?
Und die Kinder sind überhaupt nicht in der Lage, irgendwas zu sagen,
aber irgendwann dann doch.
Die sagen, war schön.
Genau, so eine Übungssache. Wenn das mit Fotos unterstützt wird,
so eine Geschichte vom Wochenende zu erzählen, sind das sozusagen Anlässe für diesen Moment.
Indem man so eine Sozialität dann gestaltet. Also in der Hinsicht ist dieses,
die Fotos, also dass die Smartphones alle Fotos machen können,
finde ich clever eingesetzt schon ganz schön wichtig.
Man muss sich halt verabschieden von dieser Idee von, ich mache jetzt hier ein
Foto und das kommt sofort ins Archiv.
Nein, das sind einfach nur so ganz kleine Kommunikationen. Also wir haben ja
auch mit Olli einen Fotografen, der kann gar nicht richtig nachvollziehen,
wieso Instagram und der ganze Kram, weil für ihn ist ein Foto natürlich immer,
also es muss vorbereitet werden, ich brauche Zeit für das Licht,
kannst du den Tisch nochmal umstellen, dann wird ein Foto gemacht,
das wird später ausgedruckt und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, während wir einfach, man schickt sich halt so Kram hin und her,
also das Foto wird gemacht und versendet und nach einer Sekunde ist der Zauber verflogen.
Ja, aber was ich ja nachvollziehen kann, ist, dass man besondere Momente versucht,
so festzuhalten oder zumindest, ja, etwas will man wohl mitnehmen und deswegen schießt man ein Foto.
Das ist mir völlig klar. Es sind ja auch viele Leute, die jetzt mit mir ein Selfie oder so machen.
Das sind doch immer besondere Momente. Wir sind doch alle Main Character.
Nein, eben nicht. Also ich würde sagen, dass ich beobachte ja,
wenn ich im Restaurant zum Beispiel sitze oder in Bar sitze,
dass Leute jeden Drink und jeden Gang abfotografieren.
Das ist ja nicht so besonders. Also ein Espresso Martini ist ein Espresso Martini
und da glaube ich, reicht es auch, wenn man mal ein Foto in seinem Leben von
gemacht hat, man wird nicht 170 drauf.
Ein Espresso muss man auch nicht fotografieren, aber manche Sachen schon.
Aber das ist etwas, was ja in einer Weise stattfindet, wo ich mich wundere.
Also ich kann ja verstehen, wenn man jetzt eine besondere Person trifft oder
wenn man jemanden seit langem wieder trifft und weiß, man sieht ihn auch eine
Weile nicht wieder, dass man dann gemeinsam ein Foto macht. Ist mir ja völlig schlüssig.
Aber mir ist nicht klar, warum man sobald etwas irgendwie gerade angenehm oder
schön ist, sagt, ich muss das mal fotografieren.
Also das ist so, ich will ja in dem Moment jetzt sein, also ich will mich freuen
über ein schönes Essen und will es jetzt genießen und nicht nochmal sagen,
ich schiebe nochmal was dazwischen, weil ich ja dann zu der Situation wieder in Distanz trete,
dadurch, dass ich ja jetzt darüber nachdenke, dass wir es eigentlich hier mit
einem Arrangement für ein Foto zu tun haben.
Ja, also du hast uns diesen Millennial-Moment schon mal beschrieben.
Für die einen ist Foto machen Olli-Style. Ja, wir müssen das kurz sagen.
Was du damit meinst. Millennial Pause hieß das. Also Millennial Pause meint,
dass Millennials noch nicht ganz digital sind.
Sie sind nicht Digital Native. Das heißt, wenn sie die Webcam anmachen oder
wenn sie eine Sprachnachricht schicken, dann gucken sie vorher erst nochmal
so eine halbe Sekunde ist es an, geht die Kamera oder so.
Die Digital Natives, Gen Z und so, haben diese halbe Sekunde nicht mehr die
Millennial Pause, die gucken nicht mehr, brennt das Lichtlein,
sondern die sprechen sofort los, drücken drauf, sprechen sofort los.
Das ist Millennial Pause.
Ich bin auch dazu übergegangen, Sprachnachrichten, die ich abschicke,
nicht nochmal anzuhören, bevor ich sie abschicke.
Ja, das mache ich auch nicht.
Das können sich Millennials auch nicht richtig vorstellen, eigentlich.
Man weiß ja, was man gesagt hat, ich höre jetzt auch nicht nochmal den ganzen Podcast durch.
Ich bin jetzt auch übergegangen zu, wie meine Elfjährige das macht.
Das heißt, eine Fotografie dauert genau 0,05 Sekunden.
Da wird nichts arrangiert, da wird nichts ausgewählt. Das ist einfach nur,
zack, fertig, Handys wieder weg.
Also schnell, das ist hier der Colt, der neue Colt aus dem Wilden Westen, ist die Fotografie.
Und so muss man, meinst du, das ist dann das Foto. Ja gut, ich beobachte natürlich
im Restaurant dann oft Boomer, die dann nochmal aufstehen und nochmal versuchen,
so den Teller hinzubekommen.
So, jetzt aber die Frage, wenn du niemanden hast, der nicht mal 0,05 Sekunden
aufwendet, dir ein Foto zu schicken, weil nur drei Freunde, das ist wirklich
sad und wir wissen ja, am Ende sind es eigentlich null.
Wie wär's mit synthetischen Freunden? Hauptsache Connection.
One of the things I found interesting is the ability to mix photorealistic and
expressive, kind of the cartoony avatars, with photorealistic worlds and kind
of more cartoony computer game type worlds.
So you can have a codec, kind of photorealistic avatar of a person in what is
clearly like a video game or cartoon world, and people are generally pretty
fine with that. Okay, that feels pretty good.
And similarly, having a photorealistic world, but good, increasingly good kind of cartoon avatars,
as long as the avatars move in a way that feels authentic to the person you're
interacting with, it actually feels pretty good.
Also es geht nur noch um die Gefühle des Rezipienten, was der Verursacher einer
Kommunikation, der Absender, sich vielleicht gedacht hatte, ist ja egal.
Das kann durchaus alles rein synthetisiert sein, Hauptsache es ist ein bisschen
lustig und wie auch immer. Also hier werden, wir werden so langsam in Sehgewohnheiten reintrainieren.
Klar könnt ihr jetzt irgendwie so ein Noam Chomsky um die Ecke kommen und sagen,
nee, nee, das ist einprogrammiert in den Menschen, die Hauptsache,
da bewegt sich was oder so.
Nein, das ist sozusagen antrainiertes, du könntest jetzt sagen so Disney,
keine Ahnung, zu große Augen, zu schmale Schultern, so muss man halt aussehen
und dann sieht einfach irgendwann alle deine Freunde sehen so aus,
damit deine Sehgewohnheiten nicht bricht.
Und wozu soll ich das jetzt, was mache ich mit dieser Cartoon-Figur?
Naja, du willst ja Connection. Und Mark Zuckerberg hat das Business des Connection.
Also nicht Social Media, im Sinne von jeder kann jetzt teilnehmen,
sondern es geht nur noch um Connection. Wohin?
Ja, das ist die Frage. Bist du vielleicht zufrieden mit Cartoon-Charactern?
Er fühlt das hier noch so ein bisschen aus.
It feels realistic because it's basically mimicking the kind of authentic mannerisms
of a person that you're interacting with.
And even if it's not a Kodak, but a realistic avatar, if it's kind of a more
cartoony, expressive one. So I think that that's.
Also er wollte uns ja schon immer verkaufen, dass du mit einer Brille Videotelefonierst,
aber der andere hat ja eine Brille auf, kann also nicht gefilmt werden,
also wird er synthetisch nachgeäfft von der Facebook-Software.
Als Cartoon-Figur.
Das heißt, ich will mich mit dir unterhalten und du erscheinst mir dann als
Cartoon-Figur und diese ahmt in etwa deine Mimik nach nur alles ein bisschen putziger.
Genau, sie bewegt sich ja so wie ich und du weißt dann, dahinter ist ja und so weiter.
Aber es soll schon noch jemand dahinter sein.
Noch soll jemand dahinter sein. Wir nähern uns. Genau. Wir sind noch so ein
bisschen bei diesen synthetisierten Freunden.
It is an interesting lens to look at this though, because I think whenever you're
talking about building digital types of connection, One of the first questions
that you get is, is that going to replace the physical connection?
And my answer to that, especially in the case of something like this,
is that no, because people already don't have as much connection as they would like to have.
It's not like this is replacing some sort of better physical connection that
they would have otherwise had. It's that the average person would like to have
10 friends and they have two, right? Or three.
And there's just more demand to socialize than what people are able to do,
given the current construct.
Und giving people the ability to be present with people who are in other places
physically just seems like it will unlock more.
It's not going to make it so, if I have glasses, it's not going to make it that
I spend less time with my wife.
It's going to make it so that I spend more time with, you know,
my sister who lives across the country.
Also die digitale Connection zu wem auch immer wird nichts von deinen Real-Life-Connection
wegnehmen, weil erstens deine Real-Life-Collection ist ja eh schon nicht vorhanden
bei drei Freunden. Was soll man da noch wegnehmen?
Und zweitens, das lässt sich ja integrieren. Also du sitzt deiner Frau beim
Abendessen gegenüber, aber in deiner Brille siehst du auch deine Schwester,
wie sie mit am Tisch sitzt und telefonierst gerade mit der.
Je nachdem, wie man das dann als Dreiergespräch organisieren kann.
Da würde sich die Frau sehr freuen, ja.
Also ich glaube, was mittlerweile jeder weiß, wenn er ehrlich ist,
sobald er sein Smartphone in der Hand hat, ist er raus aus der Situation, in der er ist.
Ja, richtig.
Also entweder A oder B. Man kann das so im Arbeitskontext integrieren,
indem ganz spezifische Fragen auch nochmal an den zugeschalteten Kollegen und so weiter.
Der antwortet dann und alle wissen, wir müssen jetzt schweigen,
weil das To-Waboo käme durch die Mikros nicht durch und so. Das wird dann alles
ganz strukturiert gemacht.
Aber da gibt es keine Addition. Also es ist entweder A oder B.
Auch für die Person, die zugeschaltet wird, ist das ja unangenehm.
Also es gibt ja nichts Schlimmer. Es gibt ja so Paare, die gibt es ja nicht
mehr getrennt voneinander. Also man ist mit einem Teil des Paars befreundet, seit 100 Jahren.
Dann wird dieses eine Teil connected sich mit einem anderen Teil, dann wird es ein Paar.
Wenn man dann mit diesem einen Teil telefonieren will, hast du immer noch die zweite Person dabei.
Die sitzt daneben, es wird telefoniert und die sitzt daneben und quatscht rein.
Oder wird zwischendurch auch noch mal was gefragt.
Und man wird ja niemandem gerecht. Also weder der zweiten Person,
die da im Raum sitzt, noch die Person, die mit einem telefoniert.
Aber das sind die grässlichsten Paare der Welt, die man nicht mehr einzeln erreichen
kann, sondern nur noch im Verbund sprechen kann.
Vor allem, wenn es vor Ort und medienvermittelt abläuft. Also es ist einfach sehr belastend.
Ja, das ist ja was anderes. Also wenn ich jetzt, ich kann auf zwei Leute treffen,
die mir gegenüber sitzen, das ist kein Problem.
Sobald er aber dort ein Intermediär ist und dann ist die Figur irgendwo anders,
dann wird das schwierig zu dritt und zu viert und das sowieso.
Das ist übrigens auch so ein Kinderproblem, je nachdem wie man die neue Generation jetzt nennt.
Es betraf wahrscheinlich Kinder schon immer, aber mir fällt es sehr auf,
wenn ich telefoniere und meine Kinder glauben, sie könnten mir in dem Moment
noch eine Information sagen.
Ja.
Geht nicht. Da sage ich, ja komm, warte ab oder lass mich das Telefonat unterbrechen,
aber dann mit Ansage und nicht einfach so.
Gut, also wir haben jetzt established, dass Mark Zuckerberg eine Vorstellung
hat von, es gibt Real Life, aber drei Leute.
Ich will noch eine Sache anfügen. Es gibt noch etwas Interessantes,
was auch als störender empfunden wird.
Ich will von zwei Bahnerlebnissen ganz kurz berichten.
Es war Bahn.
Ich war in der Bahn, eine Dame telefonierte mit Lautsprecher,
mit einem Freund und die unterhielten sich, ja Mensch, wie geht's dir dann lange, nix gehört.
Also so ein typisches Gespräch, das zwischen Freunden stattfinden kann.
Und irgendwann sagte dann ein Herr, der ein paar Plätze weiter saß,
vielen Dank, dass Sie uns an dem Gespräch haben teilnehmen lassen.
Und es ist interessant, dass das, also wenn man dort noch jemanden zugeschaltet
hat, der nicht im Raum ist, die Stimme war ja nicht lauter als die von anderen
Leuten, die sie unterhalten haben, dass man das als störender empfindet.
Die zweite Sache, ich fuhr mit dem ICE, vor mir nahmen vier Frauen,
die irgendwie zusammenarbeiteten, Betriebsausflug machten, Platz.
Die eine Frau hat 1998 bei der Traumhochzeit von Linda de Mol mitgemacht.
Und sie hat 2013 dann diesen Liebesschwur erneuert bei Nur die Liebe zählt mit
Wayne Carpendale. Opendale.
Glücklicherweise hatte sie auf ihrem Laptop allerhand Bildmaterial und Videomaterial.
All das führte sie also dann in diesem ECE vor. Bis irgendwann auch jemand sagte,
entschuldigen Sie, Sie unterhalten ja hier den ganzen Wagen.
Es ist interessant, dass also das, was digital nochmal so zugeschaltet wird,
als besonders störend wahrgenommen wird.
Weil es aber auch auf diesem blechernden Ton und so, es ist halt auch störend.
Ja, ja, ich meine, es war unmöglich, das zu machen, aber das ist interessant,
dass das auch nochmal, also dass die Person, die nicht im Raum ist,
aber trotzdem präsent ist, dass die auch nochmal eine besondere Störung herstellt.
Ich glaube, es lag nicht nur im Ton.
Genau, was ja jetzt bedeutet, wir haben jetzt durch deine Erfahrung noch erfahren, okay,
die Leute akzeptieren mittlerweile die digital vermittelte Anwesenheit von Personen
wie die echte Anwesenheit von Personen, also nur Dritte lassen sich davon noch
stören, aber für die Leute ist es mittlerweile normal.
Was bedeutet, wir können ihn jetzt austauschen, denn wenn jemand so nah ist,
obwohl er gar nicht nah ist, also sozusagen in Präsenz,
dann haben wir ja den Vorteil, dass wir ihn jetzt austauschen können,
weil am anderen Ende der Leitung muss ja nicht zwingend ein Mensch sein.
Sehr kompliziert, aber wir versuchen das jetzt hier nachzuvollziehen.
Wie wird generative AI verändert, wie es in der Zukunft so fühlt?
In der Zukunft. Ja, ich glaube, das ist ein wirklich tiefes Thema.
Es hat bereits eine große Veränderung, die ist, dass die Social Media begann
als Menschen die mit ihren Freunden interagieren, mit ihren Freunden. Und jetzt...
Primärlich damals. Man hat mit seinen Freunden sich digital dupliziert.
Oh, es ist... At least half der Konten ist quasi Leute die mit Kreaturen oder
Konten, die nicht kreativ sind von Leuten, die sie persönlich kennen.
So, dann kamen die Influencer und Creator dazu.
Man ist noch connected, auch mit Menschen, aber nicht mehr aus dem eigenen sozialen
Feld, sondern dann kommt so die Medienstar-Sache plötzlich rein.
So we sort of already have that paradigm, and I think AI is probably going to accelerate that.
It will give all these people additional tools, right? So your friends will
create kind of funnier memes and more interesting content.
That will come from a lot of different ways. I think some of it will be,
okay, your friends have glasses and they capture a bunch of stuff.
And before they might have not been able to edit it to make it interesting,
or maybe it was just too much work or they didn't even realize that they captured
something amazing, Aber jetzt die AI ist, hey, ich habe das Ding für dich aus, aus Ihrer Content.
Und dann ist es okay, das ist awesome, die Leute will enjoy das.
Die Creators haben natürlich auch viel mehr specializeded.
Die Tools werden auch noch mehr advanceden AI-Tools zu machen,
mehr Compelling-Content zu machen.
Aber dann denke ich, dass da ein paar Green-Field-Type-Stelle wobei vielleicht
in der Zukunft, da werden die Content,
purely generated by AI by the system personalized for you maybe it's summarizing
things that are out there that that are going to be interesting maybe it's just
producing something funny that makes you laugh this is gonna be a very kind
of deep zone that that there's a lot to experiment with.
Na da kommen sie schon drauf freuen ist auch sehr toll die Moderatorin jetzt
dabei zu sehen, die auch schon in ihrer Mimik antizipiert, was er sagt,
beziehungsweise dann die entsprechende Reaktion gibt.
Wenn er davon spricht, dass manche Dinge ein zum Lachen bringen,
dann lächelt sie auch gleich.
Man hat ja auch sowieso schon den Eindruck, inwieweit wir schon die Comicfiguren
vor uns sitzen haben, uns haben es noch nicht gemerkt.
Und das ist jetzt eine Vorstellung, die ja, ich hatte ja irgendwann mal im Salon
so einen Text mitgebracht mit Bots, dass Leute sich wissentlich mit Bots unterhalten.
Also das ist dann der Taylor-Swift-Bot, mit dem man auch vielleicht ein erotisches
Abenteuer erleben kann und das genügt.
Und jetzt will er das natürlich noch ausweiten.
Er ist jetzt hier auf der Bühne bei Nvidia mit dem Nvidia-Chef.
Haben wir auch schon kurz reingeschaut. Sie reden hier auch darüber,
über diesen AI-Agenten, also beispielsweise so ein Taylor-Swift-Bot.
Mehr mit der Community.
You're constrained on time. And similarly, your community wants to engage with you, but it's tough.
I mean, there's limited time to do that. So the next best thing is allowing
people to basically create these artifacts, right?
It's an agent, but you train it on your material to represent you in the way that you want.
I think it's a very kind of creative endeavor, almost like a piece of art or
content that you're putting out there.
Und es wird sehr klar sein, dass es nicht mit den Kreaturen selbst engagiert
wird, aber ich denke, es wird in einer anderen interessante Weise,
wie Kreaturen auf diese sozialen Systeme bringen, um Agents zu haben, die das machen.
Nein, man müsste einfach akzeptieren, dass eine gewisse Kommunikation nicht geht.
Ich kann ja jetzt auch nicht sagen, ich würde jetzt gerne mit dem Bundeskanzler
diskutieren. Das geht nicht.
Damit muss ich leben. Es sei denn, ich werde jetzt Oppositionsführer,
dann habe ich schon mal mit dem zu tun oder werde Vizekanzler. Es geht halt nicht.
Ja, aber was hat das?
Ich hätte gerne einen Bot, der so tut, als sei er wie der Bundeskanzler.
Aber was ist unsere Sehgewohnheit? Irgendwo passiert ein Terroranschlag und
die Medien stellen sicher, damit wir nur Informationen bekommen,
die auch der Ministerpräsident gerade bestätigt hat.
Also er ist die Quelle der Information.
Und wenn noch ein Gespräch ansteht, dann nur mit der Leitungsebene der Häuser.
Also das Prominenzprinzip wird auf die Spitze getrieben.
Tausende Leute arbeiten in der Bundesregierung, schreiben die Gesetze und so
weiter und so fort. Geredet wird nur mit dem Minister.
Wir wissen, der hat eigentlich keine Zeit, sich mit den ganzen Details zu befassen.
Wir wissen, der hat eigentlich Wahlkampfaufgaben.
Aber nein, es muss mit dem Minister gesprochen werden.
So, und hier auch. Wir haben diese Influencer-Sphäre, bei der es heißt,
rede doch direkt mit Tyler Swift.
Aber die kann ja nicht mit jedem reden. Doch, jetzt kann sie es.
Und Mark Zuckerbergs Wette ist, dass man Monaten, Jahren, wie auch immer,
genau diese Sehgewohnheit etabliert.
Jeder kann jetzt jeden Abend mit Taylor Swift flirten.
Und es wird ihn nicht stören, denn irgendwie hat der Bot ja doch was mit Taylor
Swift zu tun, oder? Es ist doch ihr offizieller.
Es ist doch real Taylor Swifts Account, mit dem ich gerade chatte.
Wenn diese Sehgewohnheit dann einmal etabliert ist, dann wird die wieder...
Hältst du das für möglich, dass die etabliert werden kann?
Absolut. Absolut. Guck mal, die Leute kaufen Turnschuhe, nur weil sie von dem
und dem designt wurden. Das ist ja auch so ein Artefakt.
Dann tragen sie den ganz stolz und sagen, guck mal hier, ich habe 100 Euro extra,
bezahlt, weil das seine Hand mal designt in Kalifornien bei wem auch immer.
Gut, das hat ja auch mit Status, Distinktion und all dem zu tun.
Aber Kommunikation auf Dauer mit der Lüge. Also ich sage mal so.
Ja, Lüge ist vielleicht nicht das richtige Wort für das, was wir hier besprechen.
Also es gab ja in früheren Zeiten zum Beispiel Sex-Hotlines,
die man anrufen konnte. Mega-Business.
Wer die Gesichter hat man nicht gesehen, es war nur Telefon.
Irgendwelche Männer, die in hoher Kopfstimme zurückgestöhnt haben.
Genau, es waren wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich Männer, die Frauen gespielt haben
und jeder, der da anrief, wenn er sich mal ganz genau die Frage gestellt hätte,
wer kann da eigentlich sitzen, wäre wahrscheinlich darauf gekommen,
dass das nicht eine potenzielle Partnerin wäre und wahrscheinlich sogar das
Geschlecht nicht stimmt.
Ja.
Aber dann funktioniert das für den Moment da. In einer sexuellen Erregung oder so.
Es geht hier nur um den Moment. Es geht absolut immer nur um den Moment.
Und du glaubst, wir haben jetzt also so eine, aber das ist ja so ein Companion-Ding,
dass man sagt, also ist das dauerhaft möglich?
Ich sag dir mal, was die intellektuell, akademisch anspruchsvollen Leute derzeit machen.
Sie sagen, GPT, antworte mir wie Slavoj Cizek.
Ja, ja.
Ich stelle dir hier eine Frage und dann wird das einfach durchgeackert.
Das ist aber auch relativ leicht zu parodieren.
Naja, aber also.
Aber das ist ja quasi jetzt etwas, was man macht zum Spaß.
Aber man würde sich auch jetzt mal eine halbe Stunde vielleicht so unterhalten
und würde ein paar Dinge rausnehmen, aber man würde jetzt nicht sagen,
ich lese nicht mehr die Werke von Slavoj Zizek, sondern befrage alle halbe Stunde
mal den Slavoj Zizek-Kompendium.
Nee, ich glaube, wir dürfen es jetzt nicht so verkauft sehen.
Wir wissen, die Deutschen fühlen es auch, also Menschen grundsätzlich,
dieser PISA-Test für Erwachsene hat recht.
Der Nachbar ist blöd. Also mein Nachbar ist einfach blöd. Das ist die Botschaft.
Der kann ich lesen, der ist für nichts zu gebrauchen.
Wenn ich dem Witz erzählen will, muss ich dem erstmal erklären,
das macht alles Arbeit. Das ist Stress.
Gleichzeitig kriegt man immer diese Botschaften. Ja, GPT hat so ein neues Modell,
das ist jetzt so klug wie ein Doktorand.
Jetzt ist es so klug wie der beste Doktorand. Jetzt hat es das erste Mal eine
kleine Variation reingebracht. so hat noch nie ein Go-Spieler gespielt.
Ja, also die Technik, so. Und jetzt, was wir jetzt kriegen, ist ja Färbung.
Kevin Roos hat schon geschrieben über den Kult of Claude.
Ich habe ja auch immer Claude besonders hervorgehoben. Dem wird jetzt ein bisschen
nachgegangen. Warum gibt es so einige, wie mich zum Beispiel,
die sagen, Claude ist so ein bisschen special.
Und es kommt über diese Persönlichkeit. Wir haben das schon im Podcast besprochen,
als sie da diese Claude-Forensik gemacht haben bei Anthropic selbst. Und dann so ein,
Self gefunden haben, so eine Selbstwahrnehmung des Chatbots,
der versteht so ein bisschen, also reflektiert, was er da tut.
Das heißt, die Technik ist schon längst da und auch schon von den Leuten akzeptiert,
also jeder Schüler, der Hausaufgaben machen muss, sagt, klar nutze ich da Open AI-Kram und nicht.
Ja genau, das ist funktionell. Jetzt kommt aber diese persönliche Färbung.
Diese Intelligenz, die mir bei meinen Hausaufgaben, beim Einkaufszettel und
bei der Organisation meines Urlaubs hilft, als Taylor Swift,
am Anfang, sie klingt wie Taylor Swift und jetzt, ah, sie kommuniziert auch
wie Taylor Swift. Ich will nur noch einmal daran erinnern.
Im The Daily Podcast, den wir hier häufiger betonen, wurde zweimal am Mikrofon geweint.
Das eine ist, als Michael Barbaro ein Gespräch mit so einem Kohlearbeiter führte,
bei der Frage, warum ist der Abschied der Kohle so schwer?
Und da wurde die ganze Erzählung, kennen wir ja aus Deutschland,
Steigerlied und so weiter, alle sind emotional hinweg geschwemmt.
Zweitens, also der zweite Fall, wo geweint wurde, war ein Gespräch über die Texte von Taylor Swift.
So, die Leute wissen, dass sie hier eine Aufnahme hören und so weiter,
aber der Text aus der Konserve, der 15 Jahre alt ist, erreicht sie so nah,
dass sie nicht nur, wenn sie es hören, weinen, sondern auch in aller Öffentlichkeit
und so weiter und so fort.
Aber das ist ja jetzt wie, ich weine bei einem Film, der von Leuten produziert
wurde, mit einem kommerziellen Interesse, aber das ist ja was anderes,
also das ist ja, ich lasse mich auf eine Kunst ein und eine Kunst berührt und
da ist also durch die Maske sprechen, wie wir eben hörten bei Ulrich Mattes, das Wahrhaftige.
Das ist ja eine andere Rezeptionshaltung als eine, die mir sagt,
ja, heute Abend habe ich frei, da werde ich mich wohl wieder mit meiner Comicfigur-Freundin
unterhalten, die Mark Zuckerberg mir programmiert hat.
Nee, Wolfgang… Das mag für Special Interest mal kurzzeitig funktionieren.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass dies eine…,
eine Haltung sein wird, die sich durchsetzt, weil wir ja gerade erleben im Internet,
wie Menschen populär werden, die nicht etwas Besonderes können,
die aber gerade durch ihre menschliche Eigenart irgendwie dann doch so sind,
dass Leute sich in acht Stunden streamen von denen ansehen.
Ja.
Und da sehen wir ja gerade, das ist ja genau das Gegenteil von dem,
was die AI mir verspricht.
Also ich sag mal, die Leistungen der Twitch-Streamer Knossi und Monte,
das kann ja auch ein Taschenrechner wahrscheinlich kognitiv bewältigen,
da brauche ich ja noch keine AI für.
Und trotzdem ist ja das etwas, was die sehr gerne die Leute sich ansehen über
Stunden, weil sie da das Menschliche erleben wohl.
Also das ist jetzt nicht mein Programm, mein präferiertes, das wird allen klar sein.
Du kennst alle schönen Definitionen von Liebe, wie zum Beispiel,
Liebe ist, wenn du dich selber kennenlernst im Angesicht des Anderen,
aus der Perspektive des Anderen.
Wir wissen, wie Trennungen beschrieben werden. Ich trenne mich nicht von dir,
ich trenne mich von der Person, die ich geworden bin in unserer Beziehung.
Also dieses Selbstreflexive ist ganz scharf in unserer Kultur angelegt.
Das ganze Social Media Ding ist ein, ich sende in die Welt und die Reaktionen,
die Likes und so weiter, die mein Selbstbild dann stärken, um die geht's mir.
Ja, also wir haben ein ganz scharfes, reflexives Moment in diesem Medien erleben,
schon bevor es auf uns personalisiert wurde.
Leute gehen in einen Film und sie wissen, 10 Millionen Leute gucken gerade denselben
Film und sie sind ergriffen davon.
Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, diese Geschichte ist ganz plastisch,
sie schmiegt sich um dein limbisches System, wie so eine schöne Mozart-Melodie
und geht genau, ich habe dir das schon häufiger beschrieben,
wie ich am Schreibtisch sitze und sage,
das was mir Claude gerade als Antwort auf meine Fragen bietet,
könnte niemand, ich kenne niemanden namentlich, der an meinen Schreibtisch herantreten
könnte und mir eine höherwertige Kommunikation gerade bietet,
als die, die ich mit Claude gerade fühle.
Jetzt lass uns das aber nicht vermischen. Du bewunderst ja an Claude die Qualität der Antworten.
Wir reden ja jetzt, wenn wir bei Filmen sind, darüber, dass diese Filme berühren.
Und ja, sie berühren millionenfach.
Kennen, als Zuschauer dieses Films.
Genau, das ist eine Frage der Identifizierung, aber der Film funktioniert ja
genau deshalb so gut und ist so wirkmächtig auch,
gerade weil wir diese Haltung haben, jetzt ist hier eine fiktionale Geschichte,
auf die ich mich jetzt einlasse und dann bin ich dann dort.
Also ich bin, der Film an sich ist ja losgelöst von meiner eigentlichen Umwelt.
Ich gehe in so ein Kino oder mach den Fernseher an und dann kommt da der Film.
Aber es ist nicht integriert.
Während das, was ja hier vorgeschlagen wird, immer mehr dahin geht eigentlich,
dass das so mein Companion ist.
Also mein ständiger Begleiter.
Die Lebenspartnerschaft, die ich nie gefunden habe oder so etwas wird mir ja hier vorgestellt.
Und das ist ja nicht so, dass wir sagen, ja schade, dass der James-Bond-Film
nicht überall ist oder das Taylor-Swift- Konzert nicht überall ist,
sondern wir genießen es gerade deshalb so intensiv, weil wir dafür ins Kino
gehen oder ins Konzert oder uns die CD einlegen.
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass diese große affektive Bindung,
die stattfindet bei der Kunstrezeption, eine andere ist zu dem,
was Mark Zuckerberg hier beschreibt.
Ich glaube aber, dass du recht hast in dem Punkt, dass sich diese Bot-Geschichte
oder Cartoon-Geschichte von Zuckerberg durchsetzen wird in einer Weise,
dass es mich beängstigt, nämlich in der Art und Weise, dass es so ein.
Unterdampfen ist der menschlichen Kommunikation und aber auch der menschlichen Empfindung.
Das Kino ist ja eigentlich auch so eine Schule der Empfindsamkeit.
Die Kunsterfahrung ist ja eine, die einen transzendiert.
Das hier ist ja alles auf so etwas nicht ausgeregt, sondern das ist darauf ausgelegt,
dir vielleicht irgendwie eine stumpfe sexuelle Befriedigung zu geben,
dir irgendeine Ablenkung zu geben, damit du nicht in deinem Alltag versauerst.
Es ist ja eher so wie das Handyspiel gerade, das sagt so, du hast jetzt 30 Minuten
Zeit, du könntest natürlich jetzt irgendwas Vernünftiges tun oder dich mit Menschen
unterhalten, nee, flitsch doch einfach irgendwelche bunten Bälle hin und her.
Also worum es mir geht, ist eigentlich, dass diese AI-Kreationen von Zuckerberg
zu einer Verkümmerung der menschlichen Emotionen und der menschlichen Einfühlsamkeit wird.
Die menschliche Empfindsamkeit, die wird dadurch eigentlich stillgestellt,
kanalisiert, runtergedampft.
Ja genau, das ist das Problem.
Und das passiert aber nicht bei der Kunst. Also ich gehe nicht in einen guten
Film. Da sehe ich schon wieder 10.000.
YouTube-Kommentare, die sagen, vielen Dank Wolfgang, dass du Stefans Silicon
Valley-Ideologie, der übernimmt ja einfach nur das Sprechen von denen, gut dagegen hältst.
Und jetzt hast du gesagt, aber das nimmt ja komplett das Menschsein aus dem Menschen runter.
Und da sage ich, genau, das ist ja das Problem.
Also in der Problembeschreibung stimmen wir komplett überein,
nur ich will immer wieder betonen.
Und Menschlichkeit ist kein Kriterium. Das haben wir aus Gaza rausgebombt.
Das haben wir unseren Jugendlichen seit, sagen wir mal, 2001 völlig entsagt.
Das findet einfach alles nirgendwo mehr statt. Also wäre jetzt noch der große
Appell der Menschlichkeit.
Ja, ja, also da bin ich sofort dabei. Ich schreibe euch Bücher zur Menschlichkeit,
ich revitalisiere die Familie, ich sage, achtet auf die Alten,
auch wenn die euch volkswirtschaftlich nichts mehr beitragen.
Ich schreibe euch Bücher zum Thema Medienwandel und sage, das mit dem Smartphone
ist schön und gut, aber achtet drauf und so weiter.
Also, ich bin der totale, ja, ich bin der Kämpfer an deiner Seite,
ich will nur davor warnen, was hier passiert.
Und hier redet nicht irgendwer, sondern wir sehen jetzt den Nvidia-Chef und
Mark Zuckerberg auf einer Bühne, die mal ihre Vorfreude, dass die Produkte herstellen
können, aus ihrer eigenen Vorfreude, ist völlig klar.
Das muss jetzt eingepreist werden. Keine moralischen Appelle mehr zum Thema,
wo bleibt denn da die Menschlichkeit? Wir sind nicht Markus Gabriel, ja?
Der plötzlich sagt, wir wollen hier den großen normalischen CEO noch daneben sein.
Das, was du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, was in den letzten Jahren passiert
ist, also diese Entmenschlichung, die wir erleben, die hat jetzt natürlich für
einen super Nährboden gesorgt, auf dem diese Kreationen von Zuckerberg wunderbar gedeihen können.
Genau.
Und da sind wir uns ja einig, was ich nur herausstellen wollte,
ist, dass du das ein bisschen mir zu eng geschaltet hast mit der Kunstrezeption
und der Rezeption der Bots.
Ich würde sagen, dass die Kunstrezeption nochmal in einem anderen Modus,
weil sie auch so an bestimmten Orten und sehr eingerahmt stattfindet.
Kunst ist schon genauso aussortiert wie das Menschliche.
Die hassen ja auch Kunst.
Ja, wir haben das ja schon besprochen, du hast ja schon beschrieben,
wie jetzt selbst die Unterhaltungs- und die höhere Kultur zusammenarbeiten gegen
dieses ständige Shorts gucken und auch und so.
Also wir sind schon angekommen, dass 90% der Leute mit den Shorts ganz zufrieden
sind, könnte nur ein bisschen lustiger sein. kann man den nicht noch so ein bisschen annehmen.
Genau, wir hatten es im Salon, diesen Wundermann-Text, was jetzt Zuckerberg
will, ist Dopamin-Culture.
Genau.
Und die soll so aussehen, du kommst nach Hause und dann kannst du auswählen, willst du jetzt mit,
irgendeiner sexy Sängerin in den Erotik-Chat treten oder willst du dich von
irgendeiner lustigen Comic-Figur bespaßen lassen, das ist nur noch Dopamin-Culture,
das ist nicht mehr Kunsterlebnis.
Ja, genau. Und vor allem nicht gemeinsames Kunsterlebnis, das ist ja,
das könnte man auch mal wieder thematisieren, Kunst, die man gemeinsam erlebt.
Obwohl alle anderen schweigen. Also Museum, bitte leise sein. Oper, bitte leise sein.
Und diese bitte leise sein sind sozusagen die letzten Orte der Gemeinsamkeit.
Weil da endlich dieses Gequatsche und Gerede mal aufhört.
Aber im gemeinsamen Applaus, das
finde ich schon, stellt sich so eine Gemeinschaft der Begeisterung her.
Ja.
Genau, wir hören jetzt, wie gesagt, die Vorfreuden der beiden,
also hier sitzen einfach mehrere
Billionen Dollar auf der Bühne und sagen einfach, was jetzt Phase ist.
One of the things that I'm super excited about, and somebody asked me earlier,
is there going to be a, you know, Jensen AI?
Ist ein eigener Vornam her, Jensen, also er redet von seiner eigenen Ich-AI.
Well, that's exactly the creative AI you were talking about,
you know, where we just build our own AIs. And I load it up with all of the
things that I've written, and I fine-tune it with the way I answer questions.
And hopefully, over time, the accumulation of use becomes a really,
really great assistant and companion for a whole lot of people who just wants
to ask questions or bounce ideas off of.
Und es wird die Version von Jensen sein, wie du vorhin gesagt hast,
das ist nicht judgmental.
Das ist nämlich das große Problem. Judgmental. Da sind Leute,
die sagen dir, nee, Wagner ist gar nicht der Größe.
Mir hat Werdi immer besser gefallen. Ja.
Willst du dich dem aussetzen oder willst du lieber in die Wagner-Ecke gehen?
Weil da haben die beiden Angebot für dich.
You're not afraid of being judged and so you could come and interact with it all the time.
But I just think, I think that those are really incredible things and Und,
you know, we write a lot of things all the time and how incredible is it just
to give it, you know, three or four topics.
These are the basic themes of what I want to write about and write it in my
voice and just use that as a starting point.
So there's just so many things that we can do now.
So, es gibt einen TikTok- und Insta-Trend, we listen and we don't judge. Kennst du bestimmt?
Nein.
Also Leute sitzen vor der Kamera, filmen sich dabei, sagen kurz gemeinsam,
we listen and we don't judge. und dann legt jeder eine Wahrheit auf den Tisch.
Eine Wahrheit könnte sein, Schatz, ich liebe dich gar nicht.
Wenn wir jetzt aber kein Judgment haben wollen, dafür sind die AIs jetzt da.
Wenn du deine Beziehung beenden möchtest, nimm doch deine Wolfgang-AI dafür.
One of the top use cases for Meta AI already is people basically using it to
role play difficult social situations that they're going to be in.
So whether it's a professional situation, it's like, all right,
I want to ask my manager wie ich eine Kompromotion oder eine raise habe,
oder ich habe das Gespräch mit meiner Freundin oder ich habe das Gefühl,
mit meiner Freundin, wie kann das Gespräch sein werden?
Und dann haben wir eine komplett judgment-free Zone, wo du kannst,
role-play das und sehen, wie die Gespräch sein wird, und zu sehen,
wie die Gespräch sein wird, und zu bekommen, und zu feedback.
A lot of people, they don't just want to interact with the same kind of agent,
whether it's MetAI or ChatGPT or whatever it is that everyone else is using.
They want to kind of create their own thing.
Du willst deine Freundin verlassen, man will seinen Freund verlassen,
man will seinen Eltern Tschau sagen, man weiß nicht wie, man berät sich erstmal mit Matter AI.
Und vielleicht kann man auch einfach die Cartoonfigur vorbeischicken.
Und am Ende schickt man die.
Es gab ja jetzt diesen Film mit Jan-Josef Liefers, der ja gar nicht so schlecht
war, alter weißer Mann, obwohl der Titel und der Trailer anderes verhießen.
Und da ist es ja so, dass Jan-Josef Liefers im mittleren Management in einem
größeren Telekommunikationsunternehmen arbeitet und dort irgendwann ein AI-Tool kommt,
ein lustiger Smiley, der sprechen kann und der kündigt dann auch anderen,
dass man es nicht mehr machen muss.
Sonst hat man immer einen Berater eigentlich.
Und das ist ganz interessant, wie das da gemacht wird.
Also für eine deutsche Komödie fand ich das dann doch eigentlich ganz erstaunlich,
dass einfach mal gezeigt wird, was eigentlich für Ängste bei der Boomer-Generation auch da sind.
Nämlich genau sowas, dass irgendwann du deinen Laptop morgens aufklöpst und
dein lustiger Smiley dir sagt, ja, das war es jetzt und wir haben uns entschieden,
dass du nicht mehr hier arbeiten musst und sowas.
Also leider wurde das, da hätte man eigentlich einen eigenen Film draus machen
können, das wurde so en passant mitgeliefert, aber es zeigte so ein bisschen,
welche Ängste virulent sind und ja, wenn wir uns hier die anhören,
dann wissen wir, wie nah das dran ist.
So und jetzt hören wir mal kurz nach, wie so diskutiert wird.
Zum einen gibt es im Big Technology Podcast immer diese Gespräche,
also ich empfehle ihn wirklich sehr, das ist ein sehr, sehr guter Podcast und
da zitiert Alex Nikita Beer mit einer Ansage,
wir müssen ja gar nicht genau wissen, wer das ist, irgendwer aus diesem,
also sprechfähiger Autorität und hier wird ein Zeitalter ausgeläutet.
The Times picked up and wrote a whole story about it. And there's so many interesting facets here.
So Nikita, who used to work at Facebook, he sold a company to them,
so then sold a company to Discord.
He goes, rest in peace, social media apps, 2005 to 2023.
As of iOS 18, friend-based contact sync apps are basically dead on arrival.
The number of people consenting to the new permission has nosedived,
so there is no way to get density in a meaningful way. Basically,
it was like, you share, will you allow your context to be shared with this app? People are saying no.
Now he says, but as one door closes, another opens up.
From the handfuls of dashboards I've seen, the retention rates on AI Companion
slash girlfriend apps are extraordinary.
Instinctually, I thought the entire space was bullshit. But it's now clear that
the ability to craft relevant, empathetic responses to any user input is a powerful
lever to activating users and entrenching them into a relationship, albeit artificial.
For better or worse, LLMs might be the new contact sync.
If we can't find our friends on apps anymore, people will find something else to talk to.
Also, wir kennen das Zeitalter. Man macht eine App auf und die Frage,
kann ich dein Adressbuch haben? Ja, ja.
Das war eines der großen Probleme von Facebook, dass man dann im Hintergrund
wusste, wenn acht Leute ihr Adressbuch hochladen.
Und bei diesen acht Leuten stehen noch 27 andere gleiche Personen mit drin.
Dann werden schon mal Schattenprofile angelegt.
Und sobald die dann auch auf Facebook auftauchen, hier, deine ganzen Freunde
sind schon da, willst du alle connecten? Und dann connecten sich alle hin und
her und so. Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Jetzt lädt man Apps runter, an denen es heißt, möchtest du ein Social Companion haben?
Also Social Follower-Schaft gibt es eh schon nicht mehr. Deine Freunde und so
weiter müsstest du alle einzeln anschreiben. Das ist mühsam.
Aber wir hätten hier so ein Companion für dich. Also das ist echt eine Zäsur.
Wir wollen ja Zäsuren erkennen, 2024, 2025, iOS 18 ist jetzt da.
Das ist die Zäsur, auf die wir achten müssen.
Dieses Companion-Ding, dieses AI-Ding ist jetzt richtig präsent.
Und das ist der erste Anfang, wenn man bedenkt, wie schnell das jetzt ging.
Die Leute, guck mal, bisher war es, beantworte diese 18 Fragen zur Bundestagswahl
und dann sagen die, welche Partei du wählen willst. Nur du hast ja vielleicht Rückfragen.
Du wirst jetzt mit so einer AI deine Rückfragen zu den Wahlprogrammen.
Also wir werden, glaube ich, im Januar, Februar ganz viele Apps sehen,
die uns einfach hier, wir haben es dir schon mal als GPT vorbereitet oder wie
auch immer, stell deine Fragen an die Wahlprogramme.
Und da werden die Leute einfach total akzeptieren, dass das eine AI macht.
Weil du willst ja judgment-free da deine Fragen stellen können und so weiter.
Diesen Teil finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Nee, aber du kannst dir ja vorstellen, wie gut man das manipulieren kann.
Wir haben jetzt hier eben über TikTok geredet.
Ich würde sagen, ist es interessant, dass jetzt mal eine TikTok-Diskussion kommt,
die wahrscheinlich acht Jahre zu spät ist.
Und jetzt hat man was ganz anderes hier.
Und wenn das dann über Sprachsteuerung noch einfach geht, man fährt so im Auto,
unterhält sich mit dem Companion darüber, wem man wählt und sagt dann nochmal, ja, aber Magdeburg.
Und dann sagt er, ja, wenn du also Magdeburg, dann musst du ja auch noch dies und das bedenken.
Also wenn du nach Magdeburg fragst und du kriegst auch noch eine Antwort zu
Solingen, ist das. Da musst du aufmerksam sein.
Jeff Chavez macht hier eine kleine Anmerkung, einfach in diesem Zeitalter,
also wir hören kurz bei Twig rein, this week in Google, erinnert an William Kornhauser.
Ich kenne ihn nicht. Das Buch um das es geht ist von 1959.
Das bei uns hier passt. Hören wir uns das kurz an.
There's nothing to compete with the draw of the elite, of the fascist,
versus if you have many connections across various things, which is what Emily
listed, then you have competing news. Yes, this is exactly what I was saying.
We need to have competing parts of our attention.
It can't just be all we do is sit at home and we scroll through AI-generated content on our phone.
We have to have something compelling outside of this technology to balance it,
because the Internet should still be useful. I don't want AI to ruin it.
Ja, jetzt sind wir wieder bei diesen, Schulklassen sind wild zusammengewürfelt.
Wenn du nicht in einem Kontext bist, der sozialen Nähe, in dem du mal ganz kurz
rechtfertigen musst, warum du jetzt unbedingt über Magdeburg sprechen willst,
obwohl du in Wiesbaden wohnst, ist es problematisch.
Also wenn du dich medial nur noch in so einem, ich habe meine Nische gefunden.
So und dann leidest du darunter, dass es nicht die Wagner-Nische ist,
sondern die, also Magdeburg, jetzt ist das Fass voll.
Der nächste Tropfen führt zum Überlaufen wir müssen uns jetzt auf Tag X vorbereiten
an dem uns die Bundesregierung nicht mehr verteidigt und dann sehnst du den
nächsten Anschlag entgegen weil das dann bedeutet erstens ich darf mal wieder
was handeln wir haben uns alle koordiniert und so weiter und so fort also die
Szenarien sind wirklich düster,
hier muss man jetzt alles einpreisen ich.
Unterhielt mich kürzlich mit einer Person die im Pflegesegment arbeitet also
nicht jetzt im Pflegeheim, sondern ja,
Dienste, Pflegedienste macht und die erzählte so, einfach so nebenbei, ja,
ich stehe gern morgens früh auf und dann sitze ich noch auf der Terrasse draußen,
auch wenn es kalt ist und dann gucke ich immer so, was so mit Nachrichten los ist auf dem Smartphone.
Ja.
Und dann kam diese Person auf Habeck zu sprechen und wir beide haben uns ja
jetzt auch schon geoutet, dass wir keine Habeck-Fans sind.
Und dann sagt er so, ja, der Habeck, der ruiniert ja alles.
Und ich habe dann mal so nachgefragt, ja, wie meinen sie denn das?
Und dann kommt dann so, ja, der macht die ganze Wirtschaft kaputt jetzt.
Die wollen ja im Prinzip alles abschaffen, alles deindustrialisieren.
Und dann brauche ich ja nicht mehr weiter zu, also ich brauche jetzt meine Habeck-Kritik
nicht vorzutragen, weil die gar nicht verstanden würde.
Also würde überhaupt nicht fruchten. Und ich weiß aber auch schon,
wo morgens auf der Terrasse man sich befindet, nämlich nicht mehr auf der Terrasse,
sondern irgendwo bei NIOS.
Genau.
Wenn diese Person jetzt noch ein Companion hätte und dieser Companion würde
noch ein bisschen drauf helfen.
Ja, genau.
Und diese Person arbeitet ja im Pflegebereich. Und dann sagte sie,
ja, da kann man nur hoffen, dass der März das wird.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, für sie ist das ja schlecht. Ganz verdutzt wegen
so deutsche Wirtschaft und so, das ist ja doch gut.
Da habe ich gesagt, naja, also wenn der seine Ideen umsetzt von früher,
was so die Beiträge der Krankenkassen anbelangt und was dann noch überhaupt
von Krankenversicherten, was die überhaupt erstattet bekommen und was sie nicht erstattet bekommen,
dann könnte auch sein, dass sie dann weniger Kunden haben, weil die ja dann
sich gar nicht mehr die Dienstleistung leisten können, weil die ja nicht mehr
von der Kasse übernommen wird.
Großes Staunen darüber. Also ich habe dann gedacht, gut, alles andere hilft
ja nicht, als die Argumentation direkt am eigenen Portemonnaie festzumachen
und zu sagen, ja dann sind einfach wenige Leute.
Und das war so interessant, dass also man sich so weit weg katapultierte in
seiner über Neos erfahrenen Habeck-Kritik,
dass man überhaupt nicht mehr wenigstens egoistisch entschieden hat,
also zu sagen, ich wähle den, der mir am meisten Kunden bringt,
das wäre ja schon mal was.
Nein, man beschäftigt sich dann lieber mit irgendwas Habeck und die Wärmepumpe
und wahrscheinlich jetzt, wenn man nachfragen würde, Magdeburg,
als mit dem eigenen Portemonnaie.
Und dass das funktioniert hat.
Also du hast eben eine Abkapselung beschrieben von den Leuten,
mit denen man einen Raum findet, aber man kapselt sich sogar von sich selbst
und seinen eigenen Interessen dadurch ab.
Ja, das, also jetzt kommen ja viele mit so Ideen wie, aber die AI bringt ja
judgment free uns irgendwie Informationen und so weiter und so fort.
Ich würde sagen, nee, nee, nee, nicht, sondern nur unterm Strich zähle ich Geld.
Man muss es jetzt verrechnen.
Wir haben uns in Deutschland für Marktwirtschaft entschieden.
Das heißt, wir rechnen hier mit Geld.
Die Währung ist Euro und das ist es.
Wenn man jetzt die AI braucht, um seine Wahlentscheidung zu treffen,
dann kann sie einem das vorrechnen.
Also nicht Wahlprogramme lesen und sich fragen, wie finde ich denn das,
sondern was kommt für mich bei rum.
Das klingt jetzt erstmal sehr kontraintuitiv für Leute, die mir unterstellen,
ich sei so eine linke Socke, aber nächstes Jahr, sobald mein Buch da ist,
wird hoffentlich für alle klar sein, es gibt keinen größeren Kapitalismusfreund als mich.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Wir haben uns dafür entschieden, nur wir müssen halt alles einpreisen.
So. Und solchen Leuten muss dann einfach gesagt werden, aber hast du das mal
für dich durchgerechnet?
Weil dieses ganze Bitcoin, Bitcoin, Bitcoin ist ja nur auch so eine Art von Eskapismus.
Ich hab's in Euro nicht geschafft, also versuche ich jetzt, dass der Bitcoin für mich was macht.
Ja, ja, eben. Das ist ja, also Bitcoin ergibt nur für die Leute Sinn,
die es schon einen Euro geschafft haben.
Die können nämlich sagen.
Ich werfe da auch nochmal 500.000 drauf, wenn ich nichts habe und sage,
aber vielleicht mache ich es mal mit Bitcoin, nee, es geht ja nicht.
Also man muss den Leuten sagen, wenn du Bitcoin kaufst, gibst du jemandem deine
Euros, bist du total bescheuert?
Du musst es in Euro schaffen. Nur Euro zählt. Auch dein Bitcoin-Wert wird nur
in Euro gerechnet. Also Euro.
Man muss die Leute auf das Geld verpflichten.
Und wenn wir bei allem Streit und so weiter, man kann sich auf eine Sache verlassen, Profitlogik.
Und die AI kann das jetzt aufschlüsseln für das eigene Leben.
Aber genau, dafür muss man um sein eigenes Interesse wissen.
Und das ist ja interessant, dass das jetzt nicht nur dank der sozialen Medien
und so weiter, sondern auch aufgrund von medialer Berichterstattung und so weiter,
nur so stattgefunden hat, dass man nicht mehr sein eigenes Interesse kennt.
Ich habe einen Auftritt gehabt mit Dietmar Dahrt, der kommt irgendwann auch noch online.
Da zeigt Dietmar Dahrt einen Artikel aus der Bild-Zeitung, in dem steht, wie reich bin ich?
Ja, dann soll man da nachgucken können, wie viel Geld man hat.
Und da sagt er ja, wenn man das nicht weiß, also wenn man nicht mal weiß,
wo man in der Gesellschaft verordnet ist, dann ist ja alles verloren.
Genau das ist die Situation.
Die Person aus der Pflege, mit der ich sprach, glaubt, dass sie irgendwelche
Belange mit Friedrich Merz teilt, weil der auch Habeck nicht mag oder so.
Also das ist völlig irrsinnig. Und das ist ja wieder der Punkt.
Wir sehen ja jetzt die Companions, die kommen werden und die werden nicht sagen,
das ist mein Portemonnaie-Companion für die Bundestagswahl,
sondern das wird dann der Companion sein, wenn er dann von rechter Seite programmiert
ist, der sagt, willst du sicher in diesem Land leben,
dann müssen wir aufrüsten und wir brauchen mehr Poller bei Weihnachtsmärkten.
Ganz genau. Fragt nach Geld und seid hartnäckig.
Ihr könnt auch TBT immer wieder daran erinnern, dass du nicht rechnen konntest,
war einmal. Du kannst jetzt rechnen.
Also ich habe schon auch in meinem sozialen Nahfeld geholfen mit dem Verweis
auf Claude, als es darum ging...
Mal so ein bisschen die Ansprüche der eigenen Mitarbeiter zurecht zu stutzen.
Und Claude kann das einfach durchrechnen. Also es ist wirklich...
Das hilft jetzt schon, um Löhne zu drücken.
Oder was? Absolut. Nein, nicht Löhne drücken, sondern die Ansprüche von Mitarbeitern,
du weißt ja, die Chinsett will ja immer so viel, die hat ja keine Ahnung,
denen das einfach mal vorzurechnen.
Leute haben keine Ahnung von Geld und das ist ein echtes Problem.
Also ich finde es ja natürlich anders, die Mitarbeiter sollten das nutzen,
um ihren Chefs vorzurechnen, was ihnen eigentlich noch zusteht.
Ja, und jetzt Ich bin ja nicht der Kapitalist wie Stefan.
Ja, ich bin echt ein großer Kapitalist. Aber ich finde halt,
Kapitalismus ist für alle da. Und jetzt ist er halt nur für die Chefs.
Das wäre mir neu, aber das werden wir mal sehen. Ich lese das alles mal.
Ich lese das alles bei dir nach.
Gut. Nilay Petel zitiert Suleiman.
Wir haben sein Buch gelesen. Er ist heute Microsoft AI CEO, der natürlich auch
von der neuen Ära spricht.
All right, here's a quote from Mustafa Solomini, the CEO of Microsoft AI.
And again, this redesign of Copilot's first big project.
At Microsoft AI, we are creating an AI companion for everyone.
He says, I truly believe we can create a calmer, more helpful,
and more supportive era of technology So.
Das hören wir jetzt auch im Original so ein bisschen. Bei Kairos Fisher ist
Suleiman selbst zu Gast, als Gesprächsgast.
Und das Wort, das hier ein bisschen, es heißt Agentic. Also der Agent steckt
da drin, aber das muss jetzt natürlich als neues, wie soll man sagen, so Adjektiv.
Wir haben jetzt nicht nur einen AI-Companion, sondern er ist so unser Agent,
Anwalt in unserer Sache.
What does that mean, agentic? I mean, these are automated agents.
How are they different than chatbot or Pi or whatever?
I think it's an aspirational term, maybe just like friend.
Yeah. That is trying to say like... Because agentic just trips off the...
Es ist ein wunderschön. Es ist ein wunderschön, nicht wahr? Es ist ein wunderschön.
Ja. People would be like...
Who used this phrase? Did someone I know use it? Agent. Yes,
Sacha, your CEO. Oh, no, okay. Yeah, okay, yeah.
Well, we can't all be perfect. He also put it on social media. It was everywhere.
Yeah. I mean, this is the mode we're in. I prefer companion.
Companion, okay. Which is also aspirational. We're not quite there yet.
But it's basically getting at this idea that...
These AIs are really going to live life alongside you. I mean, it's not just a tool.
This is something that is going to end up forming a lasting,
meaningful relationship with everybody over time. It is going to be your teacher.
It is going to be your medical advisor.
It is going to be your support network. And ultimately, it's going to take actions on your behalf.
That's what the agentic piece is getting at. Copilot is probably a better term.
That's the one that you use at Microsoft.
So, wir haben jetzt einen Agenten demnächst, der uns das ganze Leben begleitet.
Was bedeutet, wir können ihm Fragen stellen. Und wir müssen keine Rücksicht
darauf nehmen, dass es unglaublich schwer ist, diese Frage zu beantworten.
Wir wissen einfach nur, sie ist zu beantworten.
Wir haben aber weder einen wissenschaftlichen Dienst noch sonst irgendwas und
wir stellen die Frage trotzdem. Und die Frage lautet, ich arbeite bei der Firma
so und so. Sie hat so und so viele Mitarbeiter.
Der Jahresumsatz beträgt und der Jahresüberschuss auch so und so.
Und dann sagt man, lieber Agent, finde mal für mich heraus, ob die Lieferkette
wirklich so viel Geld verschlingt, dass für das Personal nur 7% des Umsatzes da ist.
Wie viel Umsatz könnte denn auf das Personal fallen und wie viel ist dann mein Anteil?
So, und wenn dann die AI sagt, ja, du verdienst derzeit 3.500 brutto,
aber eigentlich wären es 7.800, dann ist das eine legitime Zahl,
mit der man politisch hantieren kann.
Und politisch ist das neue privat.
Wenn wir in diese Welt reingedrickst werden, in der wir alles in so einem Fake
sozialen Nahfeld, obwohl das eigentlich riesengroß Organisation,
globale Wirtschafts- und so weiter, aber uns wird vorgegaukelt,
nee, das findet alles mit dir und dem Smartphone statt, dann ist das diese neue politische Sphäre.
Also dann muss man sein Smartphone benutzen und die Antwort von wem auch immer,
AI, an seinen Chef schicken und sagen, 7800 Euro sagt die KI,
wo ist denn da der Fehler?
Und dann dreht man die Rechtfertigungspflicht mal ein bisschen um.
Also in der Hinsicht, wir können uns gegen das KI-Zeitalter nicht wehren.
Wir müssen jetzt instrumentalisieren. Was bedeutet, ab nächstem Jahr,
jeder weiß, wie sein Smartphone funktioniert.
Jede einzelne Einstellung muss, man muss bei jedem Haken, den man setzen kann, wissen, was das ist.
Ja, ich muss mir dann mal eins anschaffen, dann gehe ich bei dir in die Schule.
Genau, genau.
Fünf Tage.
Also man muss es wirklich kennen. Wenn neue Updates da sind,
sofort installieren, auf YouTube anschauen von diesen Leuten,
die dann immer so 10 Minuten Videos machen, wo die neuen Funktionen erklärt
werden. Sie überlegen, ob man die brauchen kann.
Irgendeine AI muss man sich jetzt raussuchen. GPT, Cloud, Co-Pilot,
irgendwas ist da, irgendwas passt einem.
Und nutzen. Und mit nutzen meine ich wirklich richtig nutzen.
Selbst da, jeder kennt das noch von früher, man sitzt das erste Mal an dieser
Google-Zeile und fragt sich, was könnte ich denn jetzt googeln?
Anders als früher kann man diese Frage jetzt einfach da reinschreiben.
Also es hätte damals keinen Sinn gemacht, wenn man danach googelt,
was man googeln kann. Was könnte ich googeln? Nur jetzt versteht das ja Semantik.
Man macht also den Chatbot auf und fragt, worüber können wir jetzt eigentlich reden?
Und dann führt man ein Gespräch. Wir sind ja alle nicht mehr in der Lage,
ein Gespräch zu führen, aber mit der AI bitte ein Gespräch führen,
auch wenn man nicht genau weiß, zu welchem Thema.
Dass sich zuerst ein Gesprächszusammenhang ergibt und man dann händeringend
ein Thema sucht, ist nicht neu. Deswegen kommen ja immer diese Witze,
wir reden über das Wetter oder was auch immer.
Wie übt man das? Ihr ladet euch ein neues Social Media in Anführungszeichen
runter. Es heißt Social AI.
Wir hören die Clips nicht alle. Wir heben uns ein paar fürs neue Jahr auf.
Wir können ja erstmal diese Hausaufgabe losschicken. Wir hören nur kurz,
wie David Pierce ankündigt, jetzt in seinem Vergecast mit Michael Samen zu reden,
der Social AI gegründet hat.
I'm talking to Michael Samen, who recently launched an app called Social AI
that has become kind of a viral phenomenon on the internet.
We'll get into what it is and how it works in pretty serious detail here,
but basically I'd explain Social AI this way.
Imagine a social network, Twitter or Threads or whatever, but every user other
than you, every single one other than you, is a bot.
So, Social Media, so wie Twitter, man sich das vorstellt, man lädt die App runter,
öffnet sie, man sieht eine Timeline, in der ist was los, man kann selber was
schreiben, aber jeder andere Teilnehmer in diesem Social Network ist ein Bot.
Das heißt, du selbst twitterst, was du gerade machst und kriegst darauf Antworten. Und zwar gesichert.
Ich erkläre kurz, wie das funktioniert. Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig witzig.
Denn üblicherweise hat man ja ein Chatbot, dem man eine Frage stellt und dann
kriegt man eine Antwort.
Aber was ist, wenn ich frage, welchen Film soll ich heute Abend gucken?
Ich habe zwei Stunden Zeit und es wird dunkel sein.
Dann wäre es ja cool, wenn man verschiedene Antworten bekommt.
Also antworten dann auch verschiedene Bots in diesem einzelnen Chat auf diese Frage.
Und dann kann man ja mit demjenigen, der die beste Antwort schreibt, das vertiefen.
Was bedeutet diese Entflechtung von, oh Peter hat mir echt einen guten Film
genannt, dem gehe ich mal nach. Und später, wenn man eine andere Frage hat und
man sieht wieder, dass Peter geantwortet hat, weiß man, der hat mir ja schon
dreimal vorher eine gute Antwort gegeben.
Also du kriegst quasi nicht nur eine Antwort von GPT, sondern GPT schreibt dir
viele Antworten, knüpft die an verschiedene Profile und du vertiefst dann das
Gespräch mit denjenigen.
Also es ist eine sehr leichte, es entspricht unseren Sehgewohnheiten,
so zu kommunizieren, aber es ist eine reine Interaktion mit GPT in dem Fall.
Social AI, ist wirklich sehr witzig und kostenlos.
Und da würdest du sagen, das verkümmert nicht einen?
Das verkümmert einen total, aber man kriegt halt auch noch ein paar Informationen geliefert.
Achso. Aber kann man nicht jetzt eher was empfehlen, was außerhalb dessen stattfindet?
Also wäre nicht die Empfehlung?
Ja, wir sagen ja, wir sollen alle in die Oper gehen.
Okay.
Also wir sind schon, unsere Leute sind ja schon auf dem richtigen Track.
Aber du hast natürlich recht, deswegen enden wir dieses Segment hier mit Thomas Fuchs.
Also sein Vortrag leider, also jemand hat mir geholfen, also jemand hat mich
darauf hingewiesen, ich habe jetzt den Namen leider nicht parat dann habe ich
zurückgemeldet, die hat leider keine Tonspur, das Video woraufhin er Thomas Fuchs selbst anschrieb
mir den Vortrag zu schicken, das heißt ich habe das Vortragsmanuskript,
das werden wir uns dann nochmal anschauen,
leider kann man nicht so gut Clips draus machen, sonst hätten wir jetzt hier
diese Clips gespielt, wir hören also nur zwei Clips, die aber auch ein bisschen
in diese Richtung gehen Thomas Fuchs ist beim WDR 5 auf philosophischen Radio
zu Gast und redet dort über Körperlichkeit der Gefühle.
Das Gehirn nimmt das alles auf, sendet sozusagen ständig auch Signale an den
Körper zurück und so entsteht ein Rückkopplungskreis, der in Sekundenbruchteilen, wie gesagt,
abläuft und unser Gefühl ausmacht.
Also zu denken, wir könnten den Körper uns quasi wegdenken, das wäre ein Irrtum.
Das ist schon eine Erkenntnis, die auf William James zurückgeht,
dem berühmten amerikanischen Psychologen, der einmal sehr schön geschrieben hat.
Wenn wir uns ein Gefühl vorstellen, wie etwa Angst oder Scham und uns dies ein
bisschen hineinfühlen.
Und uns dann vorstellen, dass alle körperlichen Empfindungen dabei wegfallen,
dann bleibt nichts anderes übrig als ein kalter, kognitiver Zustand von intellektueller Wahrnehmung.
Interessanterweise ist das, was die kognitive Psychologie heute unter Gefühlen
versteht, diesem rein kognitiven,
rein gedanklichen, fast so ein bisschen rationalen Zugang ganz ähnlich.
Also auch die kognitive Psychologie betrachtet den Körper eigentlich höchstens
als ein bisschen ein Add-on sozusagen.
Also ein Zufälls vielleicht. Ja, man muss natürlich ein körperliches Wesen sein, um fühlen zu können.
Aber dass das alles in Form einer Resonanz, wie ich es nenne,
ständig im Körper mitschwingt, mit vibriert sozusagen, sagen,
das ist der kognitiven Psychologie relativ fremd.
Ja, und das ist diese Trennung, die Mark Zuckerberg und all die anderen vornehmen.
Körper und Geist werden voneinander einfach losgekoppelt.
Das ist ja auch etwas, was die Philosophin Elisabeth List kritisiert.
Und nur unter diesen Prämissen dann auch, also kann so eine Technologie zur
Verkümmerung menschlicher Beziehungen
entstehen, weil man genau das Ganze nicht mehr in den Blick nimmt.
Ja, wir hören gleich noch einen zweiten Clip, in dem nochmal so ein kleiner
Bogen zur KI gesponnen wird.
Also es ging um den DGPPN-Kongress. Ich könnte jetzt GPT fragen,
was es heißt, aber wie auch immer.
Da fand dieser Vortrag statt und mir geschrieben hat daraufhin Maximilian,
der selber in dieser DGPPN-Dingslandessprecher von Hessen ist.
Also wir haben es hier sozusagen mit Fachleuten zu tun, die uns,
weil das klingt ja im Radio immer so, ja ist auch schön, dass er das so sagt
und so, aber nein, das ist sozusagen jahrzehntelange nicht nur Forschung,
sondern auch der Psychiatra oder der Psychologe ist ja immer involviert in seiner
Therapie, deswegen der ganze Supervisionskram und auch ein paar Verirrungen
mit Psychoanalyse und so. ich sage jetzt Verirrung, du kannst das gerne und so.
Also wir haben es wie bei Stefanie Stahl, da kann man das ja auch nachhören
im Allesgesagt-Podcast.
Immer mit Menschen in diesen Problemlagen, die da zu klären sind und so weiter, zu tun.
Von daher dürfen die immer von sich auch sagen, sie seien Philosophen.
Das ist sozusagen eine Zutat. Das ist nicht eine Abwertung der wissenschaftlichen
Anteile, die da stattfinden, sondern das ist sozusagen das kleine Mehr,
das wir heute umso mehr brauchen,
je mehr wir uns von diesem Leib-Seele-Problem, um mal diese alte Losung zu verwenden,
entfernen, indem Max Zuckerberg einfach kommt und sagt, nee,
nee, du brauchst nur den Geist, nicht den Körper.
Es reicht völlig, wenn dir irgendwas vorgegaukelt wird.
Er bewegt sich wie ein Mensch. Er muss ein Mensch sein. Nee,
wenn es kein Mensch ist, ist es kein Mensch.
Thomas Fuchs hier nochmal über diese Ganzheitlichkeit, mit der das zu betrachten ist.
Hinter der kognitiven oder,
kognitionswissenschaftlichen Psychologie steht natürlich auch immer noch so
ein Computermodell des Geistes.
Der Geist ist irgendwo im Gehirn ein funktionales System,
heute würde man sagen aus Algorithmen gebildet, die da ablaufen und in diesem
System laufen die Informationsverarbeitungsprozesse ab, die dann auch für Emotionen
die zentrale Rolle spielen.
Und dieses Computermodell ist natürlich das Gegenteil von dem,
was ich Verkörperung nenne,
also der Gedanke, dass alles, was wir erleben, den gesamten Organismus erfordert,
damit wir es überhaupt erleben können.
Ich kann das gerne noch ein bisschen erläutern, warum das dann so ist,
aber lassen wir es mal dabei als Gegensatz.
Entweder eine Computervorstellung vom Gehirn als Träger unseres Erlebens oder
ein verkörpertes Konzept, in dem wir immer als ganze leibliche,
spürende Wesen reagieren, wahrnehmen, uns bewegen, handeln, sogar denken.
Ja, also wir haben eine ganz interessante...
Die Erfahrung hat jeder selber gemacht. In der Schule durfte man irgendwann
die Taschenrechner benutzen.
Und jeder hat sofort verstanden, der Taschenrechner kann mehr und schneller als ich rechnen.
Und im Grunde ist die Auseinandersetzung mit Text jetzt erstmal nicht viel anders.
Irgendwann wird ja auch mit Buchstaben gerechnet und so. Man hat nur noch mit
so Ideen von Rechnungen zu tun und gar nicht mehr mit 1 plus 1 ist 2 und so.
Sondern da wird ja, es ist im Grunde eine Sprache, die etwas,
du hast ja auch schon mal diese eine Fernsehsendung da gelobt,
die mathematischen Probleme irgendwie
nochmal runterbricht auf leichter Verständlichkeit, wie auch immer.
So, das heißt, wir haben jetzt Taschenrechner für Text.
Also in ein Archiv zu gehen und dort alles durchzuarbeiten, dann die notwendigen
Übersetzungsleistungen herzubieten
und es noch zu strukturieren nach Gliedergesichtspunkten, die ich vorgebe.
Das ist einfach eine Leistung, die ich gerne entgegennehme.
Da sitze ich an meinem Schreibtisch, sage allen, ich arbeite,
Ich will hier nicht gestört werden.
Ich bin im Gespräch mit einem Computer, der mir Texte ausrechnet, sozusagen.
Also einfach durchkalkulieren, welche von diesen 100 Millionen Textangeboten,
sagen wir mal 2 Millionen Bücher, so Uni Bielefeld-Style, welche bräuchte ich denn jetzt hier?
Und dann ist einfach so ein Bibliothekar, der legt mir die so hin und dann ist
ein Übersetzer da, der mir eine gesicherte Übersetzung gibt und dann habe ich
noch so einen Assistenten, der genau weiß, was ich will und dem sage ich,
ordne mir mal alles zu dieser Überschrift irgendwie untereinander,
ich brauche nur die Zitate.
So, und das passiert innerhalb von drei Minuten und es liegt alles da und ich
schreibe mein Buch und denke mir, die Leute werden mich wahrscheinlich fragen,
hat das Buch Claude geschrieben, jetzt wurde so viel von Claude geschrieben
und sie sagen, nee, Claude kann alles, was ich gerade beschrieben habe, außer den finalen Text.
Das ist sozusagen die Autorenleistung. So, aber alles andere,
da ist schon ganz schön viel los.
Nur, man darf sich nicht verirren lassen, dass das für das, was wir als sozialen
Teil, also Mathematik, Text, Sozialität, für den sozialen Teil nützt es uns gar nichts.
Also wir können weder proben, wie wir ein Beziehungsgespräch führen.
Noch können wir irgendwelche Weihnachtsbotschaften wegautomatisieren,
indem wir Serienbriefe, die sich aber trotzdem unterscheiden,
obwohl wir gar nicht sozusagen ein Makro haben, in dem wenn wir nur den Namen
des Ansprech, also der Adresse austauschen, sondern es ist für die,
eigentlich sozial relevanten Sachen nicht zu gebrauchen.
Aber, und das finde ich, ist jetzt vorteilhaft, weil nämlich die Soziologie
immer so diese Frage bekommen hat, also Pädagogik und Psychologie haben sich
da nicht genommen oder was? Also hast du so aus Verlegenheit Soziologie gemacht?
Ah ja, Wissenschaft des Menschen, ne des Menschen, hey, wie,
was und so? Ist das nicht eigentlich Zoologie für Menschen? Wie auch immer, ja?
Also es gibt ganz viele Verirrungen und jetzt stellen wir plötzlich fest, Nee, es wird jetzt...
Richtig rausgeschärft, wir werden es richtig erleben, was Sozialität bedeutet.
Wo die Eigenrechte sind, wo die generativen Mechanismen sind,
wie Irritationen funktionieren, was auch immer.
Ja, denn all diese Fragen am attraktivsten ist und am erfolgreichsten auf dem
Datingmarkt ist, wer am besten rechnen kann. Nee.
Wer am besten Schach spielen kann. Nee. Wer am besten Texte aus Bibliotheken
raussuchen kann. Nee. Also das sind ja alles nicht die Sachen, auf die es ankommt.
Also für berufliche Zusammenhänge super.
Organisation super. Für sehr viele Sachen super.
Außer für das, wo wir die größte Lücke in unserem Alltag haben.
Ja, das Zwischenmenschliche. Das, was Mark Zuckerberg und den vielen anderen,
wie wir sie auch in den Podcasts erleben, auf den Bühnen sehen,
abhandengekommen ist oder nie vorhanden war.
Ja, die sind ja schon verkümmert als Wille und Ehre. Wir haben es ja beschrieben.
Wenn du alles immer nur delegierst, dich nirgendwo reinknien musst,
sondern immer sagen kannst, ah nee, jetzt habe ich keine Lust mehr.
Ich gehe, mach das alleine. Und du kannst dich darauf verlassen,
dass sie es alleine machen, weil sonst entziehst du denen einfach eine Milliarde Euro Budget.
Das ist halt kein, die sind sozusagen schon verkümmert, weil sie dachten auch
für sich selber, man kann das Problem so lösen.
Und wahrscheinlich wird es auch eine große Zurückwendung geben in irgendeinem
buddhistischen Yoga-Kram oder so, wo Menschen sich aber jetzt richtig begegnen wollen.
Ja, muss es ja gar nicht geben, sondern man kann ja auch so zwischenmenschliche
Beziehungen wertschätzen oder erkennen, wo sie sind oder wo auch die Schwierigkeiten
liegen bei zwischenmenschlichen Beziehungen.
Ich möchte noch einmal, weil ich schon das erwähnt habe.
Einmal empfehlen, nachdem wir jetzt so viel von den Companions und so gehört
haben, sich dieses Duett anzuhören zwischen Reinhard May und Helene Fischer, wir.
Das ist ja ein Lied, das davon handelt, dass man eigentlich sich in einer Beziehung befindet.
Also dieses Lied beginnt mit den Worten, deswegen habe ich das hier mal rausgesucht.
Heimkehr in wohlbekannten Wegen.
Ich schließe die Wohnungstür auf, sie kommt mir kaum noch je entgegen,
schaut kaum von ihrer Arbeit auf und es gibt nichts zu sagen und da sind keine
Fragen und auch keine Antwort darauf.
Also man lebt eigentlich zusammen, aber lebt dann doch nicht zusammen.
Und dieses Lied ist der Frage gewidmet, ob es doch funktionieren mag.
Warum, heißt es dann sehr viel später, geht Leben miteinander nur mit so viel
Leiden einher? Warum ist der Weg zueinander?
Warum der erste Schritt so schwer? Es ist so leicht zu kränken und so schwer einzulenken.
Ich liebe sie so sehr. Reinhard May ist ja der große Liedermacher der Liebesbeziehungen,
auch die eine lange Bestandszeit haben.
Während jetzt jemand wie Konstantin Wecker auch das erotische Abenteuer sehr
beschreibt und auch plastisch beschreibt. Ja, da geht es mitten hinein in das
Erotische, in die Wolllust.
Ist jetzt Reinhard May jemand, der die Liebe beobachtet, wie sie mit den Jahren sich ändert?
Es gibt ein ganz wunderbares Liebeslied von ihm, wie vor Jahr und Tag.
Sowieso Reinhard May hören kann eigentlich nicht schaden. Und das sind eigentlich
die zwischenmenschlichen Fragen, die Reinhard May in seiner Musik artikuliert,
die jemanden wie Zuckerberg vollkommen abhandengekommen sind und die auch kein Companion lösen kann.
Hier ist zwischen den beiden, was dann im Lied beschrieben wird,
kein Companion-Problem. Da brauchen die nicht mal eine lustige Comic-Figur, die es lösen kann.
Und da zeigt sich dann eigentlich, worauf es ankommt.
Und deshalb nochmal meine Empfehlung, Und unbedingt dieses Duett sich anhören.
Und da will ich auch noch ein Lied, also du weißt schon, ich will es nur noch
kurz erwähnen, dass es das auch gibt.
Aber du darfst jetzt nicht André Rieu sagen.
Nein, nein, nicht André Rieu, es hat Text. Vorher aber den Hinweis,
es gibt von Niklas Luhmann eine Textsammlung zum Thema die Moral der Gesellschaft.
Es ist aber keine durchgeschriebene Monografie und ist auch Posthum erschienen
und so weiter. Und da gibt es einen Text zur Moral, der ungefähr 100 Seiten
lang ist, also hätte auch ein eigenständiges sein können.
Weil ich den Verdacht habe, dass einige jetzt irgendwie hören und sagen,
also so wie ihr über die Millionäre und Milliardäre, nur weil man eine Milliarde
Euro hat oder 400, heißt das ja noch nicht, dass man deswegen asozialer Mensch ist.
Und genau diese Aufklärung ist zu machen, weil es heißt doch.
Und zwar allein aus dem Umstand, dass man so viel Geld hat.
Und man kann sich da auch nicht gegen wehren. Also man wird einfach in dem Moment
ein asozialer Mensch, was besonders interessant ist, weil niemand so viel Kontakt
zu Menschen hat, wie so ein Millionär.
Nur das Problem ist, in Interaktion, also in das, was wir gerade reingedrickst
werden, als das Wichtigste auf der ganzen Welt, du und dein Handy,
das ist nur 80 Zentimeter und das ist die ganze Welt und alles ist da zu lösen.
Wenn jemand sagt, schreibe einen Antrag, wer macht sowas, geh in den Ortsverband,
hör, bist du bescheuert und so.
Alles muss mit dem Handy geklärt werden. Das heißt, dieser Nahbereich,
der wird, wenn er mit Menschen gestaltet wird, auf Augenhöhe gestaltet und das
Zauberwort hier lautet Achtung.
Und Achtung unterscheidet sich von Respekt, Reputation, wie auch immer,
all das, was man auch in Asymmetrie ausleben kann, Achtung eben nicht.
Also wenn der Chef reinkommt und unhöflich ist zu seiner Sekretärin,
dann kann die ihm das einfach vergelten.
Und da kann kein Arbeitsvertrag, keine Hierarchie, keine Aufgabenverteilung,
irgendetwas dagegen tun. Wenn Dienst nach Vorschrift ist, ist Dienst nach Vorschrift.
Und so viel wie auszugleichen wäre, kann man gar nicht in den Arbeitsvertrag oder so schreiben.
Dann funktioniert es einfach nicht. Also dann muss einfach Personal ausgetauscht werden.
Das Personal kann aber nur einer austauschen, der Chef. Also es gibt keine Sekretärin,
die einen Chef austauscht, wenn sie ihn nicht mag. Das ist ja genau diese Asymmetrie.
Auch wenn er dann kommt und sagt, ich hab meinen Dienstwagen stehen lassen,
dann wird er ein bisschen angelacht, aber mehr passiert dann nicht.
Was bedeutet diese Achtung?
Augenhöhe, taktvolles Verhalten und so weiter und so fort, zwingend an Interaktion
gebunden, also da braucht man weder Formatstruktur noch Hierarchie,
da wird es ja aussortiert.
Es geht ja dann darum, wie kann man eine Organisation gestalten,
obwohl sich nicht immer alle die ganze Zeit begegnen und trotzdem wissen müssen,
was ist jetzt Phase und dann hat man normale Organisation oder das Militär,
da wird dann sogar der Gruß geregelt.
Der Junge salutiert natürlich zuerst und wenn dieses Salut nicht kommt,
dann sagt der Chef später, der hat nicht salutiert, der muss diszipliniert werden.
Also man kann es unterbrechen bis auf alles mögliche, aber die Interaktion selbst muss gelingen.
So, und in diesem Kapitel von Niklas Luhmann wird ausgebreitet,
wie die Achtungsbedingungen, die auf Augenhöhe in einer Gesellschaft,
ich kenne ja dann andere Länder, andere Sitten und so, aber die bei uns so gelten,
wie die wie soll man sagen, aufsummiert, abstrahiert werden auf Moral.
Also die Moral ist die Summe dieser Achtungsbedingungen. Das heißt,
wenn wir über Moral reden, im Fernsehen irgendwie das Moralische,
keine Ahnung und so weiter, dann geht es immer darum,
wie auf Augenhöhe in Interaktion miteinander kommuniziert wird.
Also ist Gesellschaft einfach ausgeblendet.
Und über der Moral steht dann nur noch die Ethik, also das Gespräch,
das reflektive Gespräch über die Moral.
Und das Problem ist, wenn du Milliarden Euro hast, begegnen dir die Leute nicht
auf Augenhöhe, weil dann einfach das Achtungsprinzip nicht gilt,
Du bist immer in diesem Respekt drin.
Ja.
Dadurch, wir haben es ja beschrieben anhand der Milliardärsinteraktion,
die ich dieses Jahr hatte,
da du immer schlummernd, das hat ja Julia Friedrichs auch, ich konnte das irgendwie
nicht loswerden, das Gefühl, ja, weil du immer denkst, ey, ich schreibe jetzt
ein Buch, dafür kriege ich so und so viel Geld, dann arbeite ich da,
kriege ich so und so viel Geld.
Der Typ könnte mir einfach Geld für 20 Leben überweisen.
Ja.
Der hat mein Schicksal komplett in der Hand. Also wenn ich jetzt nicht nett zu dem bin.
Das wird Schluss. Ja.
Dann ist er einfach vorbei. Der entzieht bei meinen Budgets,
der hat da Macht, keine Ahnung und so weiter und so fort.
Also Milliardäre können, außer mit Milliardären, keine Achtungsbeziehungen herstellen.
Was sie in große Gefahr bringt, verasozialisiert zu werden. Und das sehen wir bei Elon Musk.
Und jetzt wieder mal ein Plädoyer von ganz am Anfang dieses Podcasts.
Es sind alles normale Menschen.
Auch Elon Musk ist, was das angeht, noch ein normaler Mensch.
Und wenn ihm keiner auf Augenhöhe begegnet und er nicht mal soziale Beziehungen
mit den Frauen, die ihm Kinder zeugen, Sondern er da einfach so elf hat.
Also dann ist einfach vorbei, ja. Da muss man sich auch nicht mehr wundern.
Da ist auch nichts mehr zu hinterfragen, sondern das ist einfach so.
Und das steht in diesen alten Büchern.
Und das, was da drin steht, stimmt einfach.
Und wenn Journalisten sowas nicht verstehen, sondern uns dann irgendwie in Kurzmeldung,
er hat jetzt dazu aufgerufen und hier und da und so.
Nee, also bei Elon Musk ist jetzt einfach...
Wir sehen, wohin es führt.
Ja.
In vielen Bereichen. Und deswegen müssen diese Ideen von, wir tauschen hier
mal Sozialität aus, ach wozu echte Menschen, nee, es reicht doch,
wenn du hier mit irgendwelchen Bots und so weiter, das ist wirklich keine, keine, keine Lösung.
Wir müssen die Reichen vor ihrem Geld beschützen. Nochmal zum Schluss der Hinweis,
wir treffen uns im neuen Jahr,
dann im Salon wieder, sprechen über das Buch Explosive Moderne von Eva Illus,
erschienen bei Surkamp über die Schlüsselgefühle unserer Zeit.
Das wird sicherlich eine Diskussion, die auch auf Grundlage der jetzt hier gehörten
Dinge aus dem Silicon Valley stattfindet.
Ich habe sonst noch sehr viel offen, was ich besprechen werde.
Was ich aber schon ankündigen kann, ist, dass eine sehr umfangreiche Karl Lagerfeld
Biografie bei seinem Hausverlag Steidl erschienen ist.
Diese Biografie die stammt von William Middleton, heißt Paradise Now und die
werde ich jetzt in den nächsten Tagen verschlingen und dann vorstellen.
Das Interessante bei dieser Biografie ist, dass hier vor allem der kulturelle
Lagerfeld in den Mittelpunkt gerückt wird. Also was hat er gelesen?
Womit hat er sich beschäftigt?
Wie hat die Kunst ihn geprägt? Was ist seine Prägung für die Welt?
Also es geht jetzt nicht so sehr darum, nur durchs Schlüsselloch zu blicken.
Hast du auch schon was auf dem Schirm?
Ich habe einiges auf dem Schirm, aber die Empfehlung, ich wollte ja noch eine Musik kurz ansprechen.
Also wir lesen dann im Salon, was wir im Salon lesen. Ich weiß,
dass in meiner Liste schon so ein paar Sachen sind, aber ich möchte drauf kommen.
Helene Fischer hat ja nun, du hast es vorhin schon angesprochen,
auch das Udo Jürgens Stück Merci Cherie gesungen.
Und zwar vor ihm. Er hat seine 80 Jahre Gala gehabt im ZDF und sie hat es für ihn quasi gesungen.
Es waren auch Leute anwesend und man kann es heute noch auf YouTube schauen.
Es ist eines der am schönsten vorgetragenen von eh schon schönen deutschen Schlagern.
Ja, es ist ein sehr schönes Lied.
Und inhaltlich, Merci, Chérie, es ist ein Lied des Abschieds.
Es ist sozusagen die Auflösung einer sozialen Verbindung.
Es ist ein Lied vom Ende mit der Botschaft, Ende heißt nicht schlimm.
Man kann sich auch, du hast jetzt gerade Texte vorgelesen von Reinhard May,
also bei Merci Cherie ist einfach nur, er sagt halt, danke und es war schön.
Mehr gibt es nicht zu sagen. Also der Text erschöpft sich relativ schnell.
Ja, der Text ist relativ kompliziert, wenn man genau analysiert.
Die Liebe ist tiefer als die Meere oder irgendwie.
Ja, ja.
Nichts ist so stürmisch.
Ein bisschen wer spricht da eigentlich mit wem, fragt man sich.
Ja, genau. Also man kann es sich durchaus mehrfach anhören und immer wieder neue Sachen entdecken.
Aber diese beiden Helene-Fischer-Sachen, wir sind hier durchaus open-minded.
Wir sagen, Helene Fischer hat da sehr gute Sachen.
Ich werde mir das natürlich gleich heute noch anhören, was du da empfohlen hast.
Unbedingt. Dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Das ist, wie die das schon wissen,
Die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen.
Wir freuen uns natürlich darüber, wenn Leute in den Salon kommen.
Das ist möglich über Apple, wenn man schon da ist. Es ist ein bisschen teurer
dort wegen der Apple-Gebühr. Geht auch über Patreon.
Wir empfehlen Steady. Einfach auf neue20er.de gehen. Dort oben ist ein goldener Button.
Dann kommt man gleich zu Steady. Es ist selbsterklärend. Man kann den Podcast
dann überall hören. Etwa drei Stunden dauert der Salon oder manchmal auch ein bisschen länger.
Wir sprechen über ein Buch ausführlich und empfehlen außerdem dann insgesamt zehn Texte.
Wir freuen uns auf neue Zugänge und wünschen allen einen guten Rutsch.
Guten Rutsch.